Endlich wird alles gut!
Endlich wird alles super! Aber so richtig ist der Titel Freak Show jetzt für uns nicht mehr legitim, würde ich sagen.
Warum?
Du meinst, es gibt jemanden, der größeren Freak ist?
Tim muss erstmal Audio fixen. Die Freak Show da draußen, da sehen wir altgegen aus, würde ich sagen.
Ich stimm in der Jugend.
Du erst. Also es ist wirklich jeden Tag von früh bis spät. Du kannst ja nichts mehr aufmachen, du hast gar nicht so viele Hände, wie du Face palm möchtest. Und also Freaks sind wir dagegen doch jetzt wohl.
Da sind die Hände nicht groß genug, um so viel zu palmieren. Was soll man machen? Aber immerhin, der Mac wird wieder great again. Ich auch. Ich bin immer noch in diesem vollkommen absurden Zustand, dass ich schon so lange mir keine neue Hardware mehr kaufen will, weil die Attraktivität nicht ausreicht.
Ja, also ich mein, haben wir jetzt ja jede Folge quasi das Thema. Ich kriege jetzt demnächst hier so ein ganz, also hier auch so einmal. Ja, dauert halt, weil ich ein US International Keyboard bestellt hab. Dauert länger.
Ernsthaft? Ja, das sind ausländische Keyboards, die dürfen jetzt hier nicht einfach so rein.
Insofern kriege ich ja jetzt neue Hardware, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich mich da so richtig nachreißen würde und schon denke so, wann kommt sie, wann kommt sie, wann kommt sie endlich?
Also früher wäre ich, wenn mir jemand geschrieben hat, dein MacBook ist da, sofort ins Büro gefahren, hätte dieses Ding geholt, so dachte ich mir Freitag, ach nee, jetzt noch mal da hinfahren. Das reicht, wenn ich da am Dienstag dann bin und das entgegennehme.
Traurige Zeiten.
Dass ihr das nicht boykottiert.
Was? Das Keyboard. Ich hab mir auch eine externe Kabel mit einem Numpad und so Oldschool-Tastatur noch dazu bestellt. Brauche ich natürlich einen Adapter für, aber... Das Thema attackiere ich, wenn ich dann das Gerät vor mir sitze.
Das ist aber eine gute Frage. Wie lange dauert das, bis die Tastaturen, die USB-Tastaturen, die verkaufen ja fast eh.
Nur noch die Bluetooth-Tastaturen haben?
Das ist ja ein Bluetooth-Teil.
Ja, aber du lädst die und du kannst ja auch über dieses Lightning-Kabel betreiben. Richtig. Aber was ist die andere Seite von dem Lightning-Kabel?
Also USB-A.
Gibt es aber so Kabel.
Gibt es alles, genau.
Aber nicht von Apple?
USB-C auf Lightning, klar.
Sicher?
Lang und kurz.
Verkaufen Sie es oder erstellen Sie es auch her?
Ach so, ich glaube, das war das von denen selbst. Was sie nicht verkaufen, ist Ethernet auf USB-C.
Ja, was ich auch nur so eingestellt nachvollziehen kann.
Wer hatte doch gleich noch so mit Werf diesen neuen Anschluss verteidigt?
Tim, Dennis war doch auch dafür.
Nee, ich bin voll für all USB-C. Das darf schon passieren.
Abgesehen davon, dass du dir kein neues Gerät kaufst.
Aber es liegt ja nicht am USB-C, sondern an den Cursor-Tasten und am Escape.
Richtig. Mehr noch an den Cursor-Tasten als am Escape, muss ich zugeben, aber die Summe ist sozusagen schwierig.
Ich hab letztens gedacht, wenn sie so eine Taptic-Engine unter dem Escape-Key gebaut hätten, dann wäre es vielleicht auch noch erträglicher gewesen. Aber so dieses nicht-taktile Feedback...
Kommt noch ein Problem dazu. Wenn du in deinem VIA-Code so ein paar Sekunden nachdenkst, in der Zeit geht das Touchbar ja aus. Weil es ja auch so ein Screensaver war, sagen wir mal. Und dann denkst du, ach, ich bin ja noch hier im Insert-Mirror. Jetzt drücken wir erst mal Escape. Passiert da nichts, weil beim ersten Drücken geht erst mal nur dieses Ding an.
Ach du Scheiße.
Ach so, man tappt das überhaupt erst mal alive?
Also auch wenn du einen Netzkabel dran hast.
Donald Trump wird es richten. Der ruft da an.
Makes a keyboard great again.
Genau. Magic war gestern, jetzt kommt Bigly.
Ja, wie gesagt, externe Tastatur die meiste Zeit. So ein Capslock-Remap werde ich glaube ich nicht machen.
Habe ich schon gemacht, habe ich aber noch nie benutzt, weil es geht irgendwie noch nicht so.
Und die Taste, die kann man hier oben nicht remappen, mit Apple-Bondmittel, da braucht man eine extra Tool.
Okay, also es gibt ein Apple-USB-C-Aufleit-Ding-Kabel, das ist schon offiziell.
Für nur 25 Euro.
Bei zwei Metern 35 Euro, ist doch klar. Also so ein Meter-Kabel kostet schon 10 Euro.
Das sind auch die, die nicht billiger geworden sind natürlich. Weil die brauchen wir ja nicht unbedingt, weil wenn man sich jetzt so ein iPhone 7 holt, man kann es halt einfach nicht anschließen mit dem Kabel, was dabei ist. Ich finde das schon ein bisschen lame.
Na gut, immerhin unser Podcast bleibt auch vorerst weiterhin great, was auch immer das heutzutage noch bedeuten mag. Kleine Vorstellungsrunde, kompakt besetzt mit Roddy, mit Huckel, mit Dennis, mit Letti und unten mit Icke. Wie ihr so sagt.
Mit meiner einer.
Tonstudio Timme.
Ja, nur etwas lediert, aber geht schon.
Hm, noch kurz zu dem Adapter-Ding. Ich hatte ja so ein Bild gepostet von dem Spritzbesteck hier von dem Kollegen. Dann kann ich ja nochmal hier den Link von dem Tweet in den Chat packen, damit das alle Leute auch nochmal sehen können. Was war jetzt hier der Freak Show-Kanal in Ami-Community?
Welches Adapter-Ding? Ach, das Beutelchen. Ach, das Spritzbesteck des digitalen Apple-Nomaden.
Genau. Und es hatten halt ganz viele gefragt, welche Firma dieses Produkt herstellt. Und der gute Kollege hat das auch... Oh, was ist denn das für ein Link?
Ich hab schon einen prefilled oder was?
Nee, aber irgendwie, ich weiß nicht, der Link geht bei mir gerade nur so halb. Das ist ein von Bag Smart. Universi... Reisekasten. Universiöler Elektronikzubehör Reisekasten. Ach, eine schöne Beschreibung.
Gibt es das auch mit CSS, diese Seite?
Keine Ahnung, warum das da kaputt ist bei Amazon. Aber wenn ihr danach sucht, werdet ihr das trotzdem finden. Naja, auf jeden Fall, genau, für alle die, die dann auf Twitter noch fragten und denen ich nicht antwortete, hier ist die Antwort.
Die Antwort auf was jetzt nochmal genau?
Na, ich poste dieses Bild und die Leute wollten wissen, oh geil, was ist das, will ich haben.
Was hast du denn da jetzt alles drin?
Naja, er hat ja hier auf dem Foto, wie man sieht, nicht nur Adapter, sondern auch Kabel und er hat auch so ein...
Warte mal, ist das jetzt deine Tafel?
Nee, nee, nee, das ist von einem Kollegen. Der hat nämlich jetzt auch so ein MacBook Pro Air Quotes. Und das schleppt er sich halt dann immer mit. Und dann lag das da gerade offen, da hatte ich vorm Losgehen dann mal ein Foto von gemacht und hab's gepostet. Was seh ich denn da?
Was sehen wir denn da?
Das links oben, das schwarze, das kenn ich schon mal nicht. Das nächste ist ein normaler auf USB...
Genau. Ein Ethernet-Kabel, dann ist das Lightning wahrscheinlich.
Ja, normal USB auf Lightning.
Also C auf Lightning.
Genau. Dann USB auf Lightning.
Dann USB-C auf USB-A.
Ist das nicht ein Stecker?
Aber ist da keine Buchse?
Das hört in die andere Richtung. Das ist, wenn du so ein Samsung-Kabel umkaufst und das aber an einem normalen USB-Ladegerät laden willst. Weil die haben halt USB-C, die neuen Samsungs.
Könnte auch ein Mini sein, ja.
Dann USB-Stick ist drin. Dann rechts oben, das ist der Thunderbolt.
Ich glaube, der sieht so aus, ja. Ich glaube, den habe ich heute vorhin gerade noch in der Hand gehabt.
Und hier noch so ein komisches Karma.
Das sieht so nett aus. Mit dem Nupsee, der da einnupst.
Und dann da drunter könnte dann vielleicht so was wie HDMI sein. Der links oben ist so ein LTE-Schnuffi. Ich brauche jetzt mal Internet, weil irgendwie alles andere geht nicht. Und da hat er noch so sein LTE. Und ich mache einen Hotspot auf und so weiter. Schnuffi. Und das unten, weiß nicht, ob das jetzt einfach nur so noch Strom oder sowas. Keine Ahnung, genau.
Naja, was man halt alles so dabei hat.
Ich dachte mir, ich kaufe mir einfach so ein portables Dock vielleicht, was man dann immer daran klöppelt.
Hast du auf jeden Fall weniger Scheiß, den du mit dir rumschlägst.
Ja, und vor allem die Kabel brechen halt und so, ne?
Ja, aber wenn dir das Kabel an dem Dock bricht, dann ist das Dock im Eimer.
Die Docks sind halt auch günstiger als diese Horde Apple-Kabel.
Das stimmt auch, ja. Na gut, das wollte ich jetzt nur noch nachgetragen oder dazu getragen haben.
Ja, jetzt hatten wir ja eine Woche Pause.
Zwei?
Einen Monat mein ich.
Die andere Woche.
Ja, ich war eine Woche im Urlaub und also das...
Hab nicht geholfen, ich seh schon.
Wobei jetzt...
Deiner geistigen Verfassung.
Achso, nee, meine geistige Verfassung ist eigentlich weitgehend in Ordnung. Ich hab jetzt nur gerade hier mir so eine kleine Augenverdickung irgendwie eingefangen. Da leide ich gerade ein wenig, aber nur ein bisschen. Das ist nicht so wichtig. Und ansonsten habe ich mich mit extrem... Na ja, also stupid ist nicht ganz richtig, aber auf jeden Fall mit monotoner Tätigkeit beschäftigt, weil ich muss da gerade ein Problem fixen. Ihr wisst schon, das Steuerproblem.
Hast du ein Problem?
Hast du eine Prüfung oder was?
Nee, das noch nicht, aber es ist so...
Er hat jetzt den Brief bekommen, dass er für 2015 endlich mal abgeben muss.
Ja, ich will jetzt da nicht so sehr ins Detail gehen, nimmt es einfach als...
Hab ich auch bekommen.
Es gibt einiges aufzuholen. Und was ja alle gut nachvollziehen können, ist so dieses Ding... Also es gibt ja solche Momente, da ist es ja nur, ich muss es jetzt mal machen, aber es ist zumindest klar, was ich machen muss. Also da muss man einfach mal so den Arsch hochkriegen, und wenn man den dann irgendwann hochbekommen hat, dann ist gut, ne? Zeig doch mal Dennis kurz nochmal den... Guck mal hier, das hier ist die Rolls-Royce-Taste. Und das ist auch die Nougat-Schokolade-Schmatze. Ja, ja, ich weiß. Das wollen wir aber gar nicht wissen. Und deswegen hier, guck mal, da ist die Schmatztaste. Ja, ich wollte nur nochmal kurz auf die vorrangige Grundausstattung dieses Studios hinweisen. Ja, so, das ist, sagen wir mal, das eine. Das gehört ja so ein bisschen dazu. Dann hast du so Verschleppungseffekte und das Hauptproblem mit dem Verschleppungseffekt ist natürlich dieses, irgendwann hast du natürlich auch so ein bisschen den Kontakt zu verloren, zu was eigentlich tatsächlich wirklich so alles zusammengetragen werden muss. Ja, man weiß, man hat irgendwie so Mobilfunkrechnungen und so, aber es ist ja dann auch schon noch ein bisschen mehr. Und wenn du so halbwegs kohärent dieses Thema angehen willst, brauchst du natürlich vor allem erstmal selber einen Überblick und wenn man den nicht mehr hat, dann wird es haarig.
Aber heftest du nicht alles gleich immer ordnungsgemäß weg?
Wer macht es um?
Hm, guter Punkt.
Also ich hab tatsächlich damit mal vergleichsweise angefangen, zumindest die steuerrelevanten Sachen immer gleich irgendwie in den Ordner zu tun und seitdem ist es nicht mehr ganz so schlimm.
Na klar, wenn man das macht, ist es gut. Aber wenn man dann halt in so einer Mischung aus so einer Depression und ach, ich mach das dann später irgendwie und ich bau hier mal einen Stapel und dann ist doch wieder Freak Show und dann verschieben sich die Stapel so über Wochen und dann Monate und irgendwann Jahre, bis du dann also wirklich so einen 150.000 Teile Puzzle einer Wolke vor dir hast.
Die gute Akustik in der Meterebene kommt nämlich auch nicht durch akustische Elemente, sondern durch Wände von Papierstapeln zustande.
Naja, so und wir hatten das auch vor einiger Zeit schon mal angesprochen. Clemens hat das glaube ich ursprünglich mal aufgebracht. Daraufhin hatte ich mir ja schon mal diesen wunderbaren Scansnap X500 Scanner bekommen.
Diese staubige Kiste da hinten?
Diese leicht staubige Kiste, die allerdings nach wie vor, würde ich sagen, in meinem Ranking von tollster Hardware, die ich je gekauft habe, ziemlich weit oben ist.
Ja, aber mit beschissenster Software, die ich je in Betrieb genommen habe.
Ich habe im Bereich Scanner schon alles gesehen. Ich würde sagen, Scanner ist so die Computerkategorie, in der wirklich der größte Scheiß an Software überhaupt rumfliegt. Und das geht schon seit 20 Jahren so. Seit es Scanner gibt, sind Scanner. Scanner-Programme waren schon immer schlimm.
Wie hieß denn dieses Style-Party-Tool, was es dann immer auf Mac gab, diese, weißt du schon, diese...
Da gab es mehrere. Du sprichst jetzt irgendwas an, was ich mir wahrscheinlich erinnern müsste. Ja, so ein Klassiker. Also es gab immer mal wieder auch so Programme, die versucht haben, das so ein bisschen in den Griff zu bekommen. Dann gab es ja auch OS X, was es versucht hat, in den Griff zu bekommen. Und hier haben wir dieses Image-Capture-Interface. Und da dachte ich schon so, ach, jetzt wird alles gut. Alle Scanner, die auf den Markt kommen, werden jetzt dieses Interface unterstützen. Und alle Programme, die dieses Scanner-Interface unterstützen. Hoffnung, Hoffnung, Hoffnung, Hoffnung.
Enttäuschung, Enttäuschung, Enttäuschung.
Enttäuschung, Enttäuschung, Enttäuschung, Enttäuschung. Genau. Irgendwie geht es schon, ja. Aber eben auch nur so ein Stück weit. Und gerade wenn du halt so Scanner hast wie diesen X500, der ja nicht nur ein guter Scanner ist, sondern auch so Features hat, wie dieses doppelseitiges Scanning. Und auch ein sehr flexibles Erkennungsprotokoll für Papierstau und so. Also andere Scanner, also mit Einzug, ja, die scheitern dann halt einfach. Und dann hast du vielleicht so Error. Dann steht da so, ja, minus 1423. So war es, ne?
Silverfast heißt die Software.
Richtig, Silverfast. Das war mal The Silver Lining am Horizont und so. Das hat auch eine Weile geholfen. Aber das war ja auch noch so die Zeit als Scanner, dass man ja immer noch diese Flachbett-Dinger drauflegen und heutzutage in den papierlosen Bürozeiten hat man es ja mit unglaublichen Stapeln zu tun. Beziehungsweise, ich würde sagen, der Anspruch an Scanning ist halt ein anderer geworden. Und eigentlich sind wir jetzt in dieser Ära, wo man eben wirklich dieses, okay, es gibt noch dieses Papierinterface-Ding, aber es gibt jetzt ein Gerät, wo du das alles doch verhältnismäßig easy in deinen Rechner reingeschlupst bekommst. Selbst wenn es sich um größere Stapel von Zeug handelt. Also selbst wenn du es mal mit so einem 100 Seiten Konvolut-Doppelseitiger-Doku, die es nicht in digital gibt oder ein Buch oder sowas, wenn du es damit zu tun hast, gibt es jetzt die Hardware dafür. Und auch diese Treiber-Software, die ja jetzt auch gerade beim Wechsel auf Mac OS Sierra so ein bisschen in den News war, dass sie da, ich weiß gar nicht, wer da jetzt was verkackt hat, ob das irgendwie Apples PDF-Library war oder die oder beide, weiß ich nicht so ganz genau, scheint jetzt auf jeden Fall irgendwie gelöst zu sein. Ich hab dann auch diese Update-Kaskade gemacht und da muss ich dir dann auch wieder Recht geben. Eigentlich muss man die Scanner-Software nur beim Updaten zuschauen, dann weiß man schon etwa, was Sache ist. Das hab ich auch schon lange nicht mehr gesehen. Update, ja es gibt ein Update. Dann klickst du da irgendwie drauf, Webseite, da musst du irgendwas runterladen. Da hast du so einen Installer, den startest du. Da ist aber nicht alles drin. Sondern dieser Installer lädt dann selber eine Kaskade von fünf anderen Installer nach, die sich alle dann von der einen Installer der anderen Installer runtermountet, kopiert da irgendwie was raus.
Und jedes Mal musst du das Passwort eingeben.
Genau, du musst am laufenden Meter irgendwie ja, hier, ich brauch vollen Zugriff, sonst drei, zwei, eins, explodiert, alles. War dann auch irgendwann da.
Und irgendwann gab es dieses eine Update, wo sie dann so, ja, hier Update und so weiter. Dann klickst du das Update, und es ist das Update eigentlich nur ein Text, der dich irgendwie da drüber aufklärt, dass irgendwas jetzt wieder funktioniert. Aber er installiert nichts. Und du denkst so, hä? Sehen wir uns in zwei Wochen wieder mit dem nächsten Update?
Oder was ist jetzt so?
Ja, naja, also das ist auf jeden Fall dann Teil eins. Aber das ist ja auch erstmal nur ein reines Hardware-Ding. Das heißt, ich hab die Hardware und ich hab auch die Software, die zwar nicht schön ist, aber zumindest halbwegs beherrschbar und in ausreichendem Maße auch konfigurierbar ist, um also Zettel rein zu bekommen. Aber dann ist halt wieder die Frage, was, wie, wohin, wohin legst du das? Dann fängst du an zu scannen, dann hast du auf einmal so einen Ordner voll mit 300 Dateien, die irgendein Scandatum als Titel tragen und keinen Kontext, und dann umbenennen, und dann wirst du halt auch wahnsinnig, und dann mit Unterordnern, und dann hast du auch keinen Überblick und so. Und dann war dann irgendwie klar, ich brauch da so ein bisschen Overview. Und jetzt gibt es ja auch diverse Programme, die versuchen, das in Griff zu kriegen. Und da ist ja PDF eigentlich eine schöne Sache, weil vor allem, wenn es sich um Original-PDFs handelt, die also ordentlich generiert wurden und nicht durch Scannen, ohne OCR, bearbeitet wurden, da hast du ja auch schon viele Metadaten, kannst ordentlich drinsuchen und das ist alles schon mal ganz praktisch. Und dann habe ich so mal ein bisschen geschaut, was es denn eigentlich so gibt, was einem so dieses ganze Rechnungscannen irgendwie erträglich, also Rechnung einsammeln, erträglich machen kann. Und da gibt es ja tatsächlich so einige Programme. Und in dem Moment fiel mir dann wieder auf, dass ich ja eigentlich schon längere Zeit so in so einem Beta-Test war, den ich aber nie so richtig aufgenommen habe, weil ich dieses Problem immer von mir her geschoben habe. Und das fiel mir dann wieder ein. Dann hab ich das mal benutzt und dann siehe da. Es hatte in etwa das Feature Set, was ich brauchte. Und zwar handelt es sich dabei um ein Programm, was von jemand geschrieben wird, der auch hier schon mal zu Gast war vor längerer, längerer Zeit. Da muss ich gleich mal gucken, welche Sendung das war. Das hab ich jetzt natürlich vorher nicht rausgesucht. Lang ist es hier. Genau, Mobile Max 38.
Lang ist es hier.
Da wart ihr alle nicht dabei. Ich hab mit Max gemacht, nämlich der Dirk, der Holtwig. Und der hat halt ein Programmchen geschrieben für den Mac. Das heißt einfach Receipts. Und das ist, wie der Name schon so schön sagt, für, naja, Belege, Quittungen, Rechnungen, sowas halt. Und das Pfiffige ist, einerseits ist es halt ein ganz brauchbarer PDF-Organisator. Das heißt, du schmeißt da dein Kram rein. Aber er macht dann halt auch noch mehr. Und zwar guckt er halt erstmal, ist da überhaupt schon alles drin gescannt? Also es ist da drin alles OCR'd. Entschuldigung. Also ist sozusagen lesbarer Text vorhanden? Oder handelt es sich hierbei jetzt nur um Pixel? Wenn Pixel, dann wird intern automatisch ein OCR angeworfen, ohne dass man da irgendwas zu machen braucht. Und dann schaut sich dieses Programm auch noch dieses Dokument an und versucht daraus Schlüsse zu ziehen. Und das geht halt so weit, dass das Programm dann halt erkennt, so A, Rechnung, hier ist ein Gesamtbetrag, hier ist irgendwie Mehrwertsteuer, das suche ich doch mal alles mal raus und holt das so quasi gleich in so Metadaten rein. Und das funktioniert echt ziemlich knorke. Also es ist natürlich jetzt nicht frei von Fehlern, aber man kann wirklich so größere Teilmengen Rechnungskram da so reinwerfen und hat dann so den Vorteil, dass so kritische Informationen wie, welcher Betrag ist denn jetzt hier tatsächlich zu zahlen, automatisch schon mal raussucht. Beziehungsweise, wenn es keine klare Erkenntnis darüber gewinnen kann, welche dieser ganzen Zahlen denn jetzt hier vielleicht die Richtige ist, dann werden die zumindest so geheilertet und man kann halt einfach draufklicken und sagen, das ist es. Das heißt der normale Turnaround bei so einem gescannten Dokument ist dann halt doch relativ niedrig und man hat dann relativ schnell so eine brauchbare, gut durchsuchbare und ordentlich tabellierbare und natürlich auch exportierfähige Liste von Dokumenten. Und macht halt auch so allerlei Statistiken automatisch, sortiert einem das gleich schön nach den Jahren, sodass man dann halt schnell sehen kann, ah ja, ok, das und das und Belegdatum wird automatisch rausgesucht. Genau, hier sehen wir jetzt gerade auf dem Screen, könnt ihr natürlich nicht sehen da draußen, das ist einfach mal so ein typischer Post-Porto.
Tim hat 1,45 Euro verprasst für irgendeine Sendung mit der deutschen Post.
Ja, hier habe ich sogar noch über 0,05 Euro.
Ja, so macht man das, das ist sparsam.
Ja, auch so ein Zettel, wo man sich sonst sagen würde, da investiere ich doch gar nicht mal die Zeit, um die überhaupt auch nur zur Kenntnis zu nehmen. Hiermit kann man das halt einfach alles wunderbar machen. Und was auch sehr schön ist, man kann das Ding integriert sich auch ganz nice in Mail. Das heißt, du hast halt automatisch eine Rule und kannst sagen, wenn da eine E-Mail kommt, von Deutsche Telekom, wo Rechnungen drinsteht, dann wirft doch mal automatisch den Anhang in Receipts rein und dann landen sozusagen deine Telekom DSL Rechnungen automatisch schon in dem Programm, mit irgendwie gar nichts tun. Das ist richtig. Das werde ich mal kurz nachholen. Bei so generischen Begriffen muss man heutzutage immer noch App dahinter schreiben. So, dann kannst du noch dem Beleg, kannst du quasi so, wie heißt das noch, etwas holzig pro Viola, also quasi so wer hat diesen Beleg ausgestellt, zuordnen. Und wenn du dann das zweite Mal einen Beleg hast, der ähnlich aussieht, dann wird er auch automatisch zugeordnet. Also wenn du einmal deine Telekom DSL-Rechnung einmal so getaggt hast, als das ist eine Telekom-Rechnung, dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass wenn du die Zweite und Ente dahinter wirfst, dass das auch automatisch der Telekom zugeordnet wird, relativ hoch.
Was verbirgt sich hinter Bäckerei?
Hinter Bäckerei belegt sich ein Kaufbeleg einer Bäckerei. Muss man sich halt unterscheiden. Ich hab z.B. auch generisch irgendwie Taxi für eine Taxi-Quittung, weil ich jetzt wirklich kein Interesse hatte, jede einzelne Taxi-Unternehmen, wo ich mal Taxi gefahren bin, irgendwie aufzuführen. Aber auch gerade bei diesen Quittungen ist das dann halt sehr hilfreich, dass man dann eben auch noch ein Interface dafür hat, so Steuern usw. einzugeben. Da wird auch aktiv dran entwickelt. Man kann dann auch noch so taggen, also dass man das eben auch Projekten zuordnen kann und so. Also wenn du so später deine Reisekostenabrechnung machen willst, du hast halt irgendwie so N-Belege, die alle irgendwie zu deiner Reise gehören. Tags für die halt entsprechend und wenn du dafür dann mal eine Rechnung schreibst oder so, dann hast du ja halt auch mit einem Klick wieder auf dem Bildschirm. Das ist ganz praktisch, kannst du noch eine Notiz reinmachen und du kannst auch noch vermerken, wann es bezahlt wurde. Also hast du sozusagen auch dieses habe ich bezahlt-Ding auch noch gleich mit drin. Schonmal ganz praktisch. Also für Leute, die einfach Überblick über alle Ausgaben haben wollen, ist das schonmal cool, aber es ist eben auch eine hilfreiche Zuführung von Informationen, um dann letzten Endes eine Steuergeschichte auch erfolgreich zum Abschluss zu bringen. Kannst auch eine Belegnummer eingeben und am Ende gehst du dann einfach auf dein Ja und sagst so, ja hier für 2016 bitte mal alles mal exportieren. Und dann kannst du halt sagen, ok, machen wir da mal gleich eine Excel-Datei draus, wo das sozusagen gleich übergeben wird. Und du kannst halt auch alle diese ganzen PDFs in ein, also entweder einzeln alle exportieren, wenn du das haben willst, oder halt auch in ein einzelnes PDF noch mal reindrucken. Sodass du sozusagen an einem PDF alle Dokumente drin hast, schön sortiert nach Belegnummer, einmal abheften, zack, rein in den Ordner, ins Regal schieben, fertig aus, die Maus. Das wollte ich jetzt mal hier vorstellen, weil ich das eine sehr schöne Lösung finde. Ich weiß, es gibt auch noch ein paar andere Programme, die in dieselbe Richtung gehen, die ich mir jetzt aber noch nicht so intensiv angeschaut habe, weil ich jetzt hier voll in so einen Wahn reingekommen bin.
Kennt man gar nicht von dir.
Das ist immer was ganz Neues. Na ja, es hat halt natürlich zwei Gründe. Erstens tat es halt für mich jetzt genau das Richtige und B, da ich den Dirk halt kenne, habe ich mich dann gleich nochmal mit ihm kurzgeschlossen und bin halt jetzt wieder zum aktiven Beta-Tester geworden und werfe halt irgendwie täglich 10 Feature-Requests, die auch in einer bemerkenswerten Geschwindigkeit dann entstehen und so. Allein in den letzten zwei, drei Wochen doch viele, viele, viele spürbare weitere Verbesserungen gekommen mit More Great Things to Come. Also da wird der Mac great.
Ich muss die Software verlassen, sozusagen.
Na was heißt du, du musst die Software verlassen?
Den Mac great zu machen, meine ich.
Natürlich, klar. Letztlich ist es ja die Software, die alles great macht. Und an dieser Stelle ist das auch ein gutes Beispiel, wo ich auch finde, wo diese Idealvorstellungen wie eine Macintosh-Applikation sich zu verhalten hat und wie sie auszusehen hat, wie sie sich so anfühlt, wo man diesem Ziel mal wieder sehr nahe kommt.
Und man braucht keinen Adapter.
Das weißt du ja noch nicht.
Ja, okay für den Scanner.
Das war so der erste Teil. Weil Zettel sind ja nur das eine. Und du kriegst ja heutzutage eigentlich die allerwenigsten Dokumente tatsächlich auf Papier. Also dieses Scannen ist zwar so ein Aspekt davon, aber das meiste ist halt wirklich so dieses digital Einsammeln. Von daher macht es halt total Sinn, auch quasi vor allem ein digitales Archiv zu haben. Ausdrucken kann man es ja dann immer noch. Ich weiß, wenn du das Original auf Papier bekommen hast, dann musst du auch genau das hinterlegen und so. Aber da brauchst du jetzt auch eben nicht sehr viel mehr machen, als das Ding einfach in eine Kiste reinzulegen, wo die Jahreszahl drauf steht. Und das ballerst du dann auch noch zusammen. Und du hast es auffindbar. Also wirklich nur musst du den Beleg sozusagen nur so lange irgendwie würdigen, wie du ihn zum Scanner trägst und komm, dass er da einmal durchgelaufen ist, ist das Ding danach auch weg. Das ist so schön. Das ist so toll. Aber kommen wir mal zum Teil 2 des Problems. Also des Steuerproblems.
Man muss ihn noch bezahlen, die Steuer oder was?
Nee, nee.
Oder ist das Teil 3?
Ich meine, nur weil du Belege sammelst, hast du ja noch lange keine Steuererklärung. Also du musst ja sozusagen auch etwas kohärenter rangehen. Das ist bei mir ohnehin ziemlich erwusst, weil ich natürlich durch diese zahlreichen Einzelspenden, die so reinkommen und Events und Ticketverkäufe und Subscribe hier und Pipapo, also ich habe einfach unheimlich viel Durchlauf auf meinem Konto von so Kleinkramen. Und da halt einen Überblick zu finden, ist natürlich auch nicht so einfach. Ja, da habe ich dann auch nochmal tief durchgeatmet und habe so überlegt, wie kriegst du das in den Griff? Früher habe ich meinen ganzen Bankkram eine Weile mit diesem Outbank gemacht. Hatten wir glaube ich auch schon ein paar Mal drüber gesprochen. Die haben sich dann irgendwann total verrannt und haben dann versucht, in diesen frühen Tagen schon mit iCloud Syncing zu machen. Das ist dann irgendwie komplett in die Hose gegangen mit kaputten Datenbanken und haste nicht gesehen. Da war ich dann schon so ein bisschen angefressen. Aber ich habe ja Verständnis dafür, wenn Programmierer da ihre Probleme haben, insbesondere weil man ja auch weiß, dass das ja nicht unbedingt, du bist nicht nur die Schuld der Programmierer war, in diesen frühen iCloud Zuständen.
Ja, besonders wenn man diese Kombination aus Core Data und iCloud war immer sehr...
Genau, das war nämlich am Anfang dieses Dilemma. Mittlerweile, mit CloudKit und so, soll das ja alles sehr viel besser geworden sein. Zumindest sehe ich jetzt immer mehr Programme, die durchaus ihr Syncing auf die Backe kriegen, ohne größere Probleme. Ja, und dann habe ich halt überlegt, was machst du? Outbank war für mich so ein bisschen raus, weil die jetzt eben auch auf so ein Subscription-Modell sind und zweimal irgendwie schon so ihre Upbases gewechselt haben. Also dann hieß das irgendwie Outbank 2 und dann hieß es irgendwie wieder oder X oder Outbank. Keine Ahnung, ich habe da auch so ein bisschen den Überblick verloren.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, die haben ja noch eine iOS-App. Und diese iOS-App macht so den Kardinalfehler schlechthin. Sie meldet sich beim System an als ich will deine PDFs haben. Und das führt dann dazu, wenn du mit Safari irgendeinen PDF aufmachst, das wird dann im Browser angezeigt, dann gibt es normalerweise oben rechts diesen Button in iBooks öffnen und der ist dann weg, da steht dann in Outbank öffnen. Und ich weiß nicht, wie es dir geht, aber ich habe noch nie ein PDF in einer Banking-App aufgemacht. Seit PDF existiert habe ich noch nie ein PDF in einer Banking-App aufgemacht. Und ich werde das auch weiterhin nicht tun, deswegen habe ich Outbank einfach wieder gelöscht. Ich habe dem Support dreimal geschrieben, die haben dreimal gesagt, ja das ist nett, dass du uns schreibst, aber mach lieber irgendwo ein Ticket, irgendwo in irgendeinem System. Und dann war es mir zu doof und habe die App wieder gelöscht.
Aber das hatten wir ja in der Freak Show alles schonmal besprochen, dann wurde ja für Money Money große Werbung gemacht.
Genau, da wurde für Money Money große Werbung gemacht, und das mache ich jetzt auch gleich nochmal, weil ich habe dann auch Money Money nochmal so für mich neu entdeckt.
Ein zweiter Frühling.
Ein zweiter Frühling, genau, weil früher fand ich das eigentlich nur deshalb cool, weil es an sich schon mal charmant aussah, und weil es eben so schnell war. Also dieser HBCI-Protokoll-Stack, der in dem Programm läuft, der war ja schon immer richtig gut, also der war immer schön multithreaded, und der hat einfach performt. Du checkst irgendwie 10 Konten, du machst so bling, fertig. Nur PayPal dauert immer lange, aber das liegt glaube ich eher an PayPal. Aber es war eben nicht so eins nach dem anderen. Bei Outbank immer so, ja, jetzt kommt erst mal das erste Programm, und die erste Bank, und dann irgendwie irre Fehlermeldungen, die du überhaupt nicht erklären kannst und so. Mittlerweile bin ich natürlich ein Opfer dessen, dass ich nicht auf das Allerneueste Outbank gewechselt habe, aber so ist das halt nun mal. Wenn die App auf einmal eine andere App ist, aber behauptet, dieselbe zu sein, dann ist das natürlich ein Upgrade-Problem für die User. Das kann man jetzt nicht Outbank vorwerfen, weil das ist natürlich im App Store ohne Upgrade-Option ein Problem. Aber nichtsdestotrotz existiert dieses Problem. Dann hab ich mir MoneyMoney nochmal angeschaut und dann festgestellt, dass das Programm ja sogar noch besser ist, als ich dachte. Und vor allem, was ich ja auch nicht glaubte, ist, dass wirklich eine Homebanking-Software so der Ort ist, wo du den ganzen Kram auch sortieren möchtest. Vielleicht war das etwas ignorant von mir, ich weiß nicht, wie ihr das so macht.
Ich sollte da nicht groß in der App rum.
Genau, das hab ich nämlich auch nicht gemacht.
Ich auch nicht, dafür hab ich nicht genug Geld.
Naja, mit diesem nicht genug Geld, wenn man da halt irgendwie keinen Überblick hat, dann führt das ja dazu, dass man irgendwie nicht genug Geld hat. Also verspreche mir quasi auch von diesem ganzen Neuanfang, den ich da gerade mache, am Ende weniger Geld verlieren, also weniger Geld sinnlos ausgeben durch ein weniger undichtes Sieb, Mahngebühren, Säumniszinsen auf der einen Seite, aber eben auch Verpeilung im Allgemeinen oder eben auch einfach den Mangel an Kostenkontrolle, dass Dinge am laufenden Meter abgebucht werden und man überhaupt nicht so im Blick hat, was gebe ich eigentlich in diesem Bereich aus? Was investiere ich in X, was investiere ich in Y? Welchen Anteil hat das alles zueinander? Ist das vielleicht einfach mal eine Zahl, die einfach ridiculously high ist und wo man was dran machen sollte? Ja, dann habe ich aber festgestellt, dass man in Money Money halt auch echt cool so sortieren kann. Und dann habe ich halt angefangen, so die ganzen Kanten, Konten da reinzuschmeißen und festgestellt, dass alles, was ich benutze, da auch irgendwie problemlos supportet wird. Und dass man wunderbar auch mit so einer hierarchischen Kategorisierung arbeiten kann.
Ein Outliner.
Also du kannst halt wunderbar sowohl Gruppen von Konten bilden, aber du kannst halt auch Gruppen von deinen ganzen Buchungen machen. Und dadurch halt einfach super Überblick bekommen. Nach dem Motto, solange Dinge nicht einer Kategorie zugeordnet sind, sind sie quasi noch unbearbeitet. Also wenn du mit dem Ansatz rangehst, alles muss am Ende in einer Kategorie sammeln, stellst du sicher, dass du eben auch wirklich überall mal was zugeordnet hast und dass du eben von jedem Betrag auch weißt, der spielt hier auch eine Rolle. Also was ich zum Beispiel auch öfter mal habe, sind natürlich solche Scam-Abbuchungen. Weiß nicht, wie oft das bei euch vorkommt, aber wenn man so seine Kontodaten im Netz hat, dann ist das natürlich schon mal ein Problem. Sowas musst du halt irgendwie auch finden. Teilweise sind die ja auch sehr tricky, weil die komischen Abbuchungstexte drin sind, die dir vielleicht auf den ersten Blick gar nicht auffallen, aber so fällt dir das halt auf. Und was dann auch sehr schön ist, wenn man so mehrere Konten hat, also was weiß ich, hast du ein Girokonto da, dann machst du da nochmal so ein Online-Konto, weil du das für eine tolle Idee gehalten hast, um da irgendwas zu managen oder hast noch ein Shared-Konto mit jemand anderem. Und dann kommst du da so mit Tagesgeldkonten, um vielleicht mal doch den einen oder anderen Zinssatz, den es ja heutzutage nicht mehr gibt, abzugreifen. Und dann kommst du halt immer an dieses Problem, oh scheiße, kein Geld mehr auf dem Konto, da kommt gleich die Abbuchung, was machst du jetzt, schnell mal von dem Konto auf dem Konto. Und dann kommst du natürlich, was deinen Überblick betrifft, komplett in die Hölle, wenn du eben die ganze Zeit so Beträge hin und her buchst. Und was ich dann auch gesehen habe, bei Mani Mani ist es sehr schön, dass man eben auch sehr schnell so einen Überblick kriegen kann mit so Umbuchungen. Also erst mal schaffst du dir entsprechende Kategorien, aber du kannst halt dann auch schnell, wenn du, was weiß ich, von deinem Barbestand irgendwas umgeschaufelt hast oder auf irgendein anderes Konto, mal eben auch so zusätzliche Einträge machen. Du kannst irgendwie Buchungen auch in solche, kannst sie splitten und sagen, ja, das besteht aus dem Teil und dem Teil und dem Teil, wenn du dann gleich noch Mehrwertsteuer oder ähnliche Sachen machen willst. Und vor allem, du kriegst dann eben für alles auch wunderbar so einen Überblick. Und das ist schon ziemlich cool, weil du klickst halt einfach irgendeine Kategorie an und schon hast du da schnell mal eben so einen Bar Chart oder ein Pie Chart, je nachdem, was du da so haben willst. Und ja, das ist schon cool. Also Thumbs Up für Money Money.
Und diese Tags, war das nicht so, dass du, wenn du dann einmal so eine Transaktion da getaggt hast, dass er dann die nächsten dann automatisch auch erkennt irgendwie? Oder musst du das jedes Mal von Hand machen? Also jede einzelne Transaktion? Ich dachte irgendwie, da gibt es so was.
Ja, da hast du recht. Ich glaube, da ist etwas, was ich...
Also ich dachte, man könnte da irgendwie so Rules sogar machen.
Ja, da gibt es auch noch so Rules. Das habe ich mir ehrlich gesagt noch gar nicht angeschaut. Warte mal, wo ist denn das überhaupt?
Bist du dir sicher, dass das Money Money war?
Ja, das ist auch so ein Alman-Unternehmen eigentlich.
Kann auch sein, dass ich das jetzt verwechsel, aber irgendwie war mir so, als könnte man das machen. Da ich es aber nicht benutze, also dieses Feature.
Also ich nutze ja auch Money Money seit einem Jahr. Und zwar aber zusammen mit von Reiner SCT mit so einem Security-Modul hier, wo man von seiner Bank halt so eine Chipkarte kriegt. Die muss man dann einmal in diesem Modul irgendwie initialisieren, wie auch immer, seiner Bank seinen Public Key davon, den Anteil sozusagen geben und dann tragen die das bei sich dahin. Dann sagt man alles andere außer diese Karte ist verboten. Und dann kann man Money Money, also dann nutzt Money Money dieses Gerät. Das ist auch mit Bluetooth, wenn man will. Hier gibt es eins und nur mit Bluetooth. Das schlägt dann Money Money gleich vor. Ich schalte das Gerät an, indem ich die Karte reinschiebe. Die connecten sich. Da muss man einen Pin eingeben von der Karte und dann geht erst das HBCI los. Das heißt, da kann sozusagen niemand dazwischenfuschen. Und das funktioniert eigentlich auch alles super. Ich habe vorher irgendwie hier mit... Was war das andere? Was ist Starcraft? Nein, nicht Starcraft, Star Money oder sowas? Star Money und das war alles irgendwie... Das ging gar nicht. Und dann habe ich irgendwie Money Money probiert. Das hat gleich sofort gerockt und dann bin ich da hängen geblieben.
Genau, es gibt übrigens gerade zwischen Receipts und Money Money auch so kleine Brücke. Du kannst zum Beispiel, wenn deine Rechnung gescannt ist, scannt er dir auch gleich noch die E-Bahn auch noch mit runter, das hatte ich vorhin gar nicht erwähnt. Und dann hast du halt so einen Button jetzt in Money Money bezahlen, klickst drauf und dann hast du...
Von dem gleichen Typen oder?
Nee, die arbeiten ja alle zusammen. Das ist hier irgendwie so ein kleines...
Die stecken alle unter einer Decke.
Ja, die stecken wirklich alle unter einer Decke. Ich bin immer wieder erstaunt. Diese ganzen One-Man-Shows im Macintosh-Bereich, die kennen sich natürlich alle, weil die natürlich auch alle ähnliche Zielgruppen haben auf der einen Seite und natürlich auch alle dieselben Probleme.
Und integrieren sich aber auch gegenseitig.
Das mag noch dazukommen. Ich meine, viele von denen, von denen wir jetzt gerade sprechen, bewegen sich ja auch tatsächlich alle in diesem Rechnungsschreiben, Steuererklärungs-Sachen machen.
Ich fixe jetzt mal das Problem, was ich selber habe, dann kommt auch was Gutes dabei raus.
Und vernetzen ihre Programme untereinander, dass sie prima Austausch haben. Import, Export und manchmal auch die direkte Ansteuerung, das funktioniert hier schon recht gut. Das lässt alles noch viel zu wünschen übrig, aber im Prinzip wunderbare Sache. Ja, mit diesen Regeln, weiß ich nicht, da finde ich jetzt gerade nichts zu...
Okay, dann hab ich mich da...
Ich hatte das noch nicht auch gelesen und das hat mich auch gewundert, aber jetzt weiß ich gerade nicht, wo... Also die Webseite erwähnt das selber nicht.
Na dann, vielleicht war das ein Feature von Outbank.
Ah, nee, doch, hier stimmt. Erstellen Sie Kategorien, legen Sie Kategorisierungsregeln an.
Kategorisierungsregeln...
Wo sind die denn, die so...
Wo sind die denn? Frag doch mal die Hilfe! Ruf doch mal die Hilfe an!
Ah, hier ist es! Ja genau, Augen auf dem Straßenverkehr, im Datenverkehr. Also man kann hier, wenn man eine Kategorie hat, in den Einstellungen dazu...
Ja, ein Freitextfeld ausfüllen, mit seiner Lieblingsregel.
Regeln für automatische Kategorisierung, da gibt es ein Fragezeichen.
Ja, da gibt es ein Fragezeichen, und dazu gibt es einen riesigen...
Naja, und dann gibt es so einfache...
Der unterstützt bei Money Money ja auch schon den Touch-ID vom MacBook. Und war schon vor zwei Monaten war das, glaube ich, naheliegend.
Genau, und wenn man dann auf den Button drückt, mit Touch-ID Fingerabdrucksensor entsperren, sagt er, ihr Mac besitzt keinen Touch-ID Fingerabdrucksensor.
Ja, so den Überweisen-Button.
Würde mich jetzt gar nicht groß wundern.
Gibt es hier nicht zu sehen.
Ich hier noch nicht viel von.
Gut, gut.
Ja, genau. Ach, das mit Regel ist ja nice. Das muss ich auch mal machen.
Mit nur 25 Euro ist das auch wirklich nicht so teuer.
Genau.
Im Zweifel, man will dieses Zusatzmodul haben.
Es geht sogar mit Regular Expressions.
Sehbar, Ladmisch, Rippeinzug.
Nerdvalue hier. Genau. Man kann sogar mit Regular Expressions in seinen Kontoauszügen automatisch Kategoriezuordnungen machen. Das find ich geil. Das ist cool. Mein Tipp für kriegt mal eurem Bankenkram klar. Und vor allem, ich hab jetzt außer dem beklopptesten Fintech-Scheißdreck nahezu wirklich jede Bank drin verwaltet bekommen. Oh ja, da kann ich auch gleich nochmal einen kleinen Rand hinterher legen. Weil ich mich jetzt sozusagen viel mit ich buche den ganzen Kram zusammen und am Ende muss da eine Null stehen.
Ja, weil...
Auch aktiver, passiver und so?
Nee, aber ich bin jetzt noch nicht in dem eigentlichen Steuerbuchungsteil. Das Fass werde ich dann hier in den nächsten Folgen sicherlich dann auch nochmal aufmachen. Jetzt geht's erstmal nur...
Vor Freude ist ganz auf unserer Seite.
Ja, da könnt ihr euch mal was Schöneres vorstellen, als mich über Steuerbuchungen reden zu hören.
Nein, natürlich nicht.
Das weiß ich doch, deswegen mich da auch so hinterher. Nee, trotzdem, also du willst ja sozusagen, es in den Griff kriegen und zu wissen, es passt, heißt, dass am Ende hast du dann eine Null. Weil alle Buchungen sind irgendwie korrekt zugeordnet und jedes Hin und Her hat so sein Gegenüber. Das heißt, wenn du von Konto A auf Konto B was überweist, dann ziehst du es bei dem einen ab und bei dem anderen fügst du es hinzu. Du willst halt irgendwie auf die Null kommen. Und dann war ich natürlich in so einem Prozess, dass ich natürlich erstmal so meine ganzen typischen HBCI-Banken da so drin hatte und dann gut PayPal und dann so, hm, da hab ich doch noch dieses kleine In-26-Experiment gemacht und hab mich dann sehr gewundert, dass das den hier auch unterstützt ist und ich dachte, die machen gar keinen HBCI. Ich hab festgestellt, Money Money hat expliziten In-26-Support durch Webseiten-Scraping.
Also ich meine, es spricht für Money Money, aber...
Ja, es spricht auf jeden Fall gegen... Vor allem jetzt nach dieser Experience ist für mich auch klar, ich will nicht mit Banken was zu tun haben, die irgendwie nicht in In-26-Style unterwegs sind. Also das muss schon irgendwie mit HBCI funktionieren. Nicht, dass ich jetzt HBCI für ein glorreiches Protokoll halte, aber es ist zumindest schon mal eins, was da ist und was mehr oder weniger von allen unterstützt wird. Ja, und dann hatte ich so beim Umbuchen so Probleme, da irgendwie auf meine Null zu kommen. Und dann fiel mir immer noch ein so, ach, da hat's ja da auch noch was. Und da hat's ja da auch noch was.
Lass mich raten, du hast mehr Konten als E-Mail-Account.
Ja, in der Tat ist das so. Naja, weil man ja bestimmte Sachen überhaupt nicht wahrnimmt. Zum Beispiel hatte ich im Rahmen von der ganzen Flattern-Nutzung mir halt irgendwann auch mal so ein Moneybookers-heutes-Grill-Account angelegt. Weißt du, was ich nur dafür benutze, um das Geld von A nach B zu bekommen, weil es keine SEPA-Payout-Optionen gibt. Jetzt gibt es sie mittlerweile, aber das war halt über viele, viele Jahre ein echtes Problem. Oder am Anfang habe ich das halt mit PayPal gemacht, aber PayPal hat immer unglaublich viel Geld dafür genommen, das bisschen Geld von A nach B zu schieben. Da ist dann irgendwie nochmal so 2% der Kohle einfach verloren gegangen, nur um es zu erhalten, was auch absurd ist. Ja, dann gab es zwischendurch diese Hoffnung, und dann habe ich halt irgendwie diesen Account wieder aufgemacht. Und natürlich haben die natürlich kein HBCI und gar nichts, und da gibt es auch nicht so einen Webseiten Scraper und so weiter. Dann kannst du in Money Money aber immerhin ein sogenanntes Offline-Konto einrichten. Das heißt, du machst ja halt einfach noch ein Konto in dieser Liste und machst jede Buchung manuell. Du holst es dir halt nicht von irgendeinem Server, sondern du sagst, es gab die Überweisung, es gab die Überweisung. Will man natürlich nicht von Hand machen, will man nicht von Hand machen, was macht man dann?
Es gibt dieses Austauschformat.
Es gibt da dieses Austauschformat, genau. Und wie heißt dieses Austauschformat?
MT, irgendwas, so eine Zahl dahinter oder so.
Du denkst zu kompliziert. Das Austauschformat. Wir alle wissen, CSV means nothing.
Doch, irgendwo sind Kommas.
Nicht unbedingt.
Ja, nicht mal. Das ist ja schon das Geile, dass in CSV ja noch nicht mal Kommas drin sind.
Eigentlich ist es nur SV.
Also in den amerikanischen Varianten war es halt...
Top...
.ein Komma, weil für die ein Komma nichts Besonderes war. Mittlerweile ist ja CSV mehr eigentlich ein SSV, also mehr ein Semikolon, separierte Values. Ne, mit Anführungsstrichen und so. Seitdem funktioniert das ja auch so ein bisschen. Also ist die Hölle, wissen wir alle. So, aber ich bin halt auf dieses Grillkonto gegangen und hatte da, keine Ahnung, da war ja nicht viel, da waren vielleicht so 30, 40 Buchungen, also überschaubar. Hätte ich im Prinzip auch noch von Hand machen wollen. Aber macht man ja dann nicht, weil man ist ja Nerd und sagt sich, das geht alles. Ich kann das viel besser automatisieren und so. Und dann gab es da sogar ein CSV Export-Button geklickt. Ich dachte mir so, ha, CSV, alles ist nur an meiner Kontrolle. Aber man blickt ja dann immer wieder in so Untiefen rein. Die sind erschreckend. Also bei dem Steuerberatungsprogramm, was ich da gerade teste, hatte ich zum Beispiel auch so, dass so die Export-Dateien tatsächlich noch ihre Zeichen in Macintosh-Encoding machen. Also in dem von dem alten Mac OS, du weißt, aus den 80er Jahren das... Mac Roman-Encoding, so ne Geschichten. Das war jetzt hier nicht der Fall. Und dann hab ich diese 40 Buchungen genommen und musste natürlich erstmal umfangreich diese Datei editieren, weil natürlich waren da alle Zahlen mit Punkt separiert und nicht mit Komma. Also nicht die Werte, sondern halt die Nachkommastellen. Okay, kann man auch irgendwie entschuldigen. Man kann nicht so sehr entschuldigen, dass die Programme beim Importieren davon solche Probleme haben. Weil Numbers kann natürlich, wenn es auf Deutsch eingestellt ist, mit Punkten auf einmal nichts mehr anfangen.
Ja, das hat mich ja vor Jahren schon gewundert. Schlimm. Ich glaub, ich hab sogar ein Bug-Report irgendwann mal gesendet, aber der die Hölle, die gesendet so versandet.
Aber ich immer noch so voll on top of the game, Nerd und so. Und dann hab ich halt diese 40 Buchungen dann auch tatsächlich so hin und her bekommen. Achso, ja, dann haben sie noch, oh geil, dann haben sie auch noch so ein beklopptes Datumsformat gemacht, was dann auch Numbers nicht richtig gepasst bekommen hat. Deshalb bei meinem ersten Durchlauf hatte ich auch noch falsche Daten. Zweiter Versuch, alles hinbekommen, alles drin gehabt. Ich hab das dann in meinem Money-Money drin. Dann steht da 12,95 Euro. Weil das Konto war sozusagen leer. Das war für mich so ein rein raus Konto. Ich hab immer alles komplett überwiesen. Da waren 40 Buchungen drin. Und dieser CSV-Export, dieser Buchung auf der Webseite, siehst du so, ja, hier dein Konto, 0 Euro. Und es hat ja definitiv mal bei 0 Euro angefangen, weil du kriegst ja auch nix geschenkt. Aber wenn du halt einen CSV-Export machst, bist du auf einmal bei 12,95 Euro. Die Zahlen stimmen halt einfach nicht. Da wurde mir wieder klar, auch nach diesem N26-Desaster, dass dieser ganze Fintech-Kram mit wir machen das jetzt mal richtig und jetzt kommen die Nerds und erzählen den Banken mal, wie das funktioniert.
Das ist einfach Doom.
Das ist einfach ein Mythos.
Ein Freund von mir, der hat schon vor Jahren mal im Callcenter einer Bank gearbeitet und der meinte zu mir als großen Tipp nur, leg dir dein Geld unter das Kopfkissen. Das war alles, was er zu dem Thema sagte.
Gleicher Tipp für Leute, die Bitcoins haben.
Den Spruch von dir hatten wir schon mal in dem Mt. Gox Song.
Er meinte das ja nicht als Witz, sondern er war so tief schockiert. In ernster Mine meinte er, ja.
Das sind die Untiefen, durch die ich gerade warte. Und in gewisser Hinsicht finde ich das alles auch sehr spannend. Man nimmt das ja auch so ein bisschen als Herausforderung an. Aber ich bin wirklich erstaunt, wie schlecht das alles da draußen sein kann. Das ist grauenhaft.
Wenn du dann mit Konten buchen und so weiter anfängst, bin ja gespannt, was du sagst. Ich fand das ja ziemlich geil. Also ich habe Rechnungswesen im Abi früher gehabt. Ja, ich habe dummerweise BWL...
Aber ich war...
Ja, ich habe BWL als Leistungskurs gehabt. genau das war es auch. Rechnungswesen war geil, aber der Rest ist eher zum Weglaufen.
Das war auch ein schöner Druck auf die Reuspartaste.
Also ich finde Rechnungswesen, diese ganzen Kontensachen, Buchen, fand ich echt cool. Und ich hab das halt als Praktikum, musste ich das in einem Autohaus auch gemacht. So schön mit den ganzen Akten. Also echt Spaß gemacht. Weiß nicht, ist halt so eine meditative Arbeit.
Du hast gerade Rechnungswesen im Autohaus gesagt.
Das ist jetzt ein Seelspiegel, wie krupp die es halt so unterhalten sind. Also die ticken ein bisschen anders offensichtlich.
Ich kann das total gut nachvollziehen. Ich hab im Prinzip die Hälfte meines Winterurlaubs mit dem Einsortieren von Rechnungen in diesem PDF-Receipts-Programm verbracht. Hab Kontenbuchungen rausgesucht, gegengerechnet, Umbuchungen vorgenommen, irgendwie versucht Struktur reinzubekommen, mir Kategoriesysteme einfallen lassen. Irgendwie hat er das was Meditatives.
Definitiv und du musst eine Zeit lang dabei noch mitdenken und irgendwann denkst du aber nicht mehr mit, weil das halt so drin ist. Und ich fand das super geil, weil es halt so... Man hat sich nicht totgemacht beide Arbeiten.
Also mir saugt das, wenn ich so um einen Bürokratie-Run einmal im Halbjahr mache, da saugt mir das letzte Leben aus der Hörnerin.
Aber das ist auch, weil wir das halt nur alle halbe Jahre einmal im Jahr machen. Wenn man das halt jeden Tag macht und sozusagen das eigene System perfekt stimmt und du hast halt dein Konto, da kommt was rein, auf dein Konto geht was raus, dann stimmt das. Dann hast du dein Plus Minus Null und das ist alles schick. Aber wenn man das halt immer wieder von vorne anfangen muss jedes Jahr, dann ist halt für'n Arsch. Wie eigentlich mit jeder Arbeit. Wenn ich nach einem Jahr mal wieder ein neues Xcode Projekt anfange, keine Ahnung, muss ich auch erstmal alles wieder neu denken. Wie mit jedem Scheiß halt.
Ja, aber ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht vorstellen, dass mir das in regelmäßiger Form große Freude bereitet wird.
Aber du hast auch im Prinzip auch mal erzählt, dass du eigentlich irgendwie unter dem Strich immer eigentlich dein Geld ist auch so in-out mäßig.
Rechte Hosen, Tasche, linke Hosen.
Ich könnte dir jetzt anfangen, dir einen väterlichen Rat zu geben, aber ich lasse das lieber.
Ich habe einen Dauerauftrag, der am Anfang des Monats gleich irgendwas aufs Tagesgeldkonto schiebt, damit das gar nicht erst in den Flugs eingespritzt werden kann.
Aber ganz ehrlich, dieser Gedanke, wirklich vor so einem Master-World-Control-Dashboard zu sitzen, auf dem so deine ganzen Finanztransaktionsflohungen ablaufen...
Deswegen kann ich mir dann auch so effizient wie möglich die Gadgets sozusagen...
Wie das hast du, obwohl du dich da nicht mit beschäftigst?
Na ja, wie gesagt, ganz am Anfang meinte ich ja schon, wenn man hier so den wichtigen Kram gleich wegsortiert, dann hat man ja schon mal diesen ganzen Papier. Das mache ich ja schon mal. Und Money Money läuft da auch. Und ich habe jetzt nicht so einen wilden Buchungsverkehr wie du vielleicht, sondern hält sich eigentlich in Grenzen. Kommt halt am Anfang des Monats so ein Batzen rein und dann geht so ein ganzer Batzen wieder raus. Und wie viel rausgeht, das sehe ich ja dann. Und Money Money, wie viel Spielraum da noch ist, den reize ich auch gerne. Also das ist mein Optimierungspart quasi. Und wie gesagt, irgendwann habe ich dann eingeführt, dass ich am Anfang des Monats gleich noch was beiseiteschiebe, damit dann irgendwo sich auch nochmal was anspart für unerwartete Situationen.
Unerwartete Gadgets zwischendurch?
Naja, ich mache das halt nach der Schuhkarton-Methode. Also es gibt halt den Schuhkarton, da kommt halt alles rein, was wichtig ist an der Post, die so aufläuft, eben Rechnungen und so ein Scheiß. Also Rechnungen versuche ich immer gleich zu bezahlen und zwar meistens als Terminüberweisung, sodass irgendwie noch zwei Tage passen. Und dann so die Fälligkeit, dass es halt so passt irgendwie und dann schreibe ich das direkt drauf auf die Rechnung, dass ich die bezahlt habe und wann. Oder zu wann ich das dann überwiesen habe und dann kommt es in den Schuhkarton und irgendwann wird der Schuhkarton halt in den Scan-Snap ausgeleert und dann fallen da die ganzen Scans raus und die landen dann nach Jahren sortiert in einem Git-Repository bei mir.
Das ist mein Workflow.
Ich hab halt richtig so komplexe Fälle, die nicht so einfach zu bewältigen sind. Ich kündige so zwei, drei Monate ein Event vorher an, dann gehen die Bestellungen für die Teilnahme ein und die Bezahlungen, dann überspringt das Monatsgrenzen, Quartalsgrenzen und muss sie dann halt in unterschiedliche Quartale einsortieren und so was. Das muss man einfach voll digitalisieren, sonst hat man da irgendwie gar keine Chance. Gut, soviel zum Rechnungswesen im Autohaus. Jetzt können wir auch wieder über noch nerdigeren Kram reden. Wer mag voransprechen?
Dennis! Weil ich auch gleich der erste Punkt da oben. Letzte Nacht war ich ein bisschen langweilig. Hab ich ja manchmal. Und hab so ein YouTube-Video gefunden, weil ich gerade wieder im 68k nostalgischer Modus bin. Und dann hab ich mir ein 3-Stunden-Video angeguckt. Wo irgendwie so ein von 2007 war das, wo so ein Computer-History-Museum oder sowas. Die hatten da so ein Interview mit 5 Leuten, die früher bei Motorola beschäftigt waren, als der 68k Prozessor designt, hergestellt, vermarktet und so weiter wurde. Genau ganz oben das Ding. Dauert irgendwie 2 Stunden 45 oder sowas.
Hattest du wirklich schlaflose Nächte oder was?
Nee, aber ich bin da gerade voll drin im Modus. Und mich hat mal interessiert, was sie da noch so für Anekdoten erzählen. Audio ist richtig schlecht und dann ist eine Person dabei, die sehr stark, nicht Sprachfehler, aber die Schwierigkeiten beim Sprechen hat. Und das war aber auch der, der irgendwie das meint am meisten erzählen zu müssen und der auch wirklich eine Menge interessante Sachen erzählt hat. Aber es war anstrengend zu hören. Aber trotzdem 2 Steve-Anekdoten haben die da halt noch erzählt. Also es ist wirklich sehr, sehr trocken. Muss ich schon auch ein bisschen auskennen, damit der CPU und dem ganzen, was damals so abging. Aber 2 Steve-Anekdoten haben sie erzählt. Und das erste war, dass Steve wohl 79 oder so schon zu denen hingekommen ist. Da kam der 68K Prozessor heraus, der erste. Und wir wissen ja, der Macintosh hatte ja diesen Prozessor, aber erst 84. Aber die fangen natürlich vorher an. Mit dem Design und CPU muss man natürlich als allererstes irgendwie mal festlegen. Steve da hin und hat gesagt, hier Jungs, euren Prozessor würde ich ja gerne nehmen. Also und hat sich das also angeguckt und was der denn kosten würde. Und dann meint er ja, so 125 Dollar. Meint er, was? Nee, 15 könnt ihr haben. Dann haben sie gesagt, ja also, nee, also 15, das wird ja schwierig. Also aber schon, also wie viel er dann haben wollen würde. Und Steve meinte, er will eine Million Stück haben. Und da meinten sie zu ihm, na hör mal zu, also wir können dir keine 15 Dollar am Anfang bieten, aber wir können dir garantieren, wenn du die fünf, ne, wenn du die ein millionste CPU kaufst, dass du dann bis dahin nicht mehr als 15 Millionen Dollar ausgegeben haben wirst. Also das sozusagen das Risiko auf Steves Seite ist. Und dass dann sozusagen umso mehr kauft, umso billiger wird es. Am Ende sogar billiger als 15 Dollar, weil das teuer am Anfang muss ja wieder eingeholt werden. Und der Typ meint am Ende, wenn er sich richtig erinnert, sind sie bei 14 Dollar 67 gelandet oder irgendwie so. Also er hat wahrscheinlich noch ein paar mehr gekauft als eine Million. Das war das eine. Also überhaupt haben die viel über Apple geredet, weil es halt ein 68K-Rechner war. Commodore ist komischerweise gar nicht gefallen, der Name. Aber noch Sun und HP, IBM, Intel und so. Das waren die großen Firmen und Konkurrenzen. Und Microsoft ist auch noch klein.
Also sie waren wahrscheinlich, ich meine, Atari und Commodore sind ja auch erst sehr viel später auf den 68000er-Trader gekommen.
Ja und ich glaube, das war auch eher so eine europäische Geschichte. Die Firmen waren schon von da drüben, aber der Amiga, glaube ich, ist in Europa viel besser gelaufen als in Amerika. Und Atari, glaube ich, sogar auch. Jedenfalls, die andere Story, die sie erzählt haben, ist dann, als wohl Steve, wir haben immer von Steve geredet, wieder bei so einem Meeting kam irgendwie zu Motorola mit den Prozessor-Designern und Entwicklern und weiß nicht was alles, Marketing-Chefs und hast du nicht gesehen, den ganzen Meetings halt mit tausenden Leuten, ist er ganz nett gegangen von einem zum nächsten und hat sich immer erzählen lassen, was sie dann so machen und sich vorgestellt und so weiter. Und als er dann fertig war, hat er gesagt, du, du und du, ihr geht jetzt mal raus. Und er hat sozusagen immer alle vom Marketing von Motorola, hat er mal rausgeschmissen, weil die wollte er nicht haben in den Meetings.
Und dann hat er mit denen irgendwie die Technik dann das klargemacht.
Ja, mit was wahrscheinlich die technischen Sachen durchgequatscht oder was sie da so vorhaben. Genau, eine kleine Sache, was sie noch hatten, hat mich ein bisschen an IBM erinnert. Als Steve sich den Prozessor angeguckt hat, den 68K, der hat ja hier 24-Bit-Adressleitung. Also das war ja, der hatte 16-Bit-Datenbus, 24-Bit-Adressbus und intern hat er aber 32-Bit-Register. Jedenfalls meinte Steve, 24-Bit-Adressbus, also so viel Speicher, das braucht doch kein Schwein. Also wir, wir bräuchten 128 Kilobyte und das, das niemand braucht mehr als 128 Kilobyte. Weil sie waren mit ihrem 24-Bit-Adressbus damals schon ganz schön weit vorne. Also 79, ja, mit 16 Megabyte. Der Amiga, der 85, 86, also sie hatte jahrelang nur zwei, also alle hatten, also bis...
Der erste hatte 256k.
Ja, ich weiß, aber bis zu den 90ern hatte ja keiner wirklich mehr als 16 MB irgendwie in seinem Rechner, also noch zehn Jahre lang. Also sie haben schon mit ihrer Kiste, mit ihrer CPU gut losgelegt da. Aber da hat sich Steve auch ein bisschen verschätzt wohl. Krass. Also wer 68k Fan ist und ein bisschen was hören will und zwei Stunden 50 in schlechter Audioqualität und auch noch mit einer Person, der wirklich schwer zu verstehen ist, weil er, der hat halt, weiß nicht, Krankheitsschaden, wie auch immer, ich weiß nicht, wie man das nennt, also hat Sprachschwierigkeiten auf jeden Fall. Wer das alles aushält, kann sich das mal antun. Ich fand's ganz interessant.
Tja, schade, gibt's keine CC-Subtitle-Thingy-Doodlers hier, weil ganz oft ist jetzt ja YouTube schon echt ziemlich fit im Erkennen von Sprache und automatischer Subtitel.
Ja, da hab ich mir auch überlegt, warum YouTube jetzt hier, wie heißt dieses auf Honig? Genau, warum YouTube nicht so was hat, wo man mal irgendwie so klicken kann. Haben sie? Aber nur wieder für Bezahlgründen oder was? Oder gibt's da für mich auch eine Option, wo ich klicke und das dann ein bisschen in besserer Quality kommt?
Du hast das in deinen Videos so als Setting. Und das war lange Zeit nur so beta-mäßig und ich glaube jetzt ist das sogar standardmäßig. Du musstest irgendwie einschalten und dann...
Weil die hatten ja Mikrofonen ganz komisch nur auf einer Seite der fünf Leute. Das heißt, einer war immer mega laut, die anderen auf der anderen Seite waren mega leise.
Ja, die haben sich einfach schlecht mikrofoniert, aber ich meine, wenn du das mal durch Aufhörer jagst, ist es wahrscheinlich gleich schon viel besser.
Ja, aber mit Video auch zusammen oder wie muss ich es dann...
Ja, kannst du mit Video hochladen, pack da dann wieder ins Video rein.
Wo wir schon bei Videos waren, ich hab da auch einen kleinen Tipp und zwar...
Kann ich ja mal machen.
Auf Vimeo von so einem Typen, der nennt sich Star T Rakiet oder wie hört man man das ausspricht, gibt es so Videos, 84 Rocket Launches auf 2016. Da hat er also mal alle Rocket Launches von 2016 zusammengeschnitten. Und es ist total geil, sich das anzugucken. Also erstens starten halt ständig Raketen. Ja gut, das ist irgendwann dann nicht mehr so spannend. Aber... Im Workflow ist es drin, der Link.
Pack's doch gleich in den Chat auch noch. Wo denn?
Ach hier, das.
Polnisch wahrscheinlich. Das Coole ist, dass man so schön diese Unterschiede sieht. Also zum Beispiel die NASA und die ESA, die zählen ja unterschiedlich. Also bei der NASA ist es glaube ich so...
Die Null ist, wenn das Ding abhebt.
Die Null ist, wenn die Raketen zünden. Die Null ist, wenn das Haupttriebwerk zündet. Genau.
Nein, nein. Bei der ESA ist Null die Zündung.
Ja, von dem Haupttriebwerk. Nicht von den Boostern, die kommen ja nochmal später.
Egal, bei der NASA ist Null, wenn es abhebt.
Genau, wenn es lift auf.
Wenn die loslassen, die Halteteile.
Wenn das Ding sich nach oben bewegt.
Wenn sich das Ding nach oben bewegt.
Also in anderen Worten, bei der ESA ist das alles nerdig. Und bei der NASA ist es Marketing.
Ja, das ist alles Show. Das siehst du auch in der Art, wie sie gesabbeln da. Also diese United Launch Alliance Starts, Blablabla, Satellite for Global Communications, Blablabla. Und dann denkst du dir, ja, ist ja gut. Die ESA, ne Moment, lass mich mal fertig. Die ESA zählt natürlich auf Französisch. Das muss natürlich Französisch sein. Aber am geilsten sind die Inder. Weil die zählen halt auch so rückwärts bis Null und dann kommt plus one, plus two, plus three, plus four, five, six. Und du denkst dir so, hä? Aber am geilsten war der Start von der nordkoreanischen Rakete mit so einer ordentlich wuchtigen kommunistischen Musik dahinter. Mit Chor, Heldenchor und allem drum und dran.
Davon gibt es Videos?
Ja, da ist eins dabei.
Und wo ist das drin? In 16 oder 15?
Ich glaube in 16, aber es ist irgendwo mittendrin. Also das Video läuft halt auch über eine halbe Stunde.
Wir können ja trotzdem mal kurz reinhören.
Das ist auf jeden Fall großartig. Bei meiner nächsten Party läuft das auf dem Klo.
Long March ist das nicht sogar schon? Nee, das ist jetzt wieder.
Nee, die sind auch immer relativ kurz. Also du kannst da einfach abwarten.
Aber wo ist denn hier der Nordkoreaner?
Du, keine Ahnung. Das habe ich mir jetzt nicht aufgeschrieben.
Das finde ich auch bei den SpaceX-Lodges cool, dass sie unten immer diese Timeline haben, wo dann auch diese kompletten Phasen der Missionen mit eingestellt sind.
Und Speed und Altitude oben und so weiter.
Die wissen schon, wie es geht. Was ist das, die Inder? Jetzt kommen die Franzosen.
Welche hört sich ja so an, wie wir bei einem schlechten Sponfilm.
Das Ding ist erst bei 9 Sekunden so richtig abgehoben. Aber die Donnert, ey!
Letztens meinte einer bei einem SpaceX-Lounge, dass er 2-3 km weit weg wohnt oder noch mehr. Die Häuser wackeln dann noch km weit weg, wenn so eine Rakete abgeht. Da ist schon Druck auf der Leitung. Wir haben die Anleitung.
Das sind jetzt wieder Chinesen. Ich will die Nordkoreaner. Wo sind die?
Keine Ahnung, die sind ja alle immer so...
Lass uns den Chat rausfinden. Wir gucken später nochmal rein.
What the hell?
Hab ich zu viel versprochen?
Das ist wirklich ein interessanter, kultureller Unterschied hier. Die Amerikaner, auch bei der NASA, quatschen dann immer in diese Launch-Sequenz mit rein, was da jetzt gerade startet, wofür und wofür das gut ist. Sie nutzen sozusagen diese kurzen Momente der Aufmerksamkeit nicht nur dazu, um zu sagen, jetzt fliegt das Ding, sondern wir gehen jetzt hier to Bode Ligo, where no man has gone before, und das wird jetzt hier delivered und dafür ist das gut. Und jetzt!
Ja! Ja.
Das war Korea, das war Nordkorea, ja.
Amix.
Na, jetzt wird schon jetzt startet und?
And liftoff of the United Launch Alliance Delta IV Rocket carrying the NRL-45 mission for the National Reconnaissance Office.
Also ich töte jetzt ungern die Stimmung, aber von den SZ kommt gerade die Eilmeldung, dass das britische Unterhaus für das Brexit-Verfahren gestimmt hätte.
Die letzte SpaceX-Flug, die hatten ja auch wieder eine Landung geplant gehabt und haben die auch vollzogen. Und das Coole diesmal war, dass normalerweise, wenn die Rakete wieder runterkommt und auf diesem Droneship landet, dass dann meistens das WLAN ausfällt. Also die Kameraübertragung, da kommt einfach kein Bild mehr, weil da zu viele Störungen sind wie immer. Das heißt, die geht runter, du siehst dann noch ein bisschen mehr und wenn sie dann näher kommt, dann ist das Bild weg und dann kommt es wieder, wenn die Rakete schon steht und dazwischen, das ist einfach im Rauschen verschwunden. Und bei der letzten Landung ist das nicht passiert, nicht so wirklich, zumindest deutlich weniger. Und man kann richtig sehen, wie die Rakete weiter runterkommt und weiter runterkommt, man erkennt das Wasser schon an den Welten, dann erkennt man sogar das Droneship, wo sie landen soll und das Bild bleibt und bleibt und bleibt und man sieht richtig, wie das Ding runtergeht, bis auf dieses Schiff landet, stehen bleibt und super, also es war sozusagen kameramäßig eine Bilderbuchlandung, auch wenn immer noch ein paar Auffälle waren, aber im Großen und Ganzen war das durchgehend Bild. Und das war schon ziemlich cool, das war vorher nicht der Fall.
Twitter seht das gerade nicht?
Wenn ich da hingehe, ich gebe immer einen SpaceX Twitter und dann kommt das da aber eigentlich. Achso, das war in dem Livecast irgendwo mittendrin, das war nicht nochmal das Einzelvideo. Du müsstest den ganzen Cast da irgendwie an die richtige Stelle springen. Aber das geht ja, weil da unten eben dieser Sliderbalken ist, wo man genau die Stelle sehen kann. SpaceX, Webcast, Last Dingens, irgendwie. Also genau, das war ja die Iridium Mission, wo diese zehn Satelliten irgendwie da ausgeklinkt haben aus diesen Deploy-Dings da, wie auch immer das hieß. Genau, der hat auch erstmal erklärt, warum das Iridium heißt, falls das noch keiner weiß. Hab ich vergessen, ich hoffe nicht. Die Anzahl der Satelliten war irgendwie 78 oder was war das?
Und das ist die Ordnungszahl des Elements, ne?
Genau, und dann hätten sie aber aus irgendeinem Grund haben sie dann gemerkt, dass sie doch gar nicht so viele brauchen oder irgendwie so, und dann kam eine andere Zahl raus und das wär aber irgendwie so ein kacke Element gewesen und dann haben sie gedacht, ach scheiß drauf, wir behalten den Name Iridium, daher kommt das. Aber eigentlich trifft der gar nicht mehr zu. Nervdürs, die keiner wissen will, ja.
So, wann ist denn hier die Landung?
Ganz am Anfang. Ja, das ist hier Entry. Seco könnte das sein, oder ist das? Warum ist der da nicht mit dabei? Weiß nicht, Separation-Dingens.
Wo sind wir denn jetzt gerade? Hier sind wir gerade noch beim Start und da ist Meco. Ist das Meco schon durch? Nee, aber das ist ja noch die Hauptstufe hier, die wir gerade sehen.
Na, da kommt sie wieder runter, oder was ist das? Du musst auf jeden Fall ein bisschen rein. Entry ist das, wenn er wieder zurückkommt, oder?
Kann sein, ja.
Ja, dir fehlt da unten unter der Zeit, da steht dann nämlich Landing. Das ist der vorletzte Punkt, wo du da bist. Ja, da steht noch ein Wort darunter.
Ja, aber hier hat er die Füße schon ausgedingst. Ich bin jetzt schon kurz davor. Ah, jetzt so richtig mit Video von der Rakete auch live.
Ja, genau, so und gleich. Früher ist das Bild immer verschwunden, weil das einfach da unten empfangmäßig hat das nicht geklappt.
Aber das ist jetzt hier noch ziemlich, das dauert aber nicht so lange, ne?
Ne, so in einer Minute.
17.000 km hadisch pro Stunde, da sollte das schnell gehen.
17.000.
Sind aber auch noch 160 Kilometer.
Ne, das geht trotzdem schnell. Okay, wird sogar noch schneller gerade das Ding.
Ja, ist er, geht der nach unten? Ja, der geht nach unten.
Ne, die Anzeige da oben ist für das andere.
Denke ich ja auch. Jaja, das ist davon entkoppelt. Das andere ist wie, wie stellt ihr...
Stage 2 steht ja da oben.
So, ah jetzt geht er runter. Okay, sehr spannend jetzt für unsere Hörer, uns beim Video schon.
Da ist das Droneship.
Und jetzt ruckelt der Stream.
Es geht! Aber ich meine, guck dir an, das Ding ist wirklich Punktlandung, also.
Absolut, das geht echt fast kaum besser.
Aber müssten wir das jetzt nicht eigentlich so feiern, wie die das in dem ESA-Kontrollzentrum gemacht haben?
Ja, haben wir ja auch gerade.
Lächeln, die Faust nur so drei Zentimeter nach unten schieben.
Du darfst einmal Yes sagen. Das reicht dann schon.
Das ist übrigens wieder das erste Droneship hier. Nee, das ist das zweite. Das erste hieß ja Reads the fucking Manual. Nee, so hieß das nicht, aber so ähnlich. Und das ist das erste, wo die Rakete eingeknallt und explodiert ist. Das haben die ja wieder anscheinend flott gemacht.
Also ich muss schon sagen...
Und nächsten Dienstag ist die nächste fällig. Am 14.
Und die landet dann wo?
Keine Ahnung, hab ich nicht geguckt. Manchmal landet die auch nicht. Wenn die zu schwere Sachen hochschicken, dann ist kein Sprit mehr da, um wieder runterzukommen, um abzubremsen.
Na gut.
Dann noch, wie sagt man, shameless plug für den Dienstag.
Weil ich hab nämlich auch ein Raketenthema oder einen Tipp beizutragen. Und zwar hab ich letztens mal wieder diesen Artikel rausgekramt von Telepolis, wie viele Atombomben man schon so in der Welt verloren hat, durch Unfälle. Ja, es gibt da so einige. Also weiß schon, so Flugzeug fällt vom Flugzeugträger runter oder diese B2-Bomber, die über was war das in Spanien, wo so ein Bomber zerbröselt ist und da der ganze Strand kontaminiert war und so diese ganzen Sachen. Und da hat mir Frank einen Tipp zu einem Buch gegeben, Command & Control heißt das, und dann habe ich aber gedacht, oh ich habe jetzt keinen Bock jetzt so einen ganzen Weltall zu lesen, gibt es ja nicht auch ein Audiobuch oder ein Film? Und es gibt einen Film und der ist von einem Fernseh, von einem amerikanischen Fernsehsender und der ist auch auf YouTube zu haben und da geht es um ein Unfall in einem Titan II Missile-Sylo, das sind diese Intercontinental-Raketen mit dieser, das waren die größten, fettesten Intercontinental-Raketen der Amis. Und da gab es so einen größeren Zwischenfall und in dieser Doku geht es zum einen um diesen Zwischenfall im Detail mit ganz vielen Zeitzeugen, aber da wird halt auch sehr, also im Buch noch mehr, aber da auch geschildert, wie so dieser ganze Ablauf überhaupt war, wie das gesichert war, wie sozusagen mein Herr dieses unfassbaren Atomarsenals versucht hat, Herr zu werden. Es ist echt interessant, auch so die Meinung zu hören und wie den dann so nach und nach geklickert ist. Je mehr wir diese Raketen da haben, desto mehr bedrohen die nicht nur unseren Gegner, sondern halt auch uns. Und auf amerikanischem Boden, also von diesen Raketen sind mehr Amerikaner, also sind nur Amerikaner gestorben und keine Feinde sozusagen, durch unzählige Unfälle und diese Doku ist eigentlich ganz cool. Zum einen zu diesem ganzen Raketensilo-Thema und wie diese Raketen mit analogster Technik gesteuert und betrieben und maintained wurden. Und eben dieser Unfall ist da auch relativ ausführlich geschildert, kann ich auch empfehlen. Link ist jetzt, genau, ist schon im, hab ich den schon gepostet? Dann ist das Raketenthema auch erledigt.
Also nächsten Dienstag, wie gesagt, ist die nächste Rakete und auch nächsten Dienstag, wenn man keine Raketen gucken will oder vielleicht dann später nachts, weiß nicht, wie sich das überschneidet. Nächsten Dienstag ist wieder Datengarten im Berliner Club. Und da hast du ja, ich hatte die Idee, Tim hat es dann umgesetzt, ne? So war es doch, oder?
Ja, ich hatte den getroffen, oder so kennengelernt.
Genau, der Blue Matt oder auch Matt Corallo von den Bitcoin Core-Developern war ja auf dem Kongress. Und das ist zwar ein ganz netter Typ, auch relativ jung, aber er erzählt viel und gerne und ist sehr gesellig. Und dann hatte ich die Idee, dass wir den ja zu so einem Datengarten mal einladen könnten. Und Tim hat das dann mal umgesetzt und unsere Datengarten, ja, verantwortlich.
Ich muss vielleicht mal sagen, was ein Datengarten ist, weil das kennt ja nur auch nicht jeder.
Na, das kommt ja dann gleich automatisch, wenn ich das alles erkläre. Aber gut, Datengarten bei uns im Berliner Club ist immer jeder 2. Dienstag im Monat eine kleine Veranstaltung. Weil unsere Räume sind jetzt nicht so riesengroß, wo jemand immer irgendwie was vorstellt. Also wir laden immer Leute an, die über ihr Pet-Projekt irgendwie erzählen. Und ich dachte mal, Bitcoin ist ja jetzt nicht so unspannend. Und wenn wir die Chance haben, dass wir hier so einen Bitcoin-Core-Developer irgendwie an den Start kriegen, weil so viele gibt es ja jetzt auch nicht von, dann kriegt man mal Bitcoin-Informationen so ein bisschen aus der ersten Reihe und nicht immer nur so von irgendwelchen Leuten, die sich das da irgendwie mal so von außen angeguckt haben. Und ja, das passiert nächsten Dienstag. Ich hab so die Vermutung, dass es wird scheiße voll werden. Das macht ja nichts, aber wenn wer Angst hat, dass es zu wohl wird, es gibt auch Livestreams davon, wir versuchen das immer live zu streamen. Also man kann sich das dann auch so angucken.
Was heißt versuchen?
Ja genau, in der Regel. Manchmal ist ja auch irgendwie die Schüssel vollgeschneit und dann haben wir keinen richtigen Link oder sonst wie Scheiß. Also passiert immer. Zumindest wird es aber aufgezeichnet und später zur Verfügung gestellt, wie immer, media.ccc.de. Also da muss man sich keine Sorgen machen, falls man nicht vor Ort sein kann. Und der Club hat es ja selber jetzt noch nicht so mit Bitcoins, aber ich habe gesagt, ich mache die bar und werde dann irgendwie eine frisch angelegte Wallet irgendwie alles kassieren, wenn jemand mit Bitcoin kaufen will. Und wenn dann jemand da ist und diese Bitcoins haben will, soll er Bescheid sagen. Wenn nicht, dann nehme ich die halt auf. Risikos ist ja auch nicht. Aus der Kurs fällt dann. Aber ja, es gibt auf jeden Fall Getränke gegen Bitcoin, sagen wir mal so. Ich werde dann schon grüßen. Übrigens, was mich ja noch mal interessieren würde, kannst du ja auch danach erzählen, weiß nicht, wie hast du den noch mal nachträglich kennengelernt, wenn du eigentlich nicht bei den Bitcoin-Jungs rumgestanden hast?
Den habe ich in der Lounge getroffen.
Einfach so.
Ich habe einfach so rumgegammelt, das ist ja auch immer sehr schön und fand mich auf einmal inmitten von so... Das war ein etwas trainisches Erlebnis, ehrlich gesagt, weil es waren alles so junge, aufgeregte... Also Kids will ich jetzt nicht sagen, halt so junge Hacker. Und da merkte ich dann auch mal wieder so, du bist echt ein bisschen älter geworden. Ja, mittlerweile sind so die Unterschiede schon signifikant. Trotzdem konnte ich das halt alles nachvollziehen, im Guten wie im Schlechten. Also diese überhebliche Aufgeregtheit und diese hohe Affinität zu dem aktuellen Thema.
Ich glaube, der Kurs war auch gerade ein bisschen durch die Decke geschossen, oder? Also der Bitcoin Kurs ging ja da gerade ganz schön ab.
Ja, es gab so einen ersten und dann ging es wieder runter und wieder hoch. Weiß ich jetzt auch nicht so. Die beklagten sich auf jeden Fall alle so ein bisschen, dass ja Bitcoin so wenig thematisiert werden würde auf dem Kongress und sich da so ein bisschen vernachlässigt. Woraufhin ich halt meinte, ja, die Talks sind auch ein Ergebnis der Vernetzung dieser Szenen mit dem Club. Und wenn ihr euch sozusagen unterrepräsentiert fühlt, dann ist es auch eure Aufgabe, diese Vernetzung herzustellen. Das war so meine Debatte in dem Moment. Es war einfach noch mal so eine schöne Metadiskussion in dem Moment und habe den auch mal so ein bisschen versucht, die Dynamiken, die jetzt im Club da vorliegen, so ein bisschen zu erläutern und das, was jetzt nicht Teil einer großen Verschwörung ist, sondern, und da merkt ihr auch wieder, was das eigentlich für eine unglaubliche Herausforderung für uns jetzt ist, diese doch sehr weitläufigen Szenen mit uns in Kontakt zu halten. Weil eigentlich brauchst du so für jede Major Technology heutzutage, die man nicht aus den Augen verlieren will und die man irgendwie auch bewerten will, brauchst du halt einfach Leute, die einerseits dem Club so ein bisschen nahe stehen, aber eben auch diesem Thema nahe stehen, um das immer wieder auch diese Relevanz und diese Verbindung auch aktiv zu repräsentieren. Da gibt es sicherlich einige Bereiche, wo das überrepräsentiert ist, also ganze Security-Kram und so weiter, schon immer. Aber bei so New and Emerging Technologies ist das nicht überall unbedingt im ausreichenden Maße. Ich meine, gut, du hast eine gewisse Bitcoin-Affinität, ein paar andere auch, aber mag auch daran gelegen haben. Ja, das habe ich ihm halt so ein bisschen ins Heft geschrieben. Dann stand halt auch der Matt dabei, mit dem ich dann halt ein bisschen später nochmal ins Gespräch kam. Ich fand ihn auch sehr interessant, weil er eben, also er ist ja, wenn ich das richtig sehe, eigentlich so Amerikaner, aber er hat eine längere Zeit in Deutschland verbracht.
Der kann Deutsch.
Der kann Deutsch, also er spricht jetzt nicht so, also ich denke, man kann auf jeden Fall mit ihm kommunizieren. Er will das auch, aber man merkt auch, dass er jetzt noch weit von native entfernt ist. Also er hat jetzt nicht so viele Jahre in Deutschland verbracht, dass es so ein zweites Sprachvenis ist.
Aber es ist gut genug, dass er sich mit jemandem unterhalten kann, der wirklich kein Englisch kann.
Genau, der kommt klar und wir haben dann auch teilweise Deutsch geredet. Das war ganz interessant. Ich fand ihn einfach interessant als Typen, weil er eben auch so, es gibt ja viele, die sind in so einem Thema drin und es gibt auch manchmal so junge, die schon sehr jung, schon sehr weit sind. Aber selten hast du so diese Kombination aus kann was, ist noch sehr jung, aber hat auch so diese special skills, einerseits die Sache auch wirklich vollständig zu verstehen, also so richtig deep drin zu sein und auch so eine gewisse Begabung der Kommunikation, also das dann auch zu vermitteln und auch in gewisser Hinsicht zu repräsentieren.
Also der kann auf jeden Fall reden und deswegen ist er auch ein guter Kandidat.
Genau, und deswegen fand ich den auch sehr interessant und als ihr das dann aufgebracht habt, hab ich dann halt einfach die Verbindung hergestellt.
Ja, ich freu mich schon. Ich weiß noch gar nicht, was er erzählen wird, aber ich denke mal, es wird gut werden.
Ich paste mal jetzt hier auch noch diesen kleinen Artikel, den ich gerade noch rausgesucht hab, zu den Atombombenverlusten in den Chat. Den kann dann vielleicht auch noch in die Show Notes eingepflegt werden. Ach so, dann muss ich den Workflow tun oder wo?
Ja, du kannst gerne beides tun, aber ich nehme nicht pinnen, das mit dem Pinnen funktioniert nicht. Ich hole nachher alle Links da raus.
Fax auch ins Workflow. Ja, und das ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs, weil irgendwie im Freedom of Information Act oder so vor ein paar Jahren wurden halt dann auch so einige Dokumente deklassifiziert, die dann belegen, dass es 1000 oder mehr Incidents gab und nicht nur 34 oder so.
Ja gut, aber da zählt auch jeder kleinste Scheiß schon als Incident.
Ja, aber die sind, wenn du dadurch die Liste gehst, ist wirklich ziemlich viel Serious Shit dabei.
Ja, weil für die deutschen Atommeiler gibt es ja auch eine Liste mit Incidents und da muss eine Schraube irgendwo nachgezogen werden und dann ist das ein Incident. Also die sind da auch sehr pendibel.
Ja, bei denen waren es schon eher ernstere Geschichten.
Ja, vor allen Dingen, man will eigentlich die Liste von den Sophies gar nicht sehen.
Wahrscheinlich auch das, ja.
Wenn es überhaupt eine gibt.
Nach Tschernobyl interessiert das aber auch gar nicht mehr.
Ja, das stimmt natürlich. Wollen wir kurz, ganz kurz über Bier reden? Brewdog Treffen.
Das müssen wir uns auch noch mal etwas entschuldigen. Wir haben das glaube ich so ein bisschen falsch, weiß ich nicht, wurde das falsch kommuniziert. Du hast ja dieses Treffen ausgerufen.
Genau. Das fand auch statt.
Ich hatte das auch in den Kalender reingeworfen. Aber da du dann in der Sendung davor nicht hier warst, haben wir das auch überhaupt nicht mehr auf dem Zeiger gehabt und nicht erwähnt. Wir hatten auch glaube ich alle keine Zeit, aber du warst dann da und andere Leute waren auch da.
Ja, wir waren so gefühlt 20. Linus kam irgendwie kurz nach Mitternacht noch mit einer Truppe Leute an und fragte dann ganz pikiert, wo denn Tim wäre. Lustigerweise waren zwei Jungs aus Hamburg da, die meinten, sowas haben wir noch nie gemacht. Wir sind einfach über das Wochenende nach Berlin gefahren.
Das war nicht total geil.
Extra für dich? Ja, die haben da auch einen Freund besucht irgendwie. Aber es war sehr nett. Also es gab jetzt keine großen Exzesse oder so, die berichtenswert gewesen wären, sondern wir hatten da einen von den ganz langen Tischen für uns und haben da, naja, worüber man so redet unter... Unter Nerds.
Also mit Telefonen geredet.
Haben die denn bei Pokémon gespielt?
Kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen.
Zumindest hab ich niemanden erwischt dabei.
Gut, Letty.
Gerade wenn ich die Schokolade esse.
Das war jetzt Absicht.
Warum wusste ich das?
Interessiert mich jetzt, hab ich hier gerade in der Liste entdeckt. Musste mal berichten. Du warst im...
Ich habe mir...
Im NS-Aua.
Ich habe mir einen Tag lang den NS-Aua gegeben.
Den letzten Tag. Bitte? Also die letzte Sitzung jetzt sozusagen.
Die letzte...
Oh Gott.
Letzte Woche Donnerstag? Weiß ich nicht mehr, im Januar. Die letzte Sitzung im Januar war das. Und ich dachte mir, weil ich ja auch den Technischen Aufklärung Podcast höre, gucken wir uns das Ganze echt mal selber an. Und es ist sehr anstrengend gewesen. Na ja, du sitzt halt erstmal schon mal acht Stunden und musst zuhören. Und wenn, also ich mein Strickzeug dabei gehabt hab, weil ich anders nicht zuhören kann ohne den Faden zu verlieren. Nee, selber gemerkt. Nein, ich bin 35 Reihen weit gekommen. Egal.
Ist das gut?
Jaja, ich hab sehr viel gestrickt. Nee, aber ich find... Was hab ich gesagt? Anstrengend, genau. Anstrengend war es definitiv. Vielleicht zu den Zeugen. Es waren zum einen Roland Pofaller da, der damals Chef des Bundeskanzleramts war. Bundeskanzleramts, genau. Und Günther Heiß, der die Fachaufsicht über die Geheimdienste eigentlich haben sollte im Bundeskanzleramt.
Aber offensichtlich nicht hat.
Genau, und ich meine, der Inhalt kann man nachhören oder nachlesen bei Netzpolitik. Was ich eher sehr spannend fand, war die Art und Weise, wie sich die Leute da so geben, also während der Sitzung und wenn die Sitzungen unterbrochen sind. Also man hat ganz schön gesehen, dass Günther Heiß, der noch im Amt ist, der noch nicht gegangen worden ist, in der Vernehmung super zurückhalten war und sehr darauf bedacht, nicht zu sagen, was ihnen ein Job kosten könnte. Also das hat man schon gemerkt. Genau. Und wenn man dann aber zwischen den Sitzungen ihn so beobachtet hat, wie er mit seinen Buddys da am Reden war, hat man halt schon diese Arroganz der Leute auch mitbekommen. Also das Profaller irgendwie mit Arroganz nicht geizt, das glaube ich jedem bekannt. Aber das fand ich sehr, sehr interessant, diese ganze Art und Weise, wie sich die Leute so geben in so einem Untersuchungsausschuss und der nicht wille, einen Sachverhalt aufzuklären. Das fand ich interessant halt mal live auch zu sehen. Ich war vorher noch nie in so einem Untersuchungsausschuss, wahrscheinlich wie die meisten. Und es ging halt da vor allen Dingen um einen Sachverhalt, wo Pofalla heißt und oh Gott, krieg ich den Namen noch auf die Reihe? Schindler, einen Gespräch hatten und um dieses Gespräch ging dieser Untersuchungsausschuss eigentlich hauptsächlich. Schindler hat halt zugegeben, dass was gesagt wurde und die zwei anderen haben halt darauf bestanden, dass Sachen nie gesagt wurden. An einem Punkt war der SPD-Abgeordnete Flink schon so weit, dass Pofalla schon zugeben hätte müssen, dass jemand lügt und hat sich halt ganz gekonnt aus der Affäre gezogen mit, oh, also ich müsste jetzt mal aufs Klo, das hat natürlich überhaupt nichts mit der Frage zu tun, aber können wir mal kurz die Sitzung unterbrechen? Und sind auch ordentlich die Fetzen sozusagen geflogen, wie die Abgeordneten die Befragung geführt haben, also Konstantin von Notz, Martina Renner und auch Ströbele und Flisek auch von der SPD, der hat auch ordentlich nachgebohrt, der mochte den Profiler auch überhaupt nicht, das hat man sehr gemerkt. Also es war auch sehr interessant zu sehen, wie die so fahren, wie sie das so führen, wie sie die Leute auch grillen.
Aber um jemanden grillen zu können, müsste man ja auch irgendwie was an der Hand haben.
Hatten sie auch.
Aber was denn, die können doch immer sagen, kann ich mich nicht erinnern, weiß ich nicht oder sonst was. Es gibt überhaupt gar keine Druckmittel aus den Personen, irgendwas rauszuholen, oder?
Na ja, wenn sie mit den Aussagen der anderen konfrontiert werden, schon interessant wäre es halt zu sehen, wie die Leute reagieren, wenn sie wirklich eine Aussage mit den drei Personen hätten. Wenn die halt immer nur alleine da sitzen, können sie halt echt immer sagen, ja, nee, hat er nicht gesagt. Alter, muss er ihnen was anderes erzählt haben, so nach dem Motto. Aber die haben das halt auch aus den Unterlagen, sie haben vieles halt auch zitiert, oder nicht zitiert, darauf verwiesen auf den nicht öffentlichen Teil. Was dann natürlich dir als Zuhörer dann so ein bisschen ist so, aha, okay, nicht öffentlich. Ich hab überhaupt keinen Plan, wobei redet, und dann werden halt so Akten hin und her gereicht, damit diejenigen weiß, was da eigentlich gerade gefragt wurde. Sie können halt schon in der Tat die Leute mit Dingen konfrontieren, aber profallerweise weiß halt auch, wie er sich rausredet, weil er Jurist ist. Und das merkt man halt auch. Und wie er halt auch die Argumentationen dann führt. Und wie er sich halt so gibt in dem Ganzen. Also bei zwei Situationen dachte ich, sowohl mit dem Fliesäcker als auch mit Konstantin von Notz, die gehen gleich vor die Tür und hauen sich.
War das der Profaller, der jetzt bei der Bahn irgendwie ging?
Er wurde zur Bahn gegangen.
Was war denn so dein, was war das erste Mal im Bundestag? Und war irgendwas so, wie du es dir dachtest, oder war irgendwas so anders, ganz anders als du es dir dachtest?
Hmm, anders als ich es mir dachte.
Also bist du da so rein und dann so, oh ja.
Das lustigste war erstmal. Ja gut, das ist halt großes Gebäude. Ich war halt im Landtag in Sachsen mal. Also da kennt man jetzt so diese Gebäude, wie sie aufgebaut sind so ein bisschen. Das hat mir jetzt nichts Besonderes an Gefühl gegeben, wenn du das meinst. Spannend war der Einlass. Ich hatte Angst, dass mir darauf hingewiesen wurde, dass ich vielleicht aufpassen sollte mit den Stricknadeln. Und ich hatte kurz überlegt, beim Fliegen darfst du sie in der Tat nicht mitnehmen, wenn sie eine gewisse Zentimetermaß überschreiten, auch wenn sie aus Holz sind. Ich hatte kurz schon überlegt, ob ich sie mir in die Haare stecke. Ich kann die halt abschrauben, sodass du die zwei Nadeln einzeln hast und die Strüppe, sag ich mal. Sodass du, die schauen ja generell bei Sicherheitskontrollen eigentlich nieder, was du in den Haaren hast. Also jedenfalls nie beim Fliegen. Ich bin auch mit meinen Haarstäben rein, die dieses Maß von Stricknadeln überschreiten. Richtig, Stricknadeln ja auch nicht dann in dem Fall. Die haben zwar hinten Metall, richtig, aber die gehen dir ja nicht an die Haare mit diesem Metalldetektor. Und wenn du piepst, was bei mir durch meine Piercings vielleicht auch häufiger passiert, oder Schuhe, ist dann so dieses... Ich piep dann eh meistens. Und wenn du denen dann zeigst, hier, ich hab hier so ein Piercing.
Die Trojanische Letti.
Und dann denken die sich so, ach, alles klar. Und so harmlos, wie die aussieht, gehen sie mal weiter. Aber kurz meine Idee so, stecken wir sie halt in die Haare, damit man damit reinkommt.
Du kannst das Security-Theater gut spielen, hab ich das Gefühl.
Ich bin so harmlos. Ich bin so harmlos. Also ich find auch. Ich find auch total harmlos. Also es war alles nicht überraschend für dich? Na überraschend, also die Art und Weise halt. Ich weiß nicht, ich find halt, wenn sich...
Fandest du es offener, als du es dir gedacht hättest, oder inklusiver einladender, oder eher verschlossener, abgesicherter?
Nö, das überhaupt nicht. Also man muss sich ja anmelden, ehe wenn man zu diesen Sitzungen will. Aber sobald man einmal drin ist, kann man sich mehr oder weniger frei bewegen. Ich war ja auch irgendwie in dieser Cafeteria essen. Dann wirst du da halt in Ruhe gelassen, musst halt nur deinen Ausweis wieder abholen am Ende des Tages. Aber da wirst du von niemandem belästigt, kannst da rumrennen und dir alles anschauen, Leute anquatschen im Prinzip. Das fand ich, so stelle ich es mir vor. So sollte das sein. Offen. Da war jetzt nichts, wo ich irgendwie...
Also hast du ja sozusagen als Bürgerin dieses Staates dich willkommen gefühlt im Zentrum der Macht.
Also im außen Zentrum der Macht. Nee, dann hätte ich noch einen roten Teppich erwartet. Da war kein roter Teppich. Also wenn man den Bürgern schon dieses Haus öffnen sollte, dann auch mit rotem Teppich und sie sind hier willkommen.
Was ich am Bundestag ganz cool finde, ist ja, dass sie halt Teile unsaniert gelassen haben. Ich weiß nicht, ob du die Teile gesehen hast, wo halt noch so die Graffitis von den russischen Soldaten und so sozusagen zu sehen sind. Die Kriegszeit bei der Führung zu sehen. Und das ist halt, das haben jetzt so diverse Kollegen, die halt zugezogen sind aus aller Herren Welt, Länder, halt dann hinterher so ganz beeindruckt gesagt, als Tim gerade fragte, wie hast du dir das so vorgestellt und wie war es denn so? Muss ich gerade daran denken, dass mir wirklich schon diverse Leute gesagt haben, ja also ich hätte ja nicht gedacht, dass die jetzt also in ihrem Parlament da, also die Graffitis und so weiter und voll krass und die waren total beeindruckt davon. Ich hab da nie so besonders drüber nachgedacht, aber so durch diesen Spiegel von außen nochmal, ja das ist eigentlich schon echt cooles Statement.
Ja, dann sollte ich mir mal so eine Führung geben. Das hat man ja dann im Prinzip nicht dazu bekommen.
Das war nicht inklusive.
Das war nicht inklusive, ne. Leider, leider.
Ich hab da mal einen Podcast, einen Podcast rausgemacht aus so einer Führung.
Aus so einer Führung durch den Bundestag?
Damals im Rahmen von unserem Bundesradio-Experiment.
Mit wem denn?
Mit einer Dame, die solche Führungen macht. Mit der sind wir durch den Bundestag gelatscht und haben uns, also ich und Philipp Banzer haben das zusammen ja gemacht seinerzeit. Das war dieser Experimental-Podcast, den wir mal so probiert haben.
Spannender fände ich das ja mit einem Politiker, der mir die Zeit hatte, so mit ihm dann auch erzählen lassen.
Ja, aber nur wenn er gerade abgewählt wurde, weil sonst macht er ja trotzdem nur noch Wahlkampf.
Ja, es kommt glaub ich drauf an, wer.
Naja, schon, aber trotzdem.
Nee, da gibt's echt solche und solche. Also Pech haben, aber ja, geht auch anders. Alright, nachzuhören im...
Technische Aufklärung.
Podcast Technische Aufklärung mit Letty als Gast. Sehr schön. Wird gleich verlinkert. Das ist die letzte Sendung, ne? Ich hoffe, du hast was Kluges beitragen können.
Nee, ich rede nie kluge Dinge. Also bitte Tim. Kannst du bitte diese Illusionen nicht aufrechterhalten?
Jo, haben wir noch Themen?
Na so, ich hab auf jeden Fall noch ein bisschen Kleinkram.
Bisschen was ist da noch?
Buckel, du bist jetzt wieder ein Lohn und Brot.
Ich bin wieder dran gewöhnt. Ich bin wieder einer von denen, die das Wochenende als eigenes Konzept wahrnehmen und schätzen und darauf sich freuen und jetzt am Mittwoch schon denken, na, ich hab's schon geschafft.
Das sagst du auch schon ab 10 Uhr morgens Mahlzeit? Oder ist es so schlimm, ist es noch nicht?
Nee, Mahlzeit. Ich bin ein Mahlzeitverweigerer.
Kein Mahlzeit-Sager, na dann geht's noch.
Aber ich probier das jetzt gerade wieder mit dem Arbeits- oder Lebenszeitverkaufen. Und willst du da jetzt noch was Spezielles hören? Du hast da so einen Punkt aufgeschrieben. Achso, ich hab das geschrieben, stimmt. Genau, ich hab nämlich heute und gestern eigentlich schon die ganze Woche Go programmiert.
Wie war's gewesen?
Das hatten wir hier schon ein paar Mal so angeschnitten als Themenkarte in den vergangenen Sendungen. Und ich hatte mir das ja auch schon mal angeguckt und dann als uninteressant verworfen. Und jetzt sieht es aber so aus, dass ich wohl so ein Projekt mal machen müsste jetzt mit Go. Und hab dann gedacht, okay, das fängt erst in zwei Wochen an. Da kann ich jetzt mal anfangen, mich damit nochmal etwas ernsthafter auseinanderzusetzen. Und natürlich, wie es dann so ist, Confirmation Bias und alles.
Ist nicht besser geworden, meinste?
Ja, und vor allen Dingen, nichts schlägt eher lang in meiner Favoritenliste der Programmiersprachen für irgendwie Services und Server und Backends und so. Aber auf jeden Fall ist es auch durchaus mal ganz interessant, natürlich wieder über den Teller ranzugucken und mal eine andere Perspektive einzunehmen, weil dann ja auch über das schon geliebte irgendwie neue Erkenntnisse rausputzen. Zum Beispiel, hatte ich vorhin schon Tim erzählt, ist mir so aufgefallen, dass so ein ganz grundsätzlicher Paradigmenunterschied existiert zwischen Erlang und den meisten anderen Sprachen. Zum Beispiel bei Go, du machst halt dein Executable, dein Programm, und das startet und es ist bestrebt auch zu beenden. Also es erfüllt seine Aufgabe und dann macht es sich aus im Idealfall. Und bei Erlang ist es halt so, du startest also diese Erlang-VM.
Und sie tut alles, sich nicht zu beenden.
Und sie ist der gewünschte Zustand, sie ist immer an. Also du schreibst halt ein Programm, ein Actor oder was auch immer, der da von so einem Supervisor in dieser VM halt so hängt. Und dieser Supervisor versucht auch alles in seiner Macht stehende dein Programm am Laufen zu halten. Also dieser Wunsch oder das normale Verhalten, dass so das Programm startet, was tut und dann sich beendet, ist da einfach nicht da. Und das fiel mir jetzt bei Go so auf, weil Go hat ja auch diese Go-Routines, um asynchron Sachen zu machen oder so Lightweight Threats sozusagen. Und wenn du aber nicht auf die wartest, also wenn du startest so ein paar Sachen, die dann asynchron laufen und dann in der Main Loop oder Main Funktion ist dann halt Return und Ende, dann werden die auch einfach abgeräumt, ohne dass jetzt darauf gewartet. Ja, es ist ja auch, also es ist verständlich, nur man kann das, also wenn man das aus Erlang halt jetzt nicht so gewöhnt ist, ne?
Das ist eine andere Philosophie, ne?
Man muss dann wieder ganz explizit sagen, ja, nee, ich hab jetzt so und so viele Go-Routines gestartet und wir haben jetzt hier eine Waiting Group und da zählen wir die alle und wenn die sich dann beenden, dann ziehen wir die wieder aus der Waiting Group ab und dann, wenn die Waiting Group bei Null ist, dann darf das Programm halt ausgehen, ne? Und dann sitzt halt erstmal so da und ich so so, aber na gut.
Erlang ist ja in der Hinsicht eigentlich auch viel mehr eigenes Betriebssystem als Go, was sehr viel mehr so diesen, ich bin so wie C in einem 21. Jahrhundert.
Ich weiß nicht, also ich hatte immer das Problem, Go irgendwas zuzuordnen. Das ist so auf der einen Seite viele moderne Konzepte und auch gute Konzepte auf der anderen Seite denkst du so, da fehlen auch Teile irgendwie.
Na ja, es ist halt...
Gut ist lange her, dass ich es probiert hab.
Genau, also ich...
Aber man liest immer wieder, dass die Toolchain irgendwie nicht so doll ist. Der Debugger funktioniert nicht so richtig und dort sind es auch nicht.
Also soweit bin ich noch nicht gekommen. Aber was auch auffällt, ist, sie hat ein Feature, was ich ja prinzipiell sehr schätze, wenn die Sprache klein ist. Also wenn es nicht viele Konzepte gibt und nicht viele Wege eine Variable zuzuweisen, sondern im Idealfall vielleicht ein. Also nicht wie bei C++ oder so, wo es dann 5 oder 6 verschiedene Varianten gibt.
Ja, aber C++ ist ein Gegenbeispiel zu allem.
Ich sag ja nur, es ist ja auch bei Ruby so. Da würden mir auch spontan 3 oder 4 Varianten einfallen, eine Variable zu assignen. Das ist bei Go halt relativ eingeschränkt auch nur. Aber es gibt halt auch als Schleifenkonzept nur eine Vorloop. Es gibt als Conditional nur ein If. Es gibt halt keine Convenience wie Map oder Fold oder Filter. Nee, gibt's alles nicht. Und es ist auch bewusst so und es wird auch nie in diese Sprache kommen.
Aber sie haben Closures.
Ja, das haben sie.
Aber Map und Fold, unser Kram ist ja meistens so Standardbibliothek, eher als Teil der Sprache.
Ja, aber wenn du das benutzt, dann ist das schon in den Go-Jünger-Augen kein Ideomatic Go mehr.
Ach du Scheiße.
Und dann sitzt du halt da und du hast so einen Hash. Und der ist unsortiert, das ist ja okay. Und jetzt willst du also die Keys da in einer sortierten Variante, also die Values und so weiter, und dann fängst du halt wirklich an. Du machst eine Vorloop und holst dir die Keys raus in eine extra Collection. Dann sortierst du die Collection, dann loops du über die sortierte Collection und holst dir dann mit dem Key aus dem Hash die richtigen Values raus. Es ist halt immer so ein sehr klein, gliedriges Fummeln. Natürlich kommt das, weil die halt... Also bei Go ist halt der Performance-Gedanke und Speicherverbrauch und alles halt, das ist so einer der Hauptaugenmerke, würde ich mal sagen. Deswegen, klar so ein Map und ein Reject und so weiter, das kostet halt ein bisschen Performance. Das ist halt nicht das optimalste vielleicht, aber wenn man so einmal den gepolsterten Elfenbeinhebel in der Hand hatte und dann wieder so Steine klopfen muss plötzlich, dann ist es...
Aber sag mal Huckel, du hast ja letztens schon geschrieben, dass irgendwie außer Erlangen ist ja alles andere, kriegst du ja irgendwie Brechreiz. Wo sind denn jetzt so die coolen Programme, zum Beispiel auf meinem Mac, die in Erlangen geschrieben sind? Zum Beispiel mit Goi, gibt's das?
Nein, nein, warte mal.
Du hast ja so grundsätzlich erst mal über alle Sprachen weggerantet.
Nein, das ist bei mir immer mit Fokus auf Backend-Stuff erst mal, weil ich mach ja nichts anderes.
Aber das steht nicht dabei.
Ja, das stimmt.
Weil dann könnte man schon so kriegen, entweder ist der Typ mega arrogant und eingebildet bei seiner Kacksprache oder irgendwie stimmt hier was nicht richtig.
Nein, nein, also ich würde auf jeden Fall, ich hätte jetzt auch sofort gesagt, also nicht jede Sprache ist für jede das Problem geeignet, aber das wäre kein Fall. Und auch Bo, Go hatte jetzt auch, würde ich sagen, einen etwas anderen Fokus als Erlang.
Bei Go habe ich so ein bisschen das Gefühl, dass es aber zwischen allen Türen sitzt. Also Google versucht, Go jetzt sehr stark ins Backend zu fokussieren, aber da fehlen halt dann auch wieder Goodies, die du in Erlang hast. Also irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht so recht, wo sie damit hinwollen.
Jetzt ist ja gerade der große Hype, hier Microservices aktuell, und dann natürlich alles mit Docker und dann deine Docker-Container orchestrieren und alles in der Cloud und so weiter. Und da finden das halt einige Leute toll, weil du eben nicht eine VM in der VM in der VM hast. Also zum Beispiel das ganze Orchestrieren und wo was läuft, das machen die sozusagen auf ihrem Cloud-Management-Docker-Ebene. Und wenn dann Erlang kommt und im Prinzip dieses ganze Cluster-Management, inklusive Kommunikation, Queuing, den ganzen Kram schon mitbringt und sie das aber in so einen kleinen Docker-Container sperren, der dann von einer anderen Ebene quasi skaliert wird, dann denken sie sich so ja, aber dann, und dann wollen wir doch lieber so ein kleinteiliges, einfaches Binary haben, was wir halt irgendwo hinschippen und dann diesen Docker-Container halt laufen lassen. Und da, wenn man so eine Herangehensweise hat, dann kann man das schon sinnvoll finden. Allerdings fällt mir halt eben ganz oft auf, dass alles, was die sich jetzt mühsam da oben drüber stricken lassen, bringt halt Erlang schon größtenteils halt alles mit. Deswegen sitze ich dann halt oft so da und denke mir so äh, wieso macht ihr denn jetzt hier, also gibt's doch alles, schuld.
Aber du musst natürlich sehen, wo das herkommt. Also dieser ganze Docker-Micro-Service-Diskram kommt natürlich aus einer Welt, die sehr lange monolithische Java-Riesen-Applikationen gemacht hat. Und wenn du das nur lange genug machst, dann merkst du, wenn du über ein Team von zwölf Leuten hinauskommst, dann kommst du nirgendwo mehr hin, weil die Leute sich beim Deployen ihrer Changes ständig gegenseitig auf den Füßen stehen. Und dann willst du natürlich diese Microservices haben.
Das erinnert mich irgendwie so ein bisschen an Leute, die ZFS irgendwie mit Raid-Karten irgendwie benutzen und dann irgendwie so die Raid-Levels machen und dann das ZFS einfach so oben drauf legen.
Ja, das ist halt, und das Ding ist, wenn du dir dann anguckst, wie sie mit ihrem Kubernetes und was nicht alles für Cluster da zusammenbauen, das ist, also der Monolith ist es dann vielleicht nicht mehr, aber das, was du an Schwungmasse da akkumulierst, um am Ende eine Webseite zu serven oder was auch immer, das ist...
Ich widerspreche dir überhaupt nicht.
Genau, also das ist jetzt auch ein anderes Thema. Aber ja, so ich mein, ich hab jetzt ein Programm schon gehabt, was ich in Ruby und in Erlang mal geschrieben hatte und das habe ich jetzt sozusagen die letzten Tage mal in Go geschrieben oder umgehackt. Und was halt einem dann eben schon auffällt, zum Beispiel dieses Error Handling, was wir ja auch schon mal hatten, also es gibt halt keins, so man muss halt... Also es gibt schon den Typ Error, aber es gibt kein Exception Handling oder so, Catch oder Rescue oder was auch immer Konzepte. Man muss halt immer selber nachfragen, na, hat denn alles geklappt? Und wenn nicht, dann kommt hier dieses If Statement und dann machen wir was. Das ist schon auch so ein bisschen merkwürdig, dass... Ja, das ist halt alles so ein bisschen, ja ich sag mal, mühseliger, aber ja.
Legt das nicht dann auch furchtbar diese Sprache auf oder dein Code? Also wenn du alles dann...
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, wenn... Ich kann es noch nicht sagen, weil dieses Programm, was ich da hatte, das war halt im Prinzip so eine Coding-Challenge, die ich bei einem der Job-Angebote mal machen sollte, ja. Und die hab ich dann halt, die sollte ein Ruby sein. Ich hab's dann noch in R-Lang gehackt, weil ich wissen wollte, wie es funktional dann aussehen würde. Und jetzt hab ich's halt in Go gehackt und das macht halt eine Sache. Und der Code, der dafür nötig ist, waren jetzt, glaub ich, 200 Zeilen oder so. Das war angenommen, du hast eine Konferenz mit zwei Tracks und in jeder, in jedem Track zwei Sessions, also eine Morning- und eine Afternoon-Session, ja.
Also insgesamt vier Sessions.
Genau, die sind so und so lang jeweils unterschiedlich oder so viel Kapazität und das ist jetzt ein Stapel Talks mit unterschiedlichen Durations, also ein Bin-Filling-Problem.
Okay, das musst du irgendwie einsortieren?
Muss man halt sortieren und das heißt, man muss halt rausfinden, ah, es ist ein Bin-Filling-Problem, durch halt ein bisschen googeln, die Algorithmen alle mal kurz gucken und welcher ist jetzt der beste und das dann implementieren. Und das ist dann, also es hat ganz gut Spaß gemacht, weil ich vorher noch nie so diese Bin-Filling-Probleme mir überhaupt mal so vor's Auge geführt hatte. Und insofern hat sich das jetzt gerade ganz gut angeboten, das jetzt auch noch in der dritten Sprache mal zu hacken. Und die Code-Menge war überschaubar, nur dass du eben wirklich, gerade wenn du so dann durch deine Kollektion durchiterieren willst und die mal anders bearbeiten und dann musst du immer so und dann gibt's halt bei Go und das ist halt auch ein ganz großer Schmerz jetzt für mich gewesen, wenn du halt von so einer funktionalen immutable Sprache kommst, wo halt alles immutable ist. Bei Go sind halt Teile, werden bei Value weitergereicht und manche halt bei Referencers. Es gibt halt auch Pointers, ne? Und manche Sachen musst du halt idealer, also sonst musst du dich wirklich verbiegen, wenn du es nicht mit Pointer machst, schon fast. Also es ist dann in der Sprache, fühlt sich das schon falsch an, wenn du dann dich extra bemühst, das zu kopieren und die ganze Zeit guckst du dir der Pointer um die Ecke und sagst so, nimm mich, es geht alles hier schneller. Ja, und da fühl ich mich dann halt so ein bisschen schmutzig. Es gibt so ganz viele Funktionen in der Standard Library, die führst du aus und du weißt jetzt, dass es jetzt global verändert einfach so. Oder Hashmaps sind nicht sozusagen Thread-safe oder Go-Routine-safe, also du musst dich explizit bei den Hashmaps darum kümmern, dass Lesen und Schreiben synchronisiert ist, wohingegen andere Typen das Problem nicht haben und es sind so lauter so kleine...
Na ja gut, aber Hashmaps Thread-safe zu bekommen ist schwierig, sagen wir mal so.
Ja gut, du könntest es halt eben...
Das bietet dir kaum eine Library-Implementierung von den Dingern.
Klar, der Weg wäre ja, dass es dann einfach wieder Immutable und Copy, aber dann kostet es halt Performance und RAM im Wesentlichen. Genau, irgendwas ist immer. Aber wenn du dich eben mal so an diese funktionale Immutable-Welt gewöhnt hast, dann jetzt wieder so zurück in dieses ich führe jetzt diesen Call aus und es ist global im ganzen Programm im Speicher geändert. Und du suchst so händeringend nach irgendeiner anderen Art ohne Seiteneffekt jetzt das zu transformieren. Ja, geht halt nicht dann manchmal. Aber ich gucke mal jetzt, wie das so weitergeht. Ich habe heute auch mal einen kleinen Web-Server gehackt in Erlang und in Go, um mal so eine simple statische Route, die einfach nur Hello World in HTML erinnert, mal zu gucken, ob es da irgendwelche signifikanten Unterschiede gibt, wenn man da mal gegenpustet, möglichst schnell. Das Erlang war ein bisschen schneller. Aber hat halt auch, das Go-Binary waren 6 Megabyte im RAM. Das Erlang nimmt dann halt mit der VM gleich 60 Megabyte. Also einfach nur VM hochfahren.
Hat auch irgendeine Laufzeit, also ein Runtime, die dabei ist?
Nee, du kompilst einfach nur Binaries.
Ja, aber da muss auch mindestens ein Garbage-Collector dabei sein.
Achso, ja, ein Garbage-Collector hat es, ja.
Ja, aber ich dachte noch, das ist nicht mehr State of the Art.
Behauptet ja auch keiner, dass Go State of the Art ist.
Aber es ist, also du kannst schon sehen, dadurch das es so eine C Nähe hat, dass du die Typen haltest ja auch Static Typed, ne? Also so nennt man das ja, wenn man da überall... Also es ist schon bestimmt super performant und sicherlich deutlich performanter. Zum Beispiel gilt es ja auch als eine System Programming Language, also als Ersatz für irgendwelche dynamischen Scriptsprachen, weil du eben einfach ein Binary hast und nicht dann noch deine Python Runtime oder dein Ruby oder dein sonst was da immer mitschleppen musst. Und man muss halt sagen, das was sie in der Standard Library haben, also sie haben schon einige Sachen, die so gerade für System Jobs schon convenient sind. Also gerade so Zeitformate, Parsen und so Kram, was man halt gerne auch mal mit Shell-Skripten oder irgendwie so Zeug macht, das gibt es da dann schon. Und da könnte ich mir schon vorstellen, dass das vielleicht sogar eine ganz sinnvolle Alternative ist. Im Gegensatz zu, ich installiere mir jetzt Python 27 und 30 und 31 und dazu noch ein Ruby 18 und 19 und das Perl, das darf auch nicht fehlen. Und ein Lua-Interpreter ist ja auch manchmal noch gefragt.
Also Ruby ist mir inzwischen ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln. Wir benutzen irgendwie Rake, um so ein paar Build-Tasks auszuführen. Und ich weiß nicht, das ist irgendwie, dieses Ruby ist eine Diva. Also es gibt Tage, da musst du Bundle-Exec-Rake machen, und es gibt Tage, da musst du Rake machen. Und es ist völlig unklar, warum man mal das eine funktioniert und mal das andere. Ja, das ist aber... Also ich hab's nicht verstanden.
Das ist zwar nicht direkt ein Ruby-Problem, aber es ist mittlerweile ein Problem in Wiremins. Bei Go hingegen, das fand ich auch krass. Also es ist ja eine sehr opinionated Sprache. Also die haben einen Go-Formatter, der dir sagt, wie Go zu formatieren ist. Das kann man argumentieren. In großen Teams gibt's dann halt keine Debatte, wie viel Spaces oder Tabs oder Spaces oder die geschweifte Klammer bei einer Vorloop in derselben Zeile oder in der nächsten Zeile. Dieses Gespräch fällt einfach weg. Weil Go sagt dir, wie das so sein hat. Ich find's nicht geil. Das heißt, sie benutzen Tabs zum Beispiel. Bin ich ja kein Freund von.
Was heißt, sie benutzen Tabs?
Na, wenn du deinen Code durch den Go-Format schickst, dann benutzen sie Tabs zum Eindrücken und nicht Spaces.
Ja, aber musst du sie verwenden, damit das funktioniert wie bei Python?
Nee, das musst du nicht. Aber es ist dann kein ideomatic Go, wie es so schön heißt. Das heißt, die richtigen Go-Leute, die runzeln die Stirn. Dann ist es CamelCase und so Zeug.
Kennst du das? You have to save the princess in acht verschiedenen Programmiersprachen?
Hatten wir glaube ich schon mal.
Und da ist auch Go dabei. Da steht, you have Go. Und dann stehen da zwei Typen. We don't support free captured princesses. We already have the free princesses in the standard library.
Und so, was soll ich sagen mit diesem Opinionated? Achso, genau, bei Go ist es ja so, du musst ein Work-Environment haben. Und alle deine, also das heißt im Prinzip, du hast ein Directory auf deinem Rechner, wo alle Go-Projekte rein gehören. Egal was du machst. Wenn die nicht in diesem Go-Path sind...
Ach, der Go-Path.
Schlimmer. Naja, es hat seine Vorteile tatsächlich, aber es hat auch seine Nachteile zum Beispiel verschiedene Versionen von dem gleichen Package. Also wenn du Dependencies hast in deinem Go-Projekt, die werden halt auch in dieses Work-Environment, in diesen Go-Path da rein gefaltet unter den entsprechenden Domänen. Das heißt, wenn du ein Package von GitHub hast, dann geht das unter go-path-source-github.com-projekt-name. Und wenn du das halt nicht machst, dann werden die Libraries nicht gefunden. Aber verschiedene Versionen, wie das supportet, wird es mir jetzt noch nicht ganz klar. Vielleicht geht das ja auch irgendwie, aber es ist schon wirklich... Also die geben dir einfach sehr viel vor, wie du zu arbeiten hast, wie du zu formatieren hast. Und das geht mir als kleinem Programmierer-Freigeist schon etwas auf den Bürzel.
Aber ehrlich gesagt muss ich sagen, gerade wenn man in größeren Teams arbeitet, ist es eigentlich sehr angenehm, wenn du einen Standard hast, über den nicht diskutiert wird. Bei uns ist das jetzt auch so, wir haben halt einen Formatter. Also diesen Clang-Formatter, der ist halt einmal eingestellt und wenn du Code geschrieben hast, dann lässt du einmal den Formatter drüber laufen und dann ist fertig. Und dann wird auch nicht mehr diskutiert. Und am Ende des Tages, wenn du das irgendwie ein halbes Jahr gemacht hast, dann denkst du dir, diese Formatierungsdiskussionen, die sind auch so für ein Eimer, weil was soll das?
Ich war halt immer in so Teams, wo es glücklicherweise alle der einigermaßen gleichen Meinung waren.
Wir haben halt einmal darüber diskutiert, wie man das Ding jetzt einstellt, wie es jetzt formatieren soll und dann speicherst du das Setting ab und danach ist dann Feierabend. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz angenehm.
Naja, ich werde mal sehen. Ich habe den Format dann noch nicht bei mir eingeschaltet. Ich habe ihn heute mal so testhalber über meinen Code laufen lassen. Dann dachte ich mir so, okay, ich brauche noch.
Je früher, desto besser. Du gewöhnst dich dann ganz schnell daran, wie der Code aussieht. Wenn er dann nicht mehr so aussieht, bist du selber derjenige, der denkt, was soll denn das? Wir haben doch diesen Formatter.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall so der erste Eindruck ist jetzt geschildert. Ich würde trotzdem so Backends weiterhin lieber in Erlang schreiben. Und ich würde auch nach wie vor dafür werben, dass Leute, die so Server Software schreiben, sich mal dieses Erlang wirklich nochmal angucken und nochmal. Und vielleicht auch das Elixier, wenn es sein muss. Weil da ist einfach so viel drin. Naja, ich finde es größtenteils unnötig. Aber wenn man Erlang schon kann, dann bietet einem Elixier nicht viel Mehrwert. Wenn man gerade umsteigt, dann ist natürlich die syntaktische und fluffige Toolchain-Erleichterung, also bietet einem einen leichteren Einstieg, sage ich mal. Aber mich reizt Elixier nicht.
Da hatte ich schon mal so eine interessante Diskussion mit so einem Die Hard Erlang Coder, den wir auch gemeinsam kennen, den Namen ich jetzt aber immer nicht nenne.
Und?
Groß und opinionated. Ich fragte einfach nur so, ja, Elixier und so, und dann brachte er wirklich ein sehr interessantes Argument. Das ist jetzt so wörtlich, glaube ich, nicht mehr zusammenkriege, aber er meinte im Kern, also wenn ich mir Erlang Codes anschaue, dann weiß ich genau, was es tut. Und zwar nicht, weil ich es kenne, sondern weil es in Erlang halt eigentlich nur One Way to Do It gibt. Und Elixier ist halt so mit diesem, kannst du so schreiben, kannst du aber auch so schreiben, und übrigens, guck mal, hier kannst du auch so schreiben, mit dieser Syntax-Sugar-Geschichte, die ja auch bei Ruby so ein bisschen mit drin ist, und dem auch so andere Programmiersprachen so anheimfallen.
Anles?
Ja, so kannst du noch kürzer machen, kannst noch was weglassen und so. Und tatsächlich, was es halt auf den ersten Blick eigentlich für einen Programmierer einfacher machen soll, im Sinne von, du musst nicht so viel tippen, ist im Umkehrschluss eine echte Behinderung für Leute, die diesen Code lesen müssen, die ihn vielleicht nicht geschrieben haben.
Ja, da muss man lange programmieren, um das zu merken.
Du schaust dann hin und dann so, hm, aber das kenne ich doch anders. Dann speicherst du es nicht als das Richtige ab oder kannst dem nicht die Bedeutung zuwenden. Du schaffst so eine Doppeldeutigkeit ohne Not.
Das ist ja aber im Prinzip bei vielen diesen Präprozessorsprachen, wo zum Beispiel dieses Haml oder diese HTML, DSL in Ruby, glaube ich, ursprünglich mal erdacht, wo du halt denkst, naja, jetzt hab ich zwar diese Metasprache, um HTML zu generieren, aber ich weiß halt jetzt nicht genau, was das dann da hinten draus macht sozusagen. Und natürlich ist das alles in Erlang implementiert und du kannst es bestimmt auch nachgucken in der Standard-Doku oder was auch immer.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob Haml jetzt ausgerechnet das gute Beispiel ist, weil...
Ja, für mich ist das genau das Gleiche, weil am Anfang war das limitierter als HTML selber. Also du konntest bestimmte Sachen halt nicht ausdrücken auch. Also es war immer so für mich das gleiche Gefühl. Da war immer so ein gewisser Nebel. Was ist denn jetzt dahinter? Wohingegen, wenn du literal HTML da hinschreibst und siehst, dann weißt du halt einfach genau, was das ist.
Lass mich mal anders fragen. Alexia kompiliert runter auf Erlang oder kompiliert direkt auf die Erlang-Maschine?
Na, warte mal, Moment, jetzt müssen wir mal überlegen. Alexia ist auf jeden Fall in Erlang implementiert.
Ja, na gut.
Und es kompilt zu Beam-Code dann am Ende.
Also im Prinzip ist es sowas wie Kotlin oder wie heißt das andere? Scala. Was ja Programmiersprachen auf der Java Virtual Machine sind, die relativ gut mit richtigem Java interagieren können.
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, ob ich das... Also wenn du das, du sagst, okay.
Hab ich mir sagen lassen. Ich hab das selber noch nicht.
Aber ich finde das, die Begründung auf jeden Fall ganz gut, weil genau, in Erlang finde ich auch gerade eins, der Features, wie ich ja auch schon anfangs sagte, dass viele Sachen nur einen Weg zur Implementierung haben. Und wenn du halt von wildfremden Leuten den Code anguckst, und du siehst einen Fold oder was auch immer, das ist halt immer die gleiche Struktur. Und man findet sich seltener genau in diesem Moment, wo man, gerade bei Ruby ist das halt so, dieses Metaprogramming und dieses Verstecken. Und es gibt, hey, benutze unsere Library, und du musst nur noch einen Call machen, um einen Web-Server aufzusetzen. Und natürlich ist irgendwo dahinter, im Lip-Folder, da ist der ganze Code dann, da ist alles schön kurz, für den Programmierer macht. Und bei Erlang gibt es sowas halt nicht.
Da gibt es einen uralten Blog-Artikel über Software-Abstractions von, ach Gott, wie heißt der, Ramblings in Code von 2004 oder so, wo der Mensch auch schon mal gesagt hat, so eine Abstraktion ist immer so gut, wie wenig sie liegt. Und manchmal ist es halt einfach besser, keine Abstraktion zu haben, weil du dann weißt, was passiert, statt irgendeine Abstraktion zu haben, die an irgendeiner Stelle dann bricht. Und dann musst du einmal durch das gesamte System durch, um zu verstehen, was tatsächlich passiert, und dann bist du ohne Abstraktion eventuell schneller.
Wobei das, was ja Tim und mein Bekannter eher meint, ist ja dann wahrscheinlich, wenn die Sprache selber überhaupt diese verschiedenen Arten anbietet, wie man halt eine Variable assignen kann.
Genau.
Wenn es halt dann auch noch diese ganzen Shortcuts sprachenseitig gibt und gar nicht mal über eine Library.
Ja, das ist halt wirklich eine Philosophiefrage. War das Pearl?
Das klingt auf jeden Fall nach einem guten Kandidatenführer. Man kann es auch noch kürzer schreiben.
Ja, der Slogan ist There is always one more way to do it. Also die stellen sozusagen dieses Ja, hier ist die Sprache. In der kannst du es so schreiben, wie du willst. Wir kommen dir entgegen. Und wenn das dein Ansatz ist, dann kannst du das damit machen. Und wenn du einen anderen Style pflegst, dann kannst du das auch machen. Und das alles in derselben Sprache. Hauptsache, es schmeckt.
Und daher kommt dann eigentlich die Sache, dass viele Leute sagen, Pearl ist Right Only.
Genau, das will ich nämlich auch sagen. Das ist im Prinzip die Basis für Right Only. Jetzt gibt es Programmiersprachen, die haben das jetzt nicht so zum Mantra erhoben, haben aber schon eben auch so Sachen, wo ich immer so ganz intuitiv, immer so ein bisschen zusammenzucke. Zum Beispiel, als ich mir mal Python angeschaut habe, das erste Mal, da bin ich dann schon so ins Stocken gekommen, als ich festgestellt habe, ja, es gibt if, else, so, wie immer. Aber es gibt auch diese bekloppte Ternäre.
So, dass es genau andersrum ist, ja.
Nein, es ist gar nichts andersrum, sondern es ist halt die Inline-Variante, weil du ja bei Python diese strikte Aufteil-nach-Zeilen- und Einrückending hast, kannst du halt mal nicht kompakt schreiben. Damit man das aber auch machen kann, weil sie es dann doch nämlich vermisst haben, hast du halt irgendwie diese Variante, dieses bekloppte Fragezeichen, Doppelpunkt, Operators wie schon in C, der das ja auch hat.
Ich finde den nicht verkehrt, aber bitte.
Doch, den finde ich halt total verkehrt.
Du darfst ihn nicht schachteln, aber ansonsten?
Ja, aber es ist, es handelt sich um das selbe Ding, es ist der selbe Program-Control, es ist kein Unterschied.
Nee, also zumindest in C nicht, aber ja, red weiter.
Doch, auch in C ist es dasselbe und in Python ist es auch genau dasselbe. Ja, es mag andere syntaktische, na nein, nicht unbedingt.
Ja klar, du kannst es natürlich auch missbrauchen zu anderen Dingen, aber...
Ja, es ist eine Expression und in C ist alles eine Expression. Ja, in C ist alles eine Expression und auch das ist eine Expression. Also es ist identisch zu if. Es ist aber nochmal ein anderer, syntaktischer Kram, weil du halt diese Keywords nicht irgendwie in Klammern verwenden kannst. Was eine Limitierung ist von C, die sie an der Stelle aufgebrochen haben, weil sie zu faul waren, anstatt einfach zu sagen, ja wir würden ja gerne if auch in die Klammer eines ifs schreiben, aber unser Pasa ist nicht so universell beschrieben, dass das halt jederzeit ginge. Hätte man ja auch gleich so machen können. Und deswegen haben sie diese Krücke mit eingebaut, damit sie das mal fix fix irgendwie hinbekommen. Und in Python aus etwas anderen Gründen aber auch dasselbe Ding. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, ach Tim, reg dich nicht so auf. Da gibt es Schlimmeres und das hat man doch irgendwie nach einer Stunde drin. Und das sehe ich doch gar nicht mehr. Und jetzt poamiere ich schon seit 20 Jahren Python und es war nie ein Problem. Und trotzdem sage ich, ist aber ein Problem, weil einfach die Sprache konzeptionell an der Stelle halt einfach Dinge am Biggest hält. Also kannst du es halt so schreiben und kannst es halt auch so schreiben. Und damit entwickelst du halt unterschiedliche Styles. Perl treibt es halt auf die Spitze.
Ich würde sagen, bei Ruby steht dem nichts nach.
Bei Ruby ist es auch so. Dieses Ruby-Tutorial, als das rauskam, wo sie sich so abgefeiert haben, dieses, ja, lernen Ruby ganz schnell und wir zeigen dir mal ein paar tolle Sachen. Und dann ist so dieses bekloppte Beispiel mit irgendwie Punkt Times irgendwie, ja, du Punkt Times, Klammer auf 5. Und das haben die so gefeiert, dass du irgendwas 5 mal ausführen kannst mit so einer Schreibweise, die eigentlich dafür überhaupt nicht gemacht ist. Ja, und geil fanden sie es nur, weil es sich dann halt in Englisch gut las.
Ja, so was ähnliches hat ein Kollege von mir jetzt aber auch gemacht. Also irgendwie in Swift 3 sind ja die Integer-Values jetzt tatsächlich auch richtige Objekte, wo du halt Funktionen dran hängen kannst. In Swift, ja. Und er hat quasi an Integer eine Times-Funktion rangehängt, die eine Closure benutzt, nur um dann sagen zu können, 5 Punkt Times Closure macht irgendwas. Und da hab ich ihn aber dann zurückgefilft. Hat er auch eingesehen. Das ist irgendwie Unsinn.
Also ich mein, wie gesagt, Sprache für den richtigen Job und so.
Das ist überhaupt das Allerwichtigste an der Entscheidung eigentlich.
Genau, und Ruby seh ich jetzt mittlerweile eigentlich nur noch so als reine Prototyping-Language, oder mal eben was hinhacken, weil die Sprache geht ja auch maximal halt aus dem Weg. Du kannst alles machen, du kannst alles umdefinieren. Das ist auch so die objektorientierteste Sprache in der Hinsicht, als das wirklich alles bis auf Objekt ein Objekt ist. Also die Mutterklasse aller Objekte ist dann halt in C noch ein bisschen anders definiert als alle von ihr abgeleiteten Objekte. Aber im Grunde ist alles ein Objekt und alles kann zur Laufzeit verändert werden, Operatoren überladen werden, du kannst dann alles ran. Und kein Treiber, kein Stück Code, was du noch als Dependency reinholst, ist dem sicher. Was halt so zum Hacken und mal was aufmachen und was verändern super geil ist, aber eben auch durch diese ganzen Möglichkeiten dazu führt, dass Leute die krassesten Shortcuts nehmen und du manchmal vor Robi-Codes sitzt und einfach nur denkst What? Erstmal gucke ich und ich versuche dir natürlich noch von der Erlang-Welt zu überzeugen, aber es sieht nicht so gut aus.
Haben sie das Licht noch nicht gesehen?
Ja, meine Kollegen finden Erlang eigentlich alle ganz, die warten auch nur darauf, dass jetzt mal ein Projekt kommt, wo man mal Erlang oder zumindest Elixir benutzen könnte, aber jetzt haben sie auf jeden Fall einen Mitstreiter mehr in diesen Quests.
Tja Huckel, irgendwann musst du dann deinen zweiten Kopf aufsetzen, deinen dritten Arm und sagen, komm mit mir, ich bin von einem fremden Planeten.
Oder einem Fremdland.
Schweden.
Was ich in letzter Zeit so gemerkt habe, was echt so schwierig ist, ist wenn du so eine traditionell objektorientierte Sprache hast und da fließen die ganzen funktionalen Sachen rein und plötzlich kriegst du so einen fiesen Mix aus funktionalen Sachen und objektorientierten Sachen und das ist dann oftmals recht schwer zu verstehen.
Ja, am Ende wollen sie alle dann doch wieder eine Lisp haben.
Das war nämlich auch so, als ich diese Coding-Challenge gemacht habe. Ich habe es erstmal so straight Ruby programmiert, weil ich schon gleich am Anfang diesen Reflex hatte, ich probiere es funktional und dachte mir, ne ne, erstmal diese Coding-Challenge fertig machen und dann gucke ich mal, ob ich das in Ruby auch funktional und möglichst wenig Seiteneffekte hinbekomme. Und ich habe mich dann echt so vor dieser Standard-Leibe, ich habe dann so Array, sowas gibt es hier alles. Gibt es denn hier nichts, was keinen Seiteneffekt hat? Also es ist wirklich auch so schwer zu finden. Und dann heißt es aber, ja, es ist ja funktional und multiparadigmen und wir haben hier ein Map und ein Reject und haste nicht gesehen. Aber dann im Kleingedruckten, ist halt doch nicht die ganz reine Lehre dann, ne? Aber es gab letztens auch einen Artikel, der war ein bisschen ketzerisch formuliert, ob Funktionales programmieren, ob das überhaupt Sinn macht, weil das würde ja viel zu viel Performance kosten und so weiter und so fort. Ach, den muss ich jetzt mal rausnommen.
Ja, den hab ich auch gelesen, der war ganz interessant.
Also der war schon so ein bisschen trollig oder ketzerisch formuliert, aber wenn man den mit so einem kleinen Teelöffel Salz so sich reinfährt, da sind schon interessante Punkte drin und die machen auch Sinn und gerade wenn du das jetzt mit Go vergleichst, so dass Erlang hat ja ganz viel Fanziness und alles wird kopiert und immutable und so weiter und das kostet natürlich Performance im Vergleich zu einfach nur eine Pointer-Adresse hin und her reichen und so. Also die Abstraktion, die man sich dann so baut, um eben mit dem gepolsterten Elfenbeinhebel da so rumzuvorwerken, die kosten halt Performance, ist eigentlich die Bottom Line von dem Artikel und er hat es halt jetzt ein bisschen krass formuliert vielleicht oder ein bisschen hart, also wenn man jetzt gerade auf Krawall gebürstet ist, dann würde man sofort, somebody is wrong on the Internet.
Ich fand das halt sehr klasse, wie er dieses Beispiel Sieb des Erostratenes, wie auch immer, dieses Primzahlen Sieb da anbringt und das tatsächlich irgendwie drei Doktorarbeiten gebraucht hat, bis es tatsächlich jemand den Algorithmus, so wie er ursprünglich mal im antiken Griechenlands formuliert wurde, clean in Haskell programmiert hat, in weiß ich nicht wie vielen Zeilen von Code. Weil alles, was immer angegeben wurde, dass es das machen würde, es tatsächlich nie gemacht hat.
Hier, ich hab den Artikel gefunden. Ich paste ihn sofort. Disadvantages of purely functional programming. Nur, dass er weiß, dass ich hier auch durchaus mal über den Tellerrand gucke.
Da gab es gerade so einen schönen Artikel. Ich auf GitHub, auf dem GitHub-Blog. Die haben ihre Analyse gemacht, so auf GitHub, welche Programmiersprachen oder welche Tags auch auf committetem Code in der Woche gemacht wird und welche am Wochenende gemacht wird.
Sehr schön, sehr schön.
Ah, geile Nummer.
Nach dem Motto, was benutzen die Leute in der Woche? Und wenn sie irgendwie Bock haben, am Wochenende, was wird denn da dann irgendwie gekodet? Wenig überraschend, wenn auch etwas frustrierend.
Java in der Woche?
Nee, Java war da irgendwie überhaupt nicht drin in dieser Liste in der Woche, was mich auch im Nachgang ganz schön überrascht, aber was nicht ganz so überraschend war, war das meist... Oh Gott, ich muss jetzt diesen Artikel nochmal finden, weil...
Mach das doch mal. Mach mal kurz Fenster auf.
Mach das. Das waren alles so Sachen, wo ich mir dachte so, kenn ich das eigentlich überhaupt? Und dann stellte sich heraus, dass das sozusagen alles so Microsoft-Business-Sachen waren.
Unter der Woche.
Nehm ich mal an.
Die Microsoft-Hacker müssen auch am Wochenende ran.
Ah ja, genau, warte mal, ne Entschuldigung, es war überhaupt nicht auf GitHub, es war auf Stack Overflow. Hab's gleich. Da-da-da. Da-da-da. Ist nämlich hier auf Haskell News.
Ach, die programmieren alle Haskell am Wochenende.
Genau, sie programmieren alle... Genau, what programming languages are used most on weekends. Ich werf das mal kurz hier in den Chat rein. So, da ist es. Und das ist wirklich eine scary Liste.
Aber Sie haben GitHub gescraped, oder wie?
Das machen Sie, glaube ich, jedes Jahr.
Ja, das machen Sie schon über einen längeren Zeitraum.
Das heißt, die Java-Leute checken nicht ein, ne?
Also, ich muss zugeben, dass ich diesen Artikel nur überflogen habe. Er ist relativ lang.
Sehr passend für unsere Sendung, natürlich.
Aber was benutzen, was machen die Leute hier? SharePoint wird da irgendwie programmiert. Das ist so diese Microsoft-Skram. TSQL ist auch diese Microsofts. Dann dieses XJS-Framework, von dem ich bis dahin auch nichts gehört hab.
Das sind die Fragen, die da gepostet werden. In der Woche und am Wochenende auf...
Stack Overflow.
Ah, Stack Overflow. Jetzt hab ich das natürlich vertreten.
Let's use our public Stack-Lite-Data reset on blah blah blah to explore differences between questions that are posted on weekdays and weekends.
Okay, deswegen hab ich das jetzt verdreht, Entschuldigung. Das wäre jetzt nochmal der interessante Gegenvergleich, das wirklich mit Commits auf Sprachen zu machen. Aber wonach fragen die Leute? Mit was für Fragen kommen sie auf? Unter der Woche gibt es einfach nur Microsoft-Fragen.
Aber SharePoint scheint sehr erklärungsbedürftig zu sein, weil das mit deutlichem Abstand führt.
Genau, dann dieses TSQL ist halt dieser Oracle Microsoft SQL Erweiterungssatz. PowerShell ist auch Windows.
Benutzt ja auch niemand freiwillig.
Soap, Visual Basic. Oracle, XSLT, viele Fragen. Internet Explorer, danach wird gefragt. Na ja, und jetzt auf der anderen Seite, am Wochenende, wo wird danach gefragt, nach Haskell und nach Assembler und OpenGL.
Gut, das sind aber auch so die kryptischsten. Und Pointers.
Und Algorithmen im Allgemeinen und C und Python.
Und Recursion, denn wer Recursion verstehen will, muss erstmal Recursion verstanden haben.
Okay, ich entschuldige mich hier für das Verdrehen der Fakten. Ich fände es jetzt noch mal ganz interessant, ob es eine entsprechende Auswertung von GitHub gibt, weil das wäre ja auch mal interessant. Also in welchen Programmiersprachen werden mehr Komits gemacht? Vor allem, weil sie hier auch noch so einen Trend haben, wie sich das in den letzten Jahren entwickelt hat. Also diese Fragen zu Ruby on Rails zum Beispiel gehen zurück.
Das können ja auch was Gutes sein.
Ist das Version aber auch sehr stark.
Android steigt irgendwie an. Also da kann man wirklich ganz interessant sehen, wie so... Tja, das mal jetzt aus meinem gesunden Halbwissen heraus.
Es gab mal eine GitHub-Analyse, aber dummerweise nicht. Also schon so nach Quartal, aber du hast jetzt nicht die Einordnung in Wochenende und Wochentag. Aber man sah die, für alle, die es nicht kennen, die Verteilung, wie sich die Programmiersprachen über den Zeitraum entwickelt haben. Ja, ich hab einen Link gepostet. Aber es ist von 2014, das ist so ein bisschen schade und auf GitHub selber, auf dem Blog, gab es von 2015 die letzte Auswertung.
Aber es ist ja ganz cool gemacht.
Schicke Visualisierung auch.
Ich liebe diese Visualisierung, ja. Es ist so schön.
Aber es ist jetzt leider nicht aktuell.
Nee, schade. Auch GitHub hat scheinbar länger nicht einen Post über die Trends der Sprachen ausgebracht.
Hier hat noch einer im Chat für 2016 was gepostet.
Welche am meisten gesternet werden.
Welche am meisten gesternet werden, ja, okay.
Was auch immer das für eine Metrik ist.
Es geht wahrscheinlich um Repositories, die gesternet werden, die dazugehörigen.
Sterne finde ich jetzt uninteressant. Die sagen irgendwie gar nichts aus. Ich will wirklich diese Comit-Analyse mit Wochenender sehen. Das habe ich mir jetzt wahrscheinlich so ein bisschen herbeigewünscht, in dem Moment, als ich das gesehen habe.
Wir haben ja Hörer.
Hausaufgabe zum nächsten Mal.
Das ist alles hier Fake Show. Alles sehr schön bunt, aber irgendwie auch nicht aussagekräftig. Gut, machen wir mal den Deckel zu bei Programmierern.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich die Punch-Card von jedem Repo mal sich angucken. Punch-Card? GitHub hat, wenn du ein Repo anlegst, unter den Grafen verschiedene Visualisierungen. Unter anderem kann man sich anschauen, wer was wie viel committed hat in Quotes of Lines. Und dann hast du halt so eine Punch-Card, wo du sehen kannst, wann wurde wie viel committed, genau.
Kannst du bei Pottlach, genau, hier, klick da schon. Sie baden gerade ihre Hände drin, ich muss jetzt mal da, genau.
Und der Grafs oben in der Leiste, bei den Reitern. Und dann gibst du die Punch-Card. Recht stabil.
Über die Tage meinst du jetzt? Ach so, Uhrzeit. Was ist das für eine Uhrzeit?
Unten drunter hast du die PM.
Wir fangen alle so morgens um 9 geht's schon los. Höhepunkt ist so 12, 11.
Welche Zeitzone? Die Zeitzone ist natürlich jetzt die Frage noch.
Deine vielleicht, wenn die richtig gut sind.
Ich denke auch.
Sollte passen.
In der du dich bewegst.
Das sind ja nicht meine Komits.
In der Zeitzone.
Du bist der, der sich das anguckt.
Ja, passt aber nicht, weil die Komits sind bestimmt alle früher. Das sieht mir eher nach der Zeitzone...
Das GitHub aus.
Wie es wirklich passiert ist aus. Das ist ja so tagsüber hier 9, 10 Uhr geht's los. Aber das ist ja auch nur über den kompletten Zeitraum. Über einen, ja, müsste man jetzt nochmal einschrecken, in den letzten zwei Jahren oder so.
Schicken wir mal auf Membars.
Brauchst du dann so deine Zeitzone ändern und die andere Zeitraum abwägen, dann siehst du, ob sie dich versteht oder nicht.
Oder Code Frequencies? Es gab noch einen anderen Chicken Graph irgendwie.
Bei den Komits siehst du die Anzahl der Komits und da hast du darüber noch einen Extra Bar.
Und was war denn das mit dem Puls neben dem Graph Stop? Was ist das nochmal?
Der Puls? Das ist glaube ich eher für Issues und Pull Requests.
Was ist so zuletzt passiert hier? Der letzte Monat und so. Was geht gerade so? Na gut, man kann nicht alles haben. Programmierthema erst mal beendet?
Darf ich noch eine Kleinigkeit dazuschieben? Die ich schon lange in den Show-Notes hier rumwuseln habe. Und ich fand es einfach ganz witzig, weil wir wissen ja, 2016 sind viele Leute gestorben, die uns alle sehr am Herzen lagen. Und das hört halt auch nicht auf. Es ging ja dieses Jahr direkt weiter. Dann habe ich irgendwie so einen Artikel gefunden vom MIT Media Lab, How many famous people will die in 2017? Die sich dem ganzen Thema sozusagen statistisch und historisch genährt haben. Spoiler alert, es geht vor allen Dingen, also es werden mehr Leute famous people sterben, weil wir jetzt dieses Zeitfenster erreichen, wo mehr Leute populär oder famous durch die Massenmedien geworden sind, die jetzt alt genug sind, um das Zeitliche zu segnen. Aber der Artikel ist ganz schick und hatten die dann auch irgendwie ganz unten noch irgendwelche Diagramme mit der Prediction, wie viele denn jetzt so in 2017 sterben werden. Also für alle Leute, die dann so rest in peace und so auf ihre Twitter-Timeline hauen, die können das jetzt schon mal genau eintakten. Und ja, fand ich auf jeden Fall ein kleines...
Aber gab es dann schon auch ein Artikel, wo sie meinen, 2016 sind auch nicht mehr gestorben als sonst?
Ja, also es wird da alles sehr relativiert und mal mit kleiner Flamme gekocht sozusagen. Ich pack's jetzt mal in die Show-Notes, da können die Leute dann auch nochmal...
Ich hab, glaub ich, einen ähnlichen anderen Artikel gelesen, der sich auch mit dieser Frage beschäftigt hat, aber ich glaub, das war nicht der hier. Ich kann mich an die Optik grad nicht erinnern.
Der wurde viel zitiert, auf jeden Fall. Ich hab dann mir immer die Mühe gemacht, den originalen Post zu suchen, aber ja... Vielleicht hast du auch noch einen anderen gefunden.
Ja, der hatte, glaub ich, im Titel mehr so ein... Stimmt es, dass 2016 so viele gestorben sind und nicht so sehr wie viele werden 2016... Also weniger Prediction als mehr Analyse ist denn überhaupt viel, aber im Prinzip wahrscheinlich dieselbe Feststellung. Ich weiß nicht genau, wie sie es hier gemacht haben, aber in dem anderen Artikel war eben überhaupt die Definition... Oder war das doch dieser Artikel?
Also es geht um diesen Aspekt?
Genau, die machen es hier auch... Vielleicht war es auch der selbe Artikel, weiß nicht ganz genau. Also berühmt ist man, wenn man irgendwie mit mindestens 20 Sprachversionen der Wikipedia erwähnt wird als Person oder einen Artikel hat und ich glaube, wenn man ein anderes Resholt, ab 100 oder so ist man so in dieser Kategorie superfamous, so worldfamous. Na ja klar, ich meine, wenn du irgendwie Präsident der Vereinigten Staaten bist, dann bist du halt in jeder Wikipedia drin. Auch wahrscheinlich in Esperanto und so. Und daran kann man halt schon eine gewisse Bekanntheit auch festmachen. Ja, und es gibt einfach mehr davon und das kam halt alles so mit dem Fernsehzeitalter. Sicherlich hat jetzt das Internet nochmal ein paar mehr Leute noch hervorgebracht, sodass wir dann in 20, 30 Jahren vielleicht nochmal eine leichte Steigerung haben.
Wenn PewDiePie stirbt oder wie heißt der?
Ja, vielleicht auch, dass es überhaupt jetzt eine Wikipedia gibt, an der man messen kann.
An der man messen kann, ob jemand berühmt ist, genau.
Und dass auch immer mehr Artikel geschrieben werden. Zum Thema berühmt und kleinen Rückausflug zum Programmierthema. Wir haben nämlich etwas noch nicht erwähnt. Chris Lattner, der Schöpfer von Swift und Programmierer von LLDB und allem Drum und Dran hat Apple verlassen.
Hatten wir das nicht in der letzten Sendung schon erwähnt, dass er zu Tesla ist und so weiter?
Aber eine Kleinigkeit bei dem ATP Podcasts, gibt es ein Interview von ihm.
Er ist zu Gast.
Er ist zu Gast?
Nein, nein, das war vorher gekündigt.
Nein, nein, das war genau danach.
Mit dem Firewall-Typen auch, ne? War das das?
Mit dem Firewall-Typen?
Excedental Tech Podcast. Doch, der Gruber ist doch da auch dabei?
Nein, der Gruber ist nicht dabei. Gruber macht The Talk Show und da war er nicht. Sondern Excedental Tech Podcast. Das ist halt John Siergacusa, Marco Amendt, der Overcast programmiert hat und Casey Liz. Das sind die drei, die machen ATP. Überhaupt ein super, eigentlich der Tech Podcast, meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, wenn sie nicht gerade über Autos reden.
Naja, es ist halt für ein Nerd-Publikum. Ich finde, ihre Analysen sind meistens sehr treffend. Also sind meistens sehr gut und teilweise außerordentlich gut. Also das muss man schon sagen. Es gibt natürlich auch mal Dinge, da kann man anderer Meinung sein. Aber ich finde, ihre Fähigkeit, Themen überhaupt erst mal zu abstrahieren, auseinanderzunehmen und Aspekte zu nennen, finde ich bemerkenswert. Und sie hatten sich dann halt, wie auch wir ja hier, über den Abgang von Chris Lattner unterhalten und auch gemutmaßt und so. Und typischerweise fängt ja dann die neue Sendung auch immer irgendwie mit so einem kleinen witzigen Outtake der aktuellen Sendung an. Und dann hat John C. Racusa nochmal zusammengefasst, dass das so meiner Meinung nach die Gründe sein könnten. Und meint dann noch so ganz lustig so, was meinst du Chris? Und dann meldet sich halt so Chris Lattner, sounds about right. Dann geht die Sendung irgendwie los. Und sie lassen halt dann die Bombe platzen, dass er halt da ist. Der hat sich dann einfach gemeldet und hat gesagt, oh klar, ich komm mal vorbei. So ein super netter Typ. Und dann marschieren sie halt einfach mal durch diese ganze Historie, die er so gehabt hat. Erklären LLVM from the ground up.
Erklären vom ground up jetzt nicht, aber sie reden da drüber.
Also für jemanden, der da von dem Thema, es ist jetzt kein Referenzmanual, was sie da rein diktieren, aber es gibt einen guten Überblick. Genau, wenn du keine Ahnung hast, wovon überhaupt die Rede ist, wird es dort, wie ich finde, sehr gut erläutert.
Sehr gut.
Und das ist auf jeden Fall sehr interessant. Und es ist natürlich auch sehr interessant, dass jemand, der eben noch in diesem Ring of Fire bei Apple stand und für den jeglicher Außenweltkontakt tödlich gewesen wäre in dem Moment, schwuppst dann zwei Wochen später das alles schon im Podcast breit.
Ja, jetzt übertreibst du aber ein bisschen. Ich meine, die haben diese ganze Swift-Evolution-Sache ja doch sehr in der Öffentlichkeit gemacht seit Swift 3.
Ja, aber wäre er noch bei Apple gewesen, wäre dieser Auftritt nicht drin gewesen.
Unter Steve? Ja, inzwischen...
Nein, auch jetzt nicht.
Da wäre ich mir nicht so sicher.
Ich kenne so viele Leute bei Apple, die ich frage und die mir sagen...
Na wie auch immer, das Interview ist relativ gut.
Geh mir weg mit deinem Podcast, ich bin mein Job los.
Das Interview ist relativ gut. Was ich sehr, sehr spannend fand, war seine Ausführung zum Thema Garbage Collector.
Genau.
Ansonsten hört es euch einfach an.
Wie scheiße der ist und dass es gut ist, dass er weg ist?
Seine Meinung, warum er scheiße ist. Also er kann das relativ gut begründen.
Der Objective-C oder der Swift Garbage Collector oder alle.
Grundsätzlich das Prinzip.
Weder Objective-C noch Swift haben einen Garbage Collector.
Inzwischen, das hat er ja mal einen.
Das hat er mal einen. Und er begründet relativ gut, warum er der Meinung ist, dass das eine schlechte Idee ist. Kleiner Spoiler, es geht um die Finalizer. Das hatte ich nicht erwartet. Aber sei es drum. Wir wollten ja das Programmier-Thema jetzt mal abschließen. Ich kann nur empfehlen. Hört es euch an.
Ja, es ist wirklich grandios, die Folge.
Kam da auch vor, weil ich meine, der ist ja, ich würde mal sagen, der ist ja schon als Vater dieser Programmiersprache angesehen schon, oder?
Ja.
Weil man das heutzutage noch so sagen kann, bei so Projekten, wo so viele Leute jemand machen, war ja früher mal anders.
Aber er hat es auf jeden Fall losgetreten.
Ja, haben Sie ihn auch gefragt, ob das jetzt so... Na ja, okay, wir wissen jetzt, Programmiersprachen gibt es ja für verschiedene Anwendungszwecke und so weiter, deswegen gibt es ja nicht die eine perfekte. Aber hat er gesagt, dass er so 100 Prozent mit seinem Swift zufrieden ist, und dass er auch nichts mehr ändern würde jetzt im Nachhinein, oder?
Nein, ganz im Gegenteil. Also er hat ja auch diesen Ausblick gebracht, so das und das wird es wahrscheinlich für Swift 4 geben. Und den Rest machen wir dann später. Und das, was wir eigentlich schon festklopfen wollten, für Swift 3 haben wir nicht hingekriegt und machen wir auch später. Also es ist ganz klar, dass diese Sprache noch eine Entwicklung machen wird.
Weil sie haben ja, ich weiß nicht, ob das am Anfang nur so Marketing blablabla war, aber ich glaube, in den ersten Slides hier, ich glaube, das war jetzt vor zweieinhalb Jahren, oder wann kam die Sprache? Ne, vor anderthalb Jahren?
Zweieinhalb.
Die ersten Slides, wo sie das vorgestellt haben, wo sie, wo sie glaube ich erwähnt haben, was sie damit, also was man damit koden könnte, stand glaube ich auch da, damit, dass man damit auch eine OS schreiben könnte, also dass das sozusagen komplett die Ablösung wäre, weil jetzt eigentlich Linux alles ist eigentlich in C geschrieben, oder? Mehr oder weniger so ein Körnel. Und dass man das damit ja auch machen könnte. Das ist die Frage, ob sie das auch irgendwann mal vorhaben. Ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weit hergeholt?
Nee, ist es überhaupt nicht. Es steht in den Swift Evolution Sachen drin, dass es so ein bisschen auch so ein Ziel ist, jetzt vielleicht noch nicht für Swift 4, aber für später, dass man tatsächlich eine Systems Programming Language haben will. Und dazu gehört dann aber auch nochmal ein anderes Speichermodell. Also wenn du dir Rust zum Beispiel anguckst, wo du halt sehr feinkörnig sagen kannst, die Variable soll halt jetzt nur so und so lange leben und ich weiß schon, was ich tue, danke, Compiler, sowas willst du, wollen sie halt zumindest perspektivisch auch irgendwann einführen. Ich meine, das was Rust da macht, ist halt totaler Wahnsinn. Wenn du dir das anguckst, versteht man auf Anhieb überhaupt nicht und vor allen Dingen auch nicht, warum die das machen. Aber wenn du wirklich sehr, sehr genauer Kontrolle darüber haben willst, was wann passiert, dann ist Rust halt genau das Richtige.
Das wäre dann wirklich nur für die allerwenigsten Fälle und allerwenigsten Programmierer wirklich wichtig und für die Fälle, wo es wichtig ist, könnte man halt mit so Meta-Appi oder so ähnlich das dann eben auch in Swift noch mal nachreichen, damit man das dann in den Fällen dann auch tun kann, während es den meisten Leuten aber konstitutionell überhaupt nicht in den Weg kommt. Und sie mit dem ARC-Ansatz und so weiter ohnehin schon einen guten Default haben für performantes Speicherhandling.
Ich finde das perfekt, dieses Garbage Collection. Ich hab ja noch vorher im Alok-Release irgendwie alles schön von Hand gemacht und dann kommt so eine Garbage Collection her. Da hast du so einen gewissen Kontrollverlust irgendwie. Und mit ARC hatte ich zwar auch eigentlich einen Kontrollverlust, hatte aber doch das Gefühl, dass ich trotzdem einigermaßen nachvollziehen kann, wann, wie, was, wo passiert und dass es auch schön wegoptimiert wird. Und bei Garbage Collection, das hatte ich irgendwie nicht. Ich hatte immer das Gefühl, da ist so ein Müll immer der Platzblech und dann bleibt mein Programm kurz stehen, weil sie einen Müll einmal rausbringt. Das war immer so mein Mutterkopf.
Das ist ja auch nicht so falsch.
Mag sein, dass es inzwischen ein bisschen moderner ist, aber ich fand ARK dann einen schönen Übergang und war da wieder zu Hause. Was ich aber sagen wollte wegen Swift und OS-Programmieren ist, wenn ich mich das auch richtig erinnere, damals im Jahr 2000 oder so, wo sie das OS X vorgestellt haben, stand Steve, glaube ich, auch auf der Bühne und meinte, hier ist unser neues Betriebssystem und er geht mal so davon aus, dass das jetzt für die nächsten 20 Jahre hier so Stand der Dinge ist. Ne, 20.
Er sagte 20.
2 zu 1. Wir sind hier in einer Demokratie, aber du kannst das gerne nachgoogeln und nachreichen. Ach so sogar, ich muss auch nicht. Die Hörer können das selber rausfinden. Jedenfalls, die 20 Jahre sind jetzt bald um. Die 10 sowieso. Wenn man das jetzt mal so sieht. In any case ist es jetzt bald vorbei. Oder es ist schon vorbei. Dann wäre die Frage, ob mal was Neues kommt. Ich meine, so ein neues OS mit neuen Apis vielleicht mit einer neuen Sprache, Sprachenbindung und so weiter, da müssten die auch schon längst dabei sein. Die 20 Jahre werden jetzt auch nicht plus minus eins nehmen. Alles ein bisschen modernisieren. Ich meine, wir wissen ja, die ganzen Bugs und Exploits kommen, weil die Scheiße halt im C irgendwie ist, weil irgendwie nichts ordentlich gekodet ist, Memory, Bugs, Overflows und alles, was es in ordentlichen Sprachen nicht mehr gibt.
Du möchtest einen neu geschriebenen Kernel haben und ein neu geschriebenes User-Land, am besten auch gleich.
Keine Ahnung, irgendwann wird jemand kommen und wird ein neues OS bringen und dann wird der Rest dastehen und wird ganz schön scheiße aussehen.
Die Frage ist natürlich, ob der PC-Markt, also Mac PC, Desktop, Laptop-Markt halt nicht auch ein so weit gesättigter Markt ist, dass du nicht den Aufwand bringen kannst, jetzt ein komplett neues OS zu machen.
Ich glaube, die Zeiten sind ziemlich reif.
Das sind im Prinzip ein neues OS.
So sieht es aus. Und ich glaube, demnächst werden mehr Appliance-Computer kommen, die einfach irgendwie tun, was sie tun sollen. Und so ein bisschen, also das meiste nutzt da heute eh tausende von Frameworks. Und da müssen sich die Frameworks halt an ein neues OS anpassen. Aber eigentlich das Programm, was du nutzt, also was nutzt das noch vom OS? Also ist ja gar nicht mehr so viel. Die Frameworks sind da eigentlich viel, viel mächtiger als das OS, die man nutzt. Oh, jetzt haben wir noch 15. Na, lädt die auch noch irgendwie eine Zahl. Ist nicht so schwer, komm.
Treuzen.
Zum Thema Garbage Collection ganz kurz, noch ein Link. WebKit hat jetzt irgendwie einen neuen Garbage Collector bekommen und es gibt da einen Artikel, wo sie erklären, wie er funktioniert. Ich hab angefangen reinzulesen, habe ihn aber nicht ganz durchgekriegt und ich kann auch nicht behaupten, dass ich es direkt verstanden hätte. Aber wen so was interessiert und vor allen Dingen wie viel Aufwand man treiben kann, um so was Performance oder zumindest Semi-Performance hinzukriegen.
Was ich auch immer noch drauf warte, dass es mit Swift mal kommt, aber ich glaube, das hat mir schon mal vielleicht, wäre ich jetzt wieder eines besseren belehrt, aber dass dieser, wie nennt ihr ihn, Bitcode, ja? Dass ja, dass halt als Developer, dass man halt Bitcode ausliefern kann und dass er halt auf der Plattform compilert, optimiert und gemacht und getan wird, auf der er dann laufen soll. Das ist ja auch noch nicht so richtig da, würde, aber jenen von der Technik. Schon seit Anfang an war es zumindest eingeplant und trifft die jetzt nicht unvorbereitet.
Dazu sagt Lattner auch was in dem Podcast. Und zwar sagt er, das ganze Konzept hat seine Grenzen. Und es ist kein Java-VM-Bytecode, sondern das ist halt was zwischen Assembler und Java-VM-Bytecode. Und man kann gewisse Dinge optimieren und gewisse Dinge sind aber schon festgelegt durch dieses Bitcoin-Zeug.
Ich glaube, das habe ich auch schon mal woanders von ihm gelesen.
Das hat man ja auch schon mal in der Sendung gelesen.
Also er hat es nochmal bekräftigt, auch ein bisschen erklärt. Allein schon so 32-bit, 64-bit und komplett andere Memory-Layouts und so weiter, da kriegst du damit nicht gebridged. Es ist halt dafür da, Anpassungen im Rahmen einer Architektur zu machen. Mehr Register und so weiter, also sozusagen diese Optimierung innerhalb eines Prozessors, aber die generelle Denkweise des jeweiligen Assembler-Layouts und der Architektur ist damit nicht abbildbar und das war eben auch nie der Gedanke. Das heißt Bitcode, weil es vorher hieß es Bytecode, weil es da auf Byte-Boundaries war und dann haben sie das alles nochmal richtiger und kompakter gemacht. Das war so die erste Version. Dann hat das halt Bitcode genannt und das ist eigentlich der ganze Grund.
Also da würde ich jetzt nicht den Atem anhalten, dass da irgendwie groß was passiert.
Es ist halt so der Traum eigentlich, dass die Developer das wahrscheinlich, wo die bei Java auch alle drauf reingefallen sind.
Ja, aber du hast ja heutzutage, es müsste ja ohnehin nochmal kompiliert werden, dann kannst du es halt auch gleich vom Source machen.
Den willst du ja eventuell nicht ausliefern. Mit Comments und Zeug und was du auch drin hast.
Nee, muss du ja auch nicht, aber es ist ja auch zumutbar, dass du sagst, jetzt gibt es einmal eine neue Architektur, jetzt übersetze ich das dafür mal. So, das musst du ja nicht am laufenden Meter tun. Von daher ist das noch zumutbar. Und mittlerweile leben wir ja auch in Zeiten, wo du eine sehr viel höhere Source-Kompatibilität hast. Wenn ich mir anschaue, wie das C sich so entwickelt hat und wie die Kompatibilität zwischen einzelnen Compilern war, so in den 80er und 90er Jahren, überhaupt gar kein Vergleich mit heute. Also heute hast du da einfach sehr viel mehr Stabilität drin. Sodass du ja eben sagen kannst, es kommt ein neuer Prozessor, BAM, neues Target, compiled. Ich meine, wenn jetzt wirklich ein Mac rauskommt, der mit einem ARM-Prozessor läuft.
Ja, 2070 sag ich ja.
Wie groß wäre die Anstrengung für das typische Macintosh-Programm, was nicht älter als 10 Jahre ist vielleicht, übersetzt zu werden von Xcode in ARM?
Mit oder ohne Installieren des neuen Xcodes?
Also alle Tools sind da, du hast den neuen Xcode geladen. Da klickst du das an und dann hast du da so ein paar Issues und ein paar kleine Sachen, aber im Wesentlichen ist das alles gar kein Problem.
Wenn ein Programm nur aus der Zeit ist, was sowieso von PowerPC nach Intel gewechselt hat, dann haben die das eh alles hinter sich und dann läuft das einfach. Sind ja immer nur die Anfänger, die das nicht richtig machen.
Als sie von PowerPC zu Intel gewechselt sind oder von 32, 64, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, da haben sie zum Beispiel alle deprecateden APIs weggemacht für die neue Architektur. Und wenn du tatsächlich noch deprecateden APIs benutzt hast, dann musstest du an der Stelle anfassen. Wenn sie das nicht machen, dann ist es halt einfach irgendwo Clubmenü einmal kompilieren und dann, naja gut.
Ja, auf iOS wird ja demnächst ordentlich deprecated, wie es aussieht. Haben Sie jetzt nicht mit diesem iOS 10.3 Beta schon angekündigt, dass demnächst eine Menge wegfliegt und alle gehen davon aus, dass mit iOS 11 der 32-Bit-Support komplett wegfällt?
Also die Dokus sagen nicht eine einzige Deprecation für 10.3. Ich hab da reingeguckt, da sind ein paar Sachen dazugekommen. Unter anderem das mit den App-Icons. Eine App kann jetzt zur Laufzeit seinen Icon wechseln. Allerdings nur, wenn das Icon erstens vorher schon im Bundle ist und zweitens der User okay geklickt hat. Weil als User muss man jedes Mal okay klicken, dass das jetzt in Ordnung ist, dass die App lecker ist.
Dann können sie sich auch gleich vergessen, oder?
Ich hab da schon ein paar interessante Anwendungen gehört von Poemiran. Zum Beispiel, wenn du so ein Color-Theme einstellen kannst in deinem Programm, dann kannst du sozusagen dann auch das Color-Theme auf dein Icon übertragen.
Na, verstehe. Also, sollte man also mal anhören den...
Auf jeden Fall.
Es kommt ja, es kommt ja APFS für 10.3, ne? Da haben wir, glaub ich, noch nicht erledigt.
Kommt nicht nur, es ist schon da in den Betas, wenn ich das richtig verstanden hab. Das heißt, mein Tipp, den sich jeder zu Herzen nehmen sollte, ist, installiert nicht das iOS 10.3, wenn es da ist. Ich sag jetzt nicht, dass ihr aufs nächste Update wartet, aber ein paar Tage würde ich empfehlen.
Zumindest bis klar ist, ob jemand schon alle seine Daten verloren hat. Und in dem Fall ist es dann auch, glaub ich, wirklich wichtig, dass man vor dem Update nochmal das komplette Backup mit Altruz macht.
Das werden die wahrscheinlich eh enforcen oder irgendwie so, dann nochmal ganz deutlich darauf hinweisen. Also die werden schon wissen, dass selbst wenn sie da tausende von Tests machen, dass wenn sie da auf 100 Millionen Devices oder wie vielen auch immer sind, noch viel mehr eigentlich, da so ein Update fahren, dass da, also das ist schon ein bold move. Und ich würde trotzdem so ein bisschen warten. Also ich mach das nicht sofort. Und bis dahin war ich eigentlich immer schnell dabei. Weil ich hab auch, muss ich sagen, wie nennen die das? Ein Track-Record? Also es ist noch nie was schief gegangen. Ich update mein System durch seit, seit beim 3GS habe ich durchgeupdatet. Gut und dünnlich. Na wir reden dann nochmal, wenn es soweit ist.
Ja klar, aber ich...
Ich meine, es gab schon dicke Fails auch letztens erst wieder. Und wo die Updates zurückziehen und wo Fehler passieren. Und zwar wo auch Leute nicht wirklich installieren, mehr konnten, dass schief gegangen ist, auch bei Mac OS. Und das war alles ohne, dass ihr Filesystem unten drunter in On-the-Fly ändern. Also Fehler passieren einfach.
Ja, aber bei Apple schafft es dir schon, irgendwie dein Filesystem im laufenden Betrieb unter dem Arsch wegzukrypten. Das fand ich schon, ehrlich gesagt, viel bolder als dieses...
Aber das Wegkrypten ist nicht so schwer, weil die machen das ja auf File-Basis und nicht auf File-System-Basis.
Auf dem Mac machen sie es auf File-System-Basis.
Ja, aber auf dem iPhone zum Beispiel.
Also bei Krypto wird jeder Block angefasst. Bei dieser Art PFS-Geschichte nicht.
Ja, da werden sie nur die Metadaten umschreiben und eigentlich Sachen da so rumliegen lassen. Ich bin gespannt.
Das heißt, du baust dann eine neue Struktur und wenn die fertig ist, hast du switch-off um und alle Blöcke liegen noch an der selben Stelle.
Ja, aber du kannst nicht absprechen, dass es ein risky move ist.
Nein, aber ich sage nur...
Die werden es gut testen, davon gehe ich auch mal aus.
Ich frage mich eher, was werden wir davon haben?
Auf dem iPhone wahrscheinlich nichts.
Unter 10.3 erstmal nichts. Naja, unter 10.3 erstmal nichts.
Nö, unter 10.3 wahrscheinlich nicht, aber unter iOS 11. Da könnte ich mir halt einiges vorstellen. Zum Beispiel könntest du ja als Developer, wie du gerade hast gesagt, erstmal Backup machen und hab keinen Bock, mein Backup einzustellen mit den Snapshots. Könntest du halt einen Snapshot machen, spielst die Beta-Release drauf und wenn die Beta-Release kacke ist, machst du ein Rollback und die Sache ist wieder da.
Für Betas könnte es sein, aber das mit Rollback von Versionen machen sie ja schon sehr lange nicht mehr. Also auch Betas kannst du eigentlich nicht mehr auf die ursprüngliche Vollversion.
Weil sie halt noch kein Dateisystem haben mit dem Klassmasel-Eloge.
Weil sie nicht mehr rückwärts signieren.
Nein, du bist Developer, du hast eine Beta und du möchtest wieder auf Release zurück.
Das interessiert die nicht.
Das glaube ich auch.
Das interessiert die nicht. Als Developer hast du...
Das sind nicht die Probleme, die die lösen wollen....
hast du verdammt nochmal ein Development-Only-Device zu kaufen und fertig. So denkt Apple nicht. Das kannst du knicken. Ich glaube, so gut behandeln die Developer nicht. Glaub mir, ich weiß es.
Ja, aber auch andere Risikomoves, auch das Installieren eines Updates an sich, könnte davon profitieren.
Ja, natürlich. Ich sage nicht, dass Snapshots eine doofes Idee sind. Ganz im Gegenteil.
Ich denke, wir werden schon Snapshots in irgendeiner Form sehen.
Natürlich.
Auf jeden Fall auf macOS.
Elf.
Vielleicht auch werden, wird grundsätzlich das Backupen des iPhones damit erleichtert, weil die das auf Blog-Basis machen. Da bin ich mir aber noch nicht so sicher, wie sie das hinkriegen, wenn das auf dem macOS noch nicht da ist.
Genau, also allein um so ein iCloud-Backup zu ziehen, ist so ein Snapshot schon interessant, weil du machst halt mal einen Snapshot und machst einen Backup von diesem Snapshot, während dir die Apps, während dieses Backups munter den Scheiß...
Und im iCloud können die ja ja APFS ja schon haben. Oder was auch immer sie da haben, um das blogmäßig zu machen. Wahrscheinlich haben sie ein ganz anderes Filesystem.
Ja, sie können das Diff einfach sehr viel besser herstellen.
Zumindest hast du einen Snapshot, der ist dann erst mal stabil und den kannst du dann back-upen.
Genau.
Und dann hast du nicht so ein halbes Ding, wo du auf der einen Seite angefangen hast und wenn du auf der anderen Seite quasi fertig bist, hast du irgendwelche Zwischenstände dazwischen. Das ist schon sinnvoll, also Snapshots.
Also die beste Nachricht, fand ich, dass das mit 10.3 kommt, ist eigentlich, dass man jetzt nochmal so Bestätigung hat, dass es auf jeden Fall kommen wird, nicht abgesagt ist wie z.B., das kennen wir ja schon, dass wir dann da irgendwie sich zurückgezogen haben. Und wenn sie es jetzt auf dem iPhone ausrollen, dann gibt es auch keinen zurück. Und dann wird das im Sommer dann auch oder wann auch immer, was kommt jetzt, das nächste 10-Punkt-Reizen, wenn das kommt, dass es dann auch wahrscheinlich wirklich kommt. Und ich glaube, der größte Gewinn für mich ist Backups auf Blog-Basis.
Let's move on. Wir müssen mal wieder so einen Konsumer-Aspekt besprechen, der letztes Mal schon weggefallen ist. Hat jemand von euch Earpods bestellt?
Eine Kollege von mir hat die. Die ganze Zeit drin. Sieht mega hart behämmert aus. Ich hab mich letztens auch. Das ist gar nicht so schlimm, weil das ist doch relativ klein.
Ja, man kann sich bestimmt daran gewöhnen. Sieht jetzt nicht besonders cool aus. Ich hab mich natürlich auch schon mit ihm darüber unterhalten.
Die sehen doch gar nicht anders aus als die mit den Kugeln.
Okay, Dennis, du findest die cool. Ich find sie nicht cool.
Ich find da nur nicht so groß den Unterschied.
Aber ich seh die auf jeden Fall im täglichen Einsatz. Er hätte auch schon ein, zwei nachbestellt. Weil er die halt hier und da mal dann doch verloren hat. Zum Beispiel beim Fahrradfahren, wenn eine Kapuze auf hat oder so, dann kann es bei einer ungeschickten Bewegung schon mal passieren, dass da einer so rausflötet. Beziehungsweise abends im Bett Podcast hören und dann am nächsten Morgen den EarPods suchen. Solche Szenarien gibt's wohl dann halt.
War wohl nicht so ein eigenes Bett, oder?
Da gibt's ja demnächst die Find-My-EarPods-Funktion, die jetzt nachgerüstet wird.
Du kannst ja bestimmt auch so einen kleinen Faden und beide drum machen das.
Was mich interessieren würde, das wären Motorradfahrer, ob das unter dem Helm geht oder nicht. Das wär interessant.
Ich würde meinen, ja, warum sollte es nicht gehen?
Ich hab schon mal probiert diese kleinen Dinger mit Kabel halt noch so unter dem Helm und das, wenn der Helm schon aufsetzt, das zieht schon am Kabel, was ja auch immer so ein bisschen gummimäßig ist und schon rutscht das Ding aus dem Ohr. Also ich hab schon den Helm nicht aufsetzen können, ohne dass mir gleich das Ding aus dem Ohr gezogen wird. Deswegen würde mich mal interessieren, ob das...
Was ist mal mit Gaffa-Tail probiert?
Also ich meine, er meinte, glaube ich, wenn ich mich rechnen sollte, dass es jetzt in seine Ohren gut passt und dass die anderen auch schon immer gut gehalten haben. Ich hab ja schon mehrfach gesagt, bei mir hat keiner der Apple-Kopfhörer Halt gefunden. Ich hab wirklich nur immer so In-Ears mit so Gummi-Schnuffies, die dann so reingepresst werden, quasi, die wirklich halten. Deswegen hab ich jetzt bei den...
Da gibt's aber von Apple auch die In-Ear mit Gummi-Schnuffie zum Reintun.
Aber die haben ja nicht diese... Es gibt ja noch diese mit der nicht geraden Achse von den Kopfhörern, sondern diese leicht schrägen Achse. Skullcandy hat die zum Beispiel. Das sind die einzigen, die bei mir drin bleiben. Alles andere, die nehmen wir raus.
Deswegen, das ist jetzt noch mal unter Vorbehalt, aber er ist ja offensichtlich damit glücklich, nur dass er eben schon ein- oder zweimal nachkaufen musste und hier und da halt mal aufpasst, dass sie ihm nicht unüberlegt rausfliegen.
Was ich mich so frage, ist, kann man die im Apple Store anprobieren? Würde man das überhaupt wollen, wenn die schon die Dutzende von Leuten in den Ohren hatten?
Na einmal Desinfektionsspray darüber, fertig.
Oder einfach bestellen, passen, zurückschicken.
Also einfacher geht's nicht. Das Problem ist nur, erstmal welche zu kriegen. Also ich hab ja mich eine Weile gewehrt dagegen, ähm, aus verschiedenen Gründen und hab dann klein beigegeben und hab die dann doch bestellt. Natürlich zu einem Zeitpunkt, wo es hieß so, ja...
Februar, März, April, August.
Genau, also jetzt sind's glaub ich, als we speak, also angeblich soll sie zur nächsten Sendung einen Tag vorher spätestens da sein. So in zwei Wochen.
Hurra, wir haben ein Thema.
Tim hat ein Thema.
Wir haben jetzt schon ein Thema, weil ich hatte mich ja für diese Bluetooth-Headsets von Apple oder von Beats, der Marke Beats von Apple, entschieden. Trotz dem ich eigentlich Vorbehalte hatte. Aber am Ende habe ich ja beschlossen, dass mich eigentlich Komfort am meisten reizt. Komfort im Sinne von Usability, im Sinne von Integration. Weil ich fand halt bisher Bluetooth-Kopfhörer auch scheiße, einfach weil sie immer so bekloppt ansteuerbar waren. Dieses ganze Pairing und so vergisst dann weiß ich nicht wie viele Geräte merkt sich so ein Teil. Und ich hatte einfach die Schnauze voll. Und ich wollte zumindest mal hier in meinem schönen Ökosystem, also Macs plus iPhone etc. iPads, die Möglichkeit haben, seamless zwischen diesen Geräten hin und her zu schalten. Beziehungsweise mit dem Kopfhörer schnell einen Wechsel zu machen. Und das ist ja nun eins dieser Versprechen, die Apple mit seinem geilen W1-Chip und seinem unbenannten Pairing-Modell, was sie da haben. So und da dachte ich mir so, okay, beim ersten Testen waren die zwar nicht optimal, aber scheiß drauf. So und hab sie vorgezogen gegenüber diesen Bose QC35, die ja sicherlich ihre Vorteile haben, weil sie ja auch Features haben, die diese Beats Solo 3 Wireless überhaupt nicht haben, wie zum Beispiel Noise Cancelation. Ja, dann kamen die Dinger irgendwann an und dann hab ich sie ausprobiert. Und Pairing, das hat erstmal alles wunderbar funktioniert. War auch genauso, wie ich mir das dachte. Dann bin ich gleich zu meinem Macintosh gerannt und der kannte das Ding dann auch gleich. Und dann konnte ich da oben das Ding auswählen, konnte umschalten, konnte so zwischen iPhone und Macintosh hin und her schalten. Dann war ich erstmal ganz happy. Dann hatte ich dieses Problem, was ich ja hier glaube ich schon mal berichtet hatte, dass das dann halt mit dem Audio auf einmal so ausriss bei meinem Lieblingssong, stellte sich heraus, das Problem besteht dann, wenn du mit diesen Beats-Kopfhörern am iPhone hörst und in deinen Musik, also in Settings, Musik kannst du nochmal so eine Einstellung machen, mit Lautstärke anpassen. Also da gibt es irgendeinen, mach eine allgemeine, alle Songs gleich laut zum Ding. Ja, alles gleich laut heißt das vermutlich. Ich weiß nicht ganz genau, was der Effekt ist. In dem Fall ist der Effekt einfach, dass auf den Bluetooth-Kopfhörern, also zumindest auf diesen Bluetooth-Kopfhörern, mit meinem Kate Bush Song, Pi, das Ding einfach losknarrt. Setting ausgemacht, alles super. Also dieses Problem, Musik unerträglich, war damit irgendwie weg.
Lautstärke anpassen, das ist der?
Aber war das nur mit dem Song oder bei anderen Songs auch?
Ich hab's nur bei dem Song bemerkt. Also ich bin mir sicher, dass es auch noch andere Songs gibt. Spricht für mich auch, also hat mir bestätigt, dass ich da vielleicht nicht den falschen Song schon vorher ausgewählt hatte, um überhaupt Musik zu testen, weil ich schon immer das Gefühl hatte, der hat so ein bisschen in sich und das hat sich ja da auch bestätigt. Naja, so das waren ja meine First Impressions, die waren soweit ganz gut. Jetzt kommen so meine Second Impressions. Also, ich sag mal, durchwachsen. Was mich eigentlich am allermeisten stört, ist, dass dieses geile, ich schalt um und jeder Rechner in meiner kleinen iCloud-Familie kennt diese Headsets, na das funktioniert so 8-9 out of 10 times.
Das ist ja schon mal nicht schlecht.
Das ist...
5-9, Mann, 5-9.
Das will man haben.
Also, mit 9 von 10 oder 9,5 von 10, ja vielleicht, aber ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe überhaupt keinen Grund, warum es nicht einfach immer gehen soll. Also, wenn ich mein Kabel von einem Kabel-Kopfhörer in eine Buchse reinstecke, dann geht das.
Da war es wieder, das Kabel-Pairing.
Ja, von 10 Versuchen funktioniert das 10 Mal. So, und so ein Bluetooth-Kopfhörer muss, muss zumindest annähernd in diesen Wert reinkommen. Ich akzeptiere das Weglassen eines Kabels. Das auch mal schlechter funktionieren, aber 8 von 10. Und vor allem total erratisch. Ich sitze da immer und denke mir so, why? Ich schalte so hin und her, mal höre ich auf dem iPad was, dann höre ich auf dem Mac was, dann will ich auf meinem iPhone wieder einschalten und das Ding taucht nie auf. Das liegt direkt daneben. Der sieht das irgendwie, Bluetooth ist da, erkennt das, er ist gepairt, authentifiziert, alles, 50.000 Mal schon benutzt und es taucht da nicht auf. Und dann ist es so, was muss man dann machen? Dann muss man doch wieder in die Bluetooth-Settings gehen. Wo ich mir dachte, genau die will ich eigentlich nicht mehr sehen. Das interessiert mich nicht, dass das Bluetooth ist. Bluetooth, schon der Name. Eine Liste, wo du reingehst und wo ich ja allen Scheiß, was Bluetooth ist, wo ich jede Box sehe, wo ich auf meinem Macintosh irgendwie 50 V-Modes aufgelistet bekomme, da muss ich dann irgendwie meinen Kopfhörer aussuchen und anschalten. Und vor allem, du hast auch noch das Problem, du gehst oben beim Mac in die Auswahl rein und dann tauchen die auch nicht sofort auf, sondern es ist so 21, 22, sind sie da. Und wenn sie nicht da sind, weißt du nicht, ob du noch bis 23, 24 warten musst, und dann sind sie immer noch nicht da. Und dann merkst du erst, sie sind nicht da. Und dann musst du in ein anderes Menü gehen. Warum überhaupt? Ich meine, wenn er die kennt, wenn er weiß, dass sie vielleicht unter Umständen da sein könnten. Warum ist das Menü zum Aktivier-der-Scheiß-Teil? Warum ist es nicht an der Stelle?
Ist das jetzt alles dein Beats-Ding oder was?
Ich rede nur von diesem Solo 3, weil es von Beats.
Okay, weil ich hab jetzt hier, können wir ja reden, weil wir erwähnen ja ganz viele Marken hier, ich hab ja diesen von ZenPizer. Und ich hab auch so ein Bose-Lautsprecher-Dings, das ist kein Kopfhörer, aber es ist ja auch Bluetooth-Audio. Da kann ich nur empfehlen, das ist so ein geiler, schwerer Kasten, und den finde ich einfach gut. Klingt nicht so doll, aber... Das ist sozusagen die Mac-Lite der Bluetooth-Lautsprecher.
Das stimmt allerdings.
Ich finde das gut.
Oh, da hab ich auch jetzt ein Gerät gekauft.
Wenn das runterfällt, ziehst du den Fuß weg als Reflex. Egal, was ich zurückgehen will, die sind ja auch beide mit Bluetooth gepaart. Und ehrlich gesagt, am Anfang hatte ich so ein bisschen Schwierigkeiten mit dem Bluetooth. Ich hab das Gefühl, das ist jetzt durch die Updates besser geworden. Hörst du zu noch? So, das ist durch die Updates besser geworden. Aber auch, glaube ich, einen Grund, warum ich am Anfang zumindest immer Schwierigkeiten hatte. Weil die sind eigentlich, ja, eigentlich sind die alle verschwunden. Also ich würde jetzt mal sagen, ich bin schon jetzt bei besser als 9.5 von 10. Am Anfang hatte ich die Schwierigkeiten, weil ich hab halt meinen Desktop, meinen Laptop und ein Telefon. Das sind drei Geräte, wo diese Dinger gepaart sind. Aber die wollen immer nur mit Zweien gepaart sein. Und wenn du gerade auf dem Dritten, was nicht bei den letzten beiden dabei ist, auch wenn du gerade auf dem hören willst, und er ist aber auf den anderen beiden, dann musst du eins von den anderen beiden immer erst so künstlich rausschmeißen, damit du das so ein bisschen vergisst, damit du den neuen denn da rein kriegst. Und eigentlich hab ich jetzt immer noch drei Geräte. Entweder hab ich jetzt eins von den dreien lange nicht benutzt, dass es klappt, oder die Updates hier so 10, 12 und hier iOS und so haben das irgendwie besser gemacht. Weil sie haben ja auch oft geschrieben, wir haben das jetzt verbessert, wir haben das verbessert. Sie sind ja die ganze Zeit dabei, gerade Bluetooth, Kopfhörer, Audiozeugs irgendwie zu verändern. Und ich hab keine Probleme mehr eigentlich.
Weißt du, was der eigentliche Trick ist? Habt lange mit diesem Soundlink-Mini.
Mit dem Aktivieren nicht.
Ich hab lange, lange gebraucht, um das rauszufinden. Ich hab irgendwie fünf oder sechs Geräte an dem Ding gepährt. Und du kannst auf die Bluetooth-Taste drücken. Wenn du einmal drückst, genau, dann sagt dir, welcher ist jetzt gerade angeschlossen. Und dann kannst du anfangen, durchzuzyceln. Und er sagt dir immer, welches Gerät er als nächstes machen würde. Und dann nimmt er das einfach.
Ja gut, das ist jetzt bei dem der Fall, aber bei dem Sennheiser oder auch bei dem Beats, da geht das ja irgendwie nicht. Aber ehrlich gesagt hab ich hier schon lange keine Probleme. Ich sag, also der ist einfach auf meinem Telefon und meinem Laptop irgendwie gepährt. Und das Schlimme ist eigentlich eher, dass wenn ich irgendwas Musik oder Film gucke auf dem Laptop, und dann mach ich auf dem Telefon irgendwas, was Audio macht, dann schaltet er um und hält auch sogar kurz das Video an, damit er den Sound von dem Telefon kurz dazwischen funken lassen kann. Und das nervt manchmal ein bisschen. Aber ich versteh auch, dass sie das machen, weil es dann eben einfach umschaltet, je nachdem, was ich gerade benutze, ohne dass ich irgendwas machen muss. Aber so 8 von 10 würde ich jetzt nicht mehr sagen. Das war vielleicht ganz am Anfang so, so vor letzten Sommer, aber inzwischen ist das deutlich besser.
Du hast doch irgendwelche...
Ist doch egal, ich hab Audio, Bluetooth. Darum geht's doch.
Nein, es geht um das iCloud-basierte Pairing von diesem Appelscheiß.
Aber das macht man noch einmal.
Ja, aber es taucht ja nicht... Pass auf, das ist so. Wenn ich jetzt diese Kopfhörer aufhabe, das ist das, wonach ich mich sehne. Ich höre jetzt Sachen auf meinem iPhone. Bei irgendeinem Podcast sitzt es an meinem Rechner. Krieg ich irgendwie so einen Twitter-Link vor die Nase, hier Video schnell angucken. Dann möchte ich das auf den Kopfhörern hören. Dann gehe ich oben in mein Sound-Menü.
Du musst extra umschalten.
Irgendwas muss ich ja schon tun. Es ist ein Unterschied, ob ich in ein Bluetooth-Settings-Menü gehe, ein Device aus einer langen Liste von Geräten raussuche und da auf Connect klicke. Oder ob ich einfach oben im Audio-Menü den Kopfhörer...
Aus einer langen Liste... Wie war das?
Ich schalte den Kopfhörer ein, der perrt sich automatisch und dann kann ich loshören.
Wie schaltest du auf dein iPhone um?
Gar nicht, ich mache auf dem iPhone irgendwie Audio und der schaltet von alleine um.
Wenn du auf deinem Rechner was hörst...
Dann hält er den Film an und macht dann solange ich hier Audio mache.
Ja, das macht der Soundlink.
Wodurch, dass du nur Play machst.
Wenn das hier irgendwie Audio abspielt, hört er auf dem Laptop auf und schaltet dorthin um. Und wenn ich das hier wieder rausgehe aus der App oder das iPhone ausmache, dann schaltet er wieder zurück.
Aber wenn du dein iPhone auf Lautsprecher hast, dann bist du doch auf Lautsprecher hören. Schaltet der dann immer auf deinen Kopfhörer auf, wenn du das nicht willst?
Wie auf Lautsprecher? Wenn du den Kopfhörer auf hast, sowieso, und du sitzt an deinem Laptop, dann kann ich das Telefon mit Lautsprecher eh nicht hören. Oder du nimmst halt deine fucking Kopfhörer, aber dann kannst du ja auch umschalten. Aber eigentlich will ich doch die Kopfhörer auf behalten und deswegen switcht er den Sound automatisch rüber, wenn das Sound auf dem iPhone kommt.
Aber vielleicht willst du das ja auch.
Aber während du mit deinem Rechner, mit deinen Headsets, mit deinem Rechner connected sind, sind sie doch nicht mit dem Telefon connected.
Das hätte das für beide connected.
Das Telefon hat zwei Bluetooth-Connections gleichzeitig.
Nein, das Laptop hat eine Connection zu dem Kopfhörer und das Telefon hat eine Connection zu dem Kopfhörer.
Zwei Connections.
Ja, aber nicht das Telefon, sondern der Kopfhörer hat zwei.
Der Kopfhörer hält zwei Connections. Auf beiden Geräten steht connected.
Ja.
Das ist aber nicht bei jedem Headphone so. Welches ist das noch?
Sennheiser Momentum Wireless 2.
Ja, okay, aber nur zwei.
Dieses Ding, zu dem wir später kommen, macht das angeblich auch.
Ich rede von was anderem.
Du redest von diesem Pairing.
Ich habe einen Rechner, ich habe noch einen Rechner, ich habe ein iPad und ich habe ein Telefon. Und ich will an jedem dieser Geräte jederzeit, indem ich den Audio-Ausgang auswähle, umschalten auf mein Headset. Das heißt, ich gehe im iPhone auf, hochsliden, Audio-Menü, im Player.
Also da, wo auch Apple TV auftaucht und so weiter.
Da wo Apple TV, wo Kopfhörer, wo Headset, wo Lautsprecher, also in dem da? Nee, in dem Player.
Ach so.
In dem Player-Control. Den da war übrigens eben der...
Oder welcher Player?
Nein!
Von unten hoch, dann bekommst du diese ganzen Buttons. Dann schweißt du einmal rechts.
Ja, das... Du meinst, du hast gerade mir iTunes gezeigt.
Du meinst hier den und dann das da unten oder was? Ja, sag das doch. Das ist doch das Gleiche. Das war noch früher nicht so versteckt.
Das ist ja die Audio-Auswahl.
Ja, früher war das direkt hier vorne. Da brauchte ich halt auch nie wieder, weil es funktioniert jetzt einfach.
Man, das iCloud-Versprechen hier ist ja, dass wenn mein Kopfhörer in meinen iCloud-Account eingebucht ist, dass er automatisch auf allen Geräten als Audio-Device angezeigt wird. Und ich überall umschalten kann. Ich gehe an irgendeinen Mac, ich sage, welches Audio hätten sie denn gern? Und da steht das Teil.
Ohne, dass du paren musst, ohne alles.
Ohne, dass ich mir jetzt über irgendwie Bluetooth-Settings oder irgendeinen Scheiß, ich wähle einfach nur ein Audio-Ausgang aus und es ist vollkommen egal, ob das Bluetooth ist oder so. Es ist, als wäre der da immer dran. Ich gehe in dieses Menü, er taucht nicht sofort auf, aber er taucht nach einer kurzen Zeit auf. Ich sehe ihn, er zeigt mir auch den Akkustand an in dem Moment, meistens zumindest. Und wähle ich das Ding dann aus, verbindet er sich damit und dann ist das jetzt meine Quelle, der Rechner, auf dem ich das gerade ausgewählt habe. Soweit die Theorie, ein bisschen auch die Praxis. Praktisch leider renne ich immer wieder in die Situation, dass das Telefon das Ding doch nicht anzeigt oder der Rechner das Ding doch nicht anzeigt. Und das finde ich ein bisschen enttäuschend. Das ist enttäuschender Punkt Nummer eins.
Was ist das übliche iCloud-Problem, das einfach nicht rockt?
Na ja, kann man... Ich glaube nicht, dass das wirklich ein iCloud-Problem ist, weil es ist ja offensichtlich, dass diese Geräte das schonen, wissen, dass das Ding da ist. Nur in irgendeiner Form... Ich weiß es nicht. Keine Ahnung, wo der Bug ist, aber er existiert. Ist auch noch zu beheben, ist aber derzeit nicht berufen. Zweites Problem, was ich mit diesen Kopfhörern habe. Die sehen ja nun irgendwie auch sehr sleek aus, muss man ja sagen. Sleek aussehen hilft aber meistens nicht unbedingt bei Passformen und so. Was echt das Problem ist, hast zwar hier oben so einen Bügel und der hat auch so relativ weiches Gummi und man möchte ja meinen, das hält irgendwie ganz gut, aber das ist einfach nicht der Grad an Stabilität, den ich gerne haben möchte. Das ist ja der Punkt, wo ich auch immer sage, nichts geht über die HD25 von Sennheiser mit diesem Doppelbügel. Da klappst du diesen Doppelbügel auf und dann kannst du abmorschen, bis der Art kommt. Das Ding regt sich einfach kein Millimeter von der Stelle.
Ehrlich gesagt würde ich dich jetzt gerne mal abmorschen.
Bis der Arzt kommt.
Naja, und dann setzt du dir halt hier diese Beats auf und da musst du halt nur einmal Kapuze aufsetzen, kapuze wieder runter und dann ist das Ding halt schon nicht mehr da, wo es vorher ist. Also der sitzt einfach nicht. Kann ich gerade noch irgendwie mitleben, aber wo ich dann so richtig abgequatsen hab, das Ding schaltet sich bei Minusgraden einfach aus. Du läufst dann mit diesen Dingern draußen.
Das hat ein Apple-Akku.
Designed in Kalifornien. Die haben da keine Minusgrade.
Das ist auch einer der Gründe, warum ich überhaupt dieses Format so mag. Diese On-Ear-Dinger.
Weil die ja auch die Ohren warm halten.
Im Gegensatz zu kleinen Klingel-Dinger, weil sie mir die Ohren warm halten.
Ich sehe echt viele mit diesen Bose-Dinger im Winter, wo du genau weißt, warum sie die jetzt aufhaben.
Ich trag die jetzt auch quasi täglich.
Ja, einfach so als Ohrpuschel. Auch wenn da gar nichts bei rauskommt. Und kannst ja auch da ein bisschen die Realität ausblenden, indem du da dein Noise-Cancellation machst. Und so musst du ja noch nicht mal irgendwas hören. Du hast einfach Ruhe und Wärme.
Ruhe und warme Ohren, ich meine.
Ruhe hab ich auch, weil das Gerät schaltet sich halt einfach dann ab. Also du hörst irgendwas so und du warst halt lang genug in minus 5 Grad unterwegs und dann irgendwie... Und nicht, dass der Akku leer ist oder so.
Nee, das ist dieses Standard-Apple-Akku-Problem. Da kommt halt, umso kälter der ist, umso mehr droppt wahrscheinlich die Voltage runter. Und der Controller sagt, okay, wenn die Voltage jetzt so wenig ist, dann ist die Batterie wohl leer, dann schaltet er sich aus. Und wenn die Batterie wieder warm ist, dann steigt die Voltage auf wieder und dann sagt das Gerät, ja, alles wieder super, wir sind wieder voll am Start. Und dann zeigt auch wieder die richtige Leistung an.
Ich sag nur eins.
Deswegen tauschen wir bei den iPhones die Batterien gerade aus. Hab ich doch gesagt.
Ja, die kennen keine Minus gerade. Schon allein, weil sie Fahrenheit benutzen.
So, dann war ich leider an dem entscheidenden Tag, wo ich hätte in mich gehen müssen, mit Schickst du sie zurück oder nicht?
Warst du da verpeilt?
Ja, war ich leider so dermaßen auf einmal von anderen wichtigen Ereignissen übermant und hatte dann keine Zeit mehr. Sodass ich die jetzt immer noch besitze, aber ich überlege trotzdem, ob ich nicht vielleicht doch noch mal was anderes ausprobiere. Und da jetzt diese Syncing Experience dann doch irgendwie nicht so geil ist, kann ich es dann auch noch mal mit so normalen Stinke-Bluetooth probieren. Ich habe mir natürlich auch Earpods bestellt, weil mir nämlich zwischendurch auch klar geworden ist, dass Dinge vielleicht nicht ganz so wild sind, wie ich dachte. Ich dachte ja immer, ohne Lautstärkenkontrolle geht es nicht. Und in gewisser Hinsicht bin ich da auch immer noch dabei. Man kann hier bei den Wireless-Dingern passabel die Lautstärke ändern. Du hast ja da links einen großen Mittel-Taster und drum herum den Ring. Und wenn du oben den Ring drückst, wird es lauter. Ich finde, es ist immer noch zu wenig getrennt voneinander. Man muss ja auch die Möglichkeit haben, sowas mit Handschuhen sicher bedienen zu können, weil du willst nicht die ganze Zeit, wenn du lauter oder leiser machst, an- und ausschalten. Das ist nervig. Von daher kann man da noch was verbessern. Hat aber grundsätzlich schon mal funktioniert und ist meistens auch praktisch, weil man eben dein Scheiß-Telefon nicht rausholen muss. Das heißt, du kannst das Ding einfach in der Tasche versenken und für die nächste Viertelstunde Fahrradfahren brauchst du dich, um dieses Ding nicht mehr zu kümmern. So, das hast du natürlich bei diesen Earpods nicht. Aber was mir dann irgendwie aufgefallen ist, als ich nochmal ein bisschen dran nachgedacht habe, ist, die Earpods lösen unter Umständen andere Probleme. Weil man sie nämlich tragen kann, wo man bisher Kopfhörer noch nicht tragen kann, wenn man zum Beispiel eine warme, enge Mütze auf hat. Oder überhaupt dieses Kapuzenpullover-Problem. Oder Helme haben wir gerade diesen Aspekt, also dass man die Dinger halt auf einmal ins Ohr kriegt, obwohl man eigentlich klamottentechnisch komplett abgeschirmt ist.
Wobei genau dieses Kapuzen-Thema, weil da halt dann doch noch ein bisschen so spiel ist, da meinte, glaube ich, der Kollege, dass ihm da die...
Ja, das kann natürlich sein....
so rauswischen. Enge Mütze vielleicht schon eher dann.
Ich werde es ausprobieren. Mal sehen. Weil diese Kabelfreiheit ist eigentlich schon ganz krank.
Da geht ja mit dem neuen Phone auch nicht anders.
Ich habe es ja vergessen.
Achso, du willst jetzt auch noch was zu Bluetooth sagen?
Die ganz kleine Sache zu Bluetooth, das hatte ich irgendwie auf meiner Wunschliste drauf und hat mir jemand geschickt. Vielen Dank dafür. Das Ding heißt E-Syncing oder E-Synkin, wie auch immer man es ausspricht. We are E-Syncing, genau, irgendwie so. Das ist so ein mini kleines Viereck. Also es ist ein bisschen größer als hier auf dem Originalding.
Pack's aus!
Ja, ich hab das nicht mit.
Links, links, E-Synkin.
E-Synkin.
I oder E?
Das ist im Prinzip ein Bluetooth-Empfänger, wo hinten Kinschdinger dran sind. Und das hab ich tatsächlich verwendet, um meine Aktivboxen an die Apple TV anzuschließen. Das Ding tut nichts anderes, und das tut es tatsächlich wirklich gut.
Batteriebetrieben, oder?
Nee, da ist so ein Steckernetzteil dabei.
Also so ein super kleines Teil, damit man größeres Netzteil hat als das Gerät selbst.
Nee, das Netzteil ist auch relativ klein. Also es ist schon okay. Also, ja, das ist keine Macht.
USB-Kabel wenigstens, oder normal?
Wie USB.
Strom?
Nö. Ich glaube nicht. Einfach nur so ein...
Na ja, so ein runder...
So ein runder Nupsee an so einem Steckernetzteil.
Ja, verstehe.
Aber es tut zuverlässig und ich hab jetzt vor allen Dingen zuverlässig regelbaren Sound an der Apple TV. Was halt vorher mit diesem dämlichen Monitor nicht ging, der da dran ist, weil der Monitor das nicht rafft, dass man auf der Fernbedienung laut leise drückt. Na ich koppel ihn mit dem Apple TV.
Ach so, weil der A, A, A.
Der muss ja Bluetooth haben, sonst könnte er mit den HomeKit-Geräten ja nicht kommunizieren.
Also Apple TV macht Bluetooth und dann perch dieses Ding über Bluetooth und hängen da meine Boxen dran und alles ist gut. Funktioniert ohne Problem.
Wie lange bootet der? Ist der instant da?
Was der?
Weil ich hab bei mir nämlich meine Airpod Express dran und bevor die da ist, damit ich die Audio hinschicken kann, das dauert eine Weile, bis die gebootet hat.
Also er bootet schneller als die Apple TV selber, aber die mach ich eigentlich auch nicht aus, sondern die schläg ich ja immer nur schlafen. Also es ist jetzt... Sagen wir mal so, ich steck den ein, dann schalt ich die Lautsprecher ein, die brauchen auch noch eine Weile, bis die sich irgendwie anschalten. Die Aktivboxen...
Verstehst also schnell da.
Ist schnell genug für meine Verhältnisse, ist irgendwie nicht nervig oder so.
Da fällt mir gerade noch so eine Limitierung ein. Das kam irgendwie hier im Metaebene-Chat, auf das jemand meinte, ja die neuen Earpods sind ja total toll, da kann man dann auch endlich mal zu zweit irgendwo zuhören. Weil man ja sozusagen den rechten und den linken... Jemand anderem geben kann. Ist natürlich dann halt nur ein Kanal. Und dann fiel mir auf so, was mach ich eigentlich bei Bluetooth, wenn zwei Leute zuhören sollen? Es gibt keine Möglichkeit.
Gibt es keinen Bluetooth Y-Adapter?
Ich meine, wie machst du denn das?
App-ID.
Das ist jetzt mit Kabel?
Doch, sowieso per...
Wie machen das denn die Earpods?
Per DRM nicht erlaubt.
Der eine nimmt den einen und der andere nimmt den anderen.
Nee, aber ich meine, ja, aber trotzdem sind die Earpods zwei Bluetooth-Devices oder quatschen die Earpods dann untereinander. Nee, also es geht prinzipiell schon.
Wie die Kommunikation, also ob die beiden untereinander noch, ich glaub nicht, dass die sich untereinander noch mal sinken, sondern die sinken sich einfach aus demselben Signal so zuverlässig, dass sie halt gesinkt sind. Aber what do I know? Ja, aber ich meine, wenn ich jetzt ein iPad hab, wo dann irgendwie zwei Kinder einen Film gucken sollen, was wirklich in manchen Momenten eines Elternlebens ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr wichtiger Moment ist.
Mehr als bei Kindern, ne?
Das wissen alle Eltern, die wenigsten geben mir das zu.
Ja, das ist so wichtig. Du stehst da so zu kreisen und... Das muss dann funktionieren. Und ich hab noch so Kabel-Kopfhörer, die sogar zwei Anschlüsse haben, wo der zweite immer durchschleift. Also erstens kannst du das Kabel an der Seite reinstecken, wo du es gerne hättest, und du kannst an dem anderen eben noch einen Kopfhörer ranstecken und die einfach so daisy-chainen. Also ich muss noch nicht mal so einen Y-Adapter mitführen. So, und dann sitzt du da die strahlenden Kinder vor den Gru und...
Aber je nach Kind kann das schwierig werden, oder? Wenn zwei Kinder mit Kabel- und Kopfhörern miteinander verbunden sind.
Wie ist denn so das schwierig werden?
Weil Kabel eine Maximal-Länge haben und Kinder eine...
Die müssen sich da immer mit dem iPad...
Maximal Ruhe...
Ja, aber wenn der Film läuft, dann weißt du, wie groß die Bereitschaft ist, zusammen zu rücken und sich nicht zu streiten. Also das ist sozusagen...
Sehr gering, sehr gering, weil sie dann an dem iPad zerren, weil jeder will es direkt vor der Nase haben.
Wie auch immer, das ist... Händelbar, aber nicht händelbar ist, wenn du gar keinen Klinkenausgang mehr hast.
Im nächsten iPad wahrscheinlich, meinst du?
Also wahrscheinlich muss ich als nächstes einen akkubetriebenen Bluetooth-Audioadapter mit Doppelklinkenausgang mitführen.
Oder einen Lightning-Doc was laden und Audioadapter-Genutzung gleichzeitig ermöglichen. So ein Lightning-Y-Doc, was du unten ransteckst, damit du einerseits dein iPad beim Filmgucken laden kannst und andererseits Audio rausführen kannst.
Ja, okay, ich kann natürlich immer noch... Aber ich fände es auch generell jetzt keinen Fehler, wenn die Computer einfach mal vorsehen würden, dass man über mehr als ein Audio-Device auskommt.
Oder Multicast besser.
Multicast! Gibt es dafür eigentlich eine Bingo-Karte?
Ja, richtig.
Ich glaube, ich habe da schon was von gelesen, von Bluetooth, Multicast.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Und wer weiß, vielleicht machen die das ja mit ihren AirPods schon.
Ich habe auf jeden Fall auch noch einen kleinen Beitrag zum Thema Bluetooth, weil auch wenn ich mich des Blauzahns eigentlich weitestgehend verweigere, hatte ich doch die Notwendigkeit, in meiner bescheidenen Behausung hier und da in einem anderen Zimmer mal Musik zu hören, als meine Hauptlautsprecher stehen. Und nach Evaluierung verschiedenster Bluetooth-mobiler Lautsprecher bin ich dann beim Marshall Kilburn gelandet, der so aussieht wie ein Marshall-Verstärker, auch von Marshall gebrandet ist.
Die Optik schreckt mich ehrlich gesagt ab.
Ja, ich war auch skeptisch, aber ich pack den Link mal in die Show Notes. Der hat überragend gute Reviews in allen möglichen Tests für den Sound gehabt. Und ich kann euch bestätigen, das Ding macht ordentlich Druck. Also wenn man mal kompakt Leute und Räume beschallen will, kann man das mit diesem Lautsprecher gut tun. Und das Pairing, wie ihr es beschrieben habt, so Bluetooth hier und so, ganz easy, ohne Stress, das hat da auch wunderbar funktioniert.
Ja, dann bringe ich dir noch ein nächstes Mal mit, dann bring ich mein Bose mit, dann machen wir mal ein Shootout.
Battle of the Bluetooth-Beakers.
Ich finde den Bose nach wie vor zu basslastig.
Ist er auch.
Und der hat hier einen Bass- und Treble-Regler, ne?
Nee, der Bose, ich stelle den immer so hoch, dass er irgendwie etwas freier im Raum steht.
Du darfst ihn einfach nicht direkt an die Wand stellen, weil der nutzt die Wand hinter sich.
Ja, du darfst ihn auch nicht direkt auf den Tisch stellen, weil er ist echt eine fiese Bass-Überhöhung. Ich habe sogar schon im Support geschrieben, ob man da irgendwas machen kann. Da waren die etwas knumpftig, aber naja.
Der Bose ist ja nun auch schon immer bekannt für Bass, oder mit ihren kleinen Mini-Lautsprechern, dass sie da so viel Bass rausholen können.
Die Kopfhörer haben nicht so eine Bass-Überhöhung, also das ist irgendwie...
Wenn wir jetzt mit diesem Bluetooth-Thema fertig sind, würde ich ja mal euch gerne eine Frage stellen, weil ich habe letztens auf OS 10 oder Mac OS, wie es jetzt heißt, ein Tool gefunden, das war mir noch gar nicht bekannt. Und zwar nennt sich dieses Tool NetTop. Wer von euch kenntet?
NetTop, ich glaube, ich habe das mal benutzt, aber das ist lange her.
Ich sage es jetzt erstmal nicht, aber wenn das ein Abklatsch von PFTOP und diesen ganzen anderen Netzwerktops ist, dann schon.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, also ich kannte das jetzt so nicht. Mach mal auf den Hauptschirm hier, Tim. Und mach mal Fullscreen. Also groß, weil du kriegst halt nicht nur welche Ups, wie viele Ports und welche Ports und V4 oder V6 aufhaben. Du kriegst die Interfaces, den In- und Out. Und irgendwie, weiß nicht warum du das bei dir jetzt nicht siehst, ich hab jetzt auf meinem Schirm im Fullscreen auch noch die Roundtrip-Times pro Connection. Also zum Beispiel hier bei Slack.
Ich muss einfach kleiner machen.
Ja, oder genau so. Du kriegst halt auch dann die Roundtrip-Time-Averages von den Connections. Also du kriegst richtig, richtig viel Info. Und das Krasse ist, im Terminal kannst du halt auch scrollen. Also du kannst einfach so da geschmeidig durch deine Liste von Connections hoch und runter scrollen und es updatet sich auch noch. Also es ist ein richtig komfortables...
Mit so so ein Schaf, wie manche Seiten würden.
Also ich finde das ziemlich geil, um mal eben auch ohne GUI zu gucken, was auf dem Mac so sprudelt und welche Sockets und Connections so offen sind. Also auf jeden Fall übersichtlicher als ein Netzdat. Also falls ihr das auch noch nicht kanntet, ich bin da wie gesagt auch nur durch Zufall irgendwie drüber gestolpert.
Aber ist dich dabei oder doch? Doch.
Das ist standard. Krass.
Alte Waldfee hier.
Na dann bin ich ja froh, dass ich ja auch mal was zeigen konnte im Terminal. War mir auch nicht bekannt irgendwie.
Nee, das ist richtig super, weil du siehst auch mal die ganzen Listening Ports und was Established und Close Weight ist.
Wie gesagt, diese Roundtrip Averages finde ich halt auch ziemlich geil.
Roundtrip Averages?
Das ist hier so, da wo...
128 steht. 120 steht da.
Das ist sozusagen, wenn da wirklich in der Daten fließen oder was.
Ja, wenn es TCP ist und so.
Mach mal Doppelklick auf so eine Connection. Du hast ja gerade die Farbliche hervorgehoben. War das schon Curses oder war das deine Selection?
Meine Selection.
Okay, dann hätte ich sagen können, dass das Programm auch noch reagiert.
Ja, APSD, das ist auch wieder so ein Prozess. Wenn man sich fragt, was ist das eigentlich?
Der Prozess.
Der Prozess. Aber warte mal, Roundtrip, also wann steht denn da ein Wert und wann nicht?
Wahrscheinlich, wenn du, wenn Daten gerade fließen.
Ja, für UDP-Connections dann dementsprechend natürlich nicht. Aber für TCPs, wenn du vielleicht einen ACK bekommst oder so.
Wenn Daten da fließen oder müssen da noch mehr Daten fließen?
Ich hab hier beim Launch-Themen, weiß ich nicht, wie viele Ports der offen hat, die stehen alle auf Listen. Und da ist natürlich kein Roundtrip.
Nein, das ist ja klar, aber ich hab hier mehr.
Hier, da wo Established ist, ist Roundtrip.
Stimmt, also da oben war alles nicht Established oder was?
Nee, hier die beiden sind Established.
Okay, alles klar, also immer wenn es Established ist.
Oder nicht UDP.
Das heißt, man sieht sozusagen für die einzelnen Verbindungen, wie schnell die so end to end sind. Also wie latenz da ist.
Einmal hin und zurück.
Und warum ist mein, ah, okay.
Mich würde vor allen Dingen mal interessieren, also es steht da, wenn sie das Open Source machen.
Vor allem, man sieht ja mal richtig, was V6 ist und was nicht.
Ja genau, ich glaube, deswegen bin ich irgendwie auch drauf. Also irgendwie, also sie ist bei Slack zum Beispiel, dann halt auch, was die machen, weil offiziell deren Api unterstützt kein V6, aber sie haben ein paar V6-Verbindungen.
Dann kann man so richtig V4-Shaming machen.
In der nächsten OS-Version gibt es nicht nur die Apps mit erheblichem Stromverbrauch, sondern Apps mit erheblichem V4-Verbrauch.
Hier zum Beispiel Bitcoin QT.
Na wieso, ist Listen auf 6 aber immerhin? Du hast vielleicht gerade keinen V6.
Na die da draußen haben keinen V6. Du konnektierst mit V4 überall hin.
Wie die draußen?
Na es gibt nicht genug V6-Gegenstellen.
V6-Gegner.
Und hier das Resilio-Sync macht auch nur V4.
Das wundert mich jetzt nicht so, aber...
Da hat auch kein V6 offen. Was? Die machen keinen V6?
Also in der Man-Page steht unten Darwin, February 8th 2017. Aber das war wahrscheinlich das letzte Update.
Ahem, meine ganzen... Ah ne, doch, hier gibt es auch ein paar andere.
Ein guter Fund auf jeden Fall.
Ja, sehr guter Fund.
Du hast jetzt eine schöne Bett-Einschlaf-Beschäftigung noch mit dem Tablet, wie alle deine Connections, Protokoll.
Ja, vor allem das ist auch so ein geiles Angebertool. Wenn du mal wieder zu einem Freund gerufen bist, ich hab ein Problem mit meinem Internet. So, ein Problem. Das ist so das Äquivalent zum Matrix-Moment.
Also die Man-Page, die hat irgendwie auch noch so einige Modifier-Keys dann irgendwie parat, was man dann noch so...
Toggle Human Readable Numbers, auch schön, ne?
Slack?
Ja, die hosten halt auf Amazon. Die haben immer noch keinen V6 da? Nein, Amazon nicht. Die haben halt Amazon halt auf den Elastic Load Balancer V6, aber auf den Elastic Cloud Machine. Heißen die so?
Willst du mir noch nicht erzählen, dass Twitter keinen V6 hat?
ap.twitter.com Keine IPv6 Adresse.
Nein! Really?
Die Webseite hat glaube ich... Ich mach mal kurz einen Dick. Ja, das ist alles, was so...
Können alle ja gar nix.
Also Facebook ist V6, wenn er jetzt hier...
Da hast du mir jetzt was gezeigt. Let's Top.
Interfaces marked as expensive.
Letty, was mit dir? Bist du noch da?
Nochmal Schokolade holen.
Jetzt sind wir überhaupt in der Zeit. Wir sind eigentlich am Ende ein bisschen.
Wir sind auf jeden Fall schon fortgeschritten.
Also haben wir noch was Wichtiges.
Ihr habt jetzt hier noch Dinge in euren Listen. Ich hab mir alles von der Seele.
Also hier, ich mach mal ein paar Sachen.
Und zwar hatte ich was auf meiner Amazon-Rundschlist. Und da war ein großzügiger Spender, hat mir eine Sache zukommen lassen. Und zwar ist das hier, behaupte ich jetzt mal, solange einer das Gegenteil behauptet, die Mutter aller USB-Voltage-Monitore. Mit OLED-Display in Farbe. Ich kann es bei mir nicht anschließen, weil ich hab ja USB-Zone.
Wie viel Strom verbraucht denn das OLED-Display?
Aber darum geht's ja nicht. Sondern mit dem Ding kannst du halt, also der zeigt, wir haben ja schon mal diesen kleinen Billigdinger vorgestellt. Kann man abschalten, das ist nur der Startscreen. Das kann man ja halt, die Volt und Ampere sind, die halt durch den Anschluss durchgehen. Und der zeigt dann aber auch Watt an und wie viel Ampere schon durchgeschoben hat.
Wie heißt das Ding?
Ja, das ist schwierig jetzt.
Und zwar die Firma heißt XYZX Studio.
Hast du einen Link?
Und das Teil heißt ZY1270. Link. Ich bin da nicht in diesem Slack. Such mal nach ZY1270. ZY1270. Das Slack ist mir zu Slack. ZY1270 heißt er. Die haben verschiedene.
ZY1270.
Da die meisten Akkubooster und so weiter auch noch das normale USB haben, finde ich das schon auch okay, dass er das auch noch so hat. Jedenfalls, er kann alles möglich anzeigen. Er hat einen Button, du kannst durchcyceln, er hat Menüs und du kannst auch Sachen einstellen und speichern und du kannst auch hier Longtime-Monitor machen. Du kannst damit auch deinen Stromausgang nehmen, das Ding kalibrieren und dann merkt er sich, wie viel Volt da kommt. Dann schließt du das Teil über dein Kabel an, was du testen möchtest und dann guckt er, wie viel Verlust auf deinem Kabel ist. Wenn ihr das kennt, ihr habt manchmal so Kabel, die wollen einfach nicht ordentlich eure Geräte laden. Und das machst du dann mit dem, testest das einmal ohne Kabel, merkst du die Voltage, schließt das wieder an und drückst einmal den Kalibrier-Button, dass er sich das merkt, schließt das mit Kabel an und dann zeigt er dir genau hier, ich hab hier ein halbes Volt irgendwie Abfall und so viel Widerstand auf dem Kabel und wenn das irgendwie zu viel ist, dann weißt du, das Ding ist Schrott und du solltest das Kabel mal wegschmeißen. Und das gibt's ja wirklich zu Genüge, dass man Kackkabel hat irgendwie. Und er sagt dann auch, wenn du das an einen Apple anschließt, hat jetzt bei mir letztens nicht so geklappt, aber er sagt dir, ob das halt ein Apple-Netzteil ist oder ob das hier eher so ein Quick Charge, hier QI ist oder so was. Also er kann da schon eine Menge irgendwie auch noch rausfinden. Das, was ich jetzt hier nicht hab, aber es gibt auch, man kann einen Deckel abnehmen und so einen Deckel mit so einem Bluetooth-Adapter draufsetzen, dann kannst du sogar hier richtig Longtime-Blogging machen und das per Bluetooth irgendwie dauerhaft mitschneiden. Wenn du wirklich ganz lange mitlesen willst, ob dein iPhone vielleicht immer kurz vor Ende mit dem Laden abbricht oder was auch immer du für Geräte hast. Ich finde schon, vor allem... Ja, es gibt ja so billige Akkus, wo sie sagen, das Ding hier hat 20.000 mAh Akkuleistung. So, und wenn du mit dem Ding einfach mal mitschneidest, wie viel da rauskommt und das immer schon bei 10 aufhört, weil da nichts mehr kommt, dann weißt du, da kommen halt keine 20.000 mAh raus. Das Gleiche gilt auch fürs Laden. Was ich nicht reinladen konnte, kann ich natürlich auch später nicht rausholen. Das heißt, so kann man seine El Cheapo Akkus mal durchtesten, ob die dann irgendwie das haben, was sie versprechen, oder ob er schon zu alt ist und mal sich den nächsten kaufen sollte und so weiter. Ja, also schicke Spielzeug, vielen Dank. Ist voll halt so ein Nerd-Tui. Wie gesagt, und Kabel würde ich vorher wirklich immer einmal durchkalibrieren, um zu gucken, wie gut die sind, weil, gibt's wirklich Schrott.
Also das heißt, ich kann das Kabel jetzt hier wieder reinstecken oder wie kalibriert das Kabel?
Dann steckst du das Teil in eine Quelle, der du vertraust, wo gleichmäßig Strom rauskommt. Dann drückst du das, na doch, dein Laptop haut ja gleichmäßig Strom raus. Das schwankt ja nicht hin und her. Dann gehst du jetzt da in das richtige Menü. Genau das. Hier siehst du, Referenz steht da. Du hast oben 514, bei mir steht jetzt da 513, als ich das mal gemacht hab. Das heißt, wahrscheinlich war das mein Laptop oder so. Du drückst jetzt hier lange. Klick. Und jetzt hat er bei Referenz deine Standard-Voltage ein paar Schritte übernommen. Und jetzt nimmst du sozusagen dieses Kabel hier, steckst das genau da rein, wo das Gerät vorher drin gesteckt hat, damit es die gleiche Stromquelle hat. Und steckst das Kabel jetzt aber hier in den Dings rein. So rum, ne? Genau. Und jetzt kannst du da in dem Menü genau sehen, der hat 0,177, ne, wo ist es da? Der hat gar keinen Voltabfall. Der ist also perfekt.
Voltabfall.
Ja, nennt man so.
Spannungsabfall.
Spannungsabfall, ja. Ja, Entschuldigung.
Jetzt ist sogar mehr aus irgendeinem Grund, ja.
Na dann schwankt dein Laptop doch ein bisschen hin und her. Du brauchst halt eine stabile Quelle.
Ne, ich glaub das Problem war, dass wir das kalibriert haben, als der Akku da dranhing und Strom gesaugt hat.
Na ja, verstehe. Nee, da muss man das noch einmal machen. Aber das Prinzip hast du ja verstanden, so geht das. Und ja, ist auf jeden Fall ein schickes Spielzeug.
Langes Zehr, ich hab ja mal Elektrotechnik studiert, ich verstehe das ja halbwegs.
Du alles kannst. Womitels, wenn jetzt keiner noch ein dringendes Thema hat, will ich sagen...
Ich mach mal den Rest fit nächstes Mal.
Ich dachte mal, das ist jetzt so schnell weggeballert, die Zeit ist ja ein Ding.
Ich sag nur kurz, Metacast, ich war Gast in einem anderen Podcast, wer den mal hören will, soll ihn irgendwie raussuchen. Metacast.
Metair oder Meta? Ah, du hast hier Meta geschrieben.
Dies und das ging auch wieder um Programmiersprache, nein nicht das mit dem Kaffee, das mit dem Eisbär, der davor.
Nehmen wir zur Kenntnis, warum auch immer man keine richtigen URLs in diesen Slack reindrängen kann. Dreckstein.
Dreckstein. Schreibst du das dann auch mit A?
Das Slack mag nicht in allen Belangen optimal sein, aber es gibt viel Schlimmeres. Ja, na dann können wir uns noch gegenseitig eine gute Nacht wünschen. Letty ist eh schon irgendwie abgetaucht.
Du siehst aber auch irgendwie gerade relativ...
Was?
Sein Auge.
Ich hab so ein Matschauge, ich hab hier irgendwie so eine Binderhaut.
Habt ihr das Time-Cover von Steve Bannon gesehen?
Der sieht da richtig schlimm aus.
Das musst du dir jetzt noch geben. Also nicht, dass ich sage, dass du jetzt so schon aussiehst, aber das Cover ist wirklich alles andere als vorteilhaft. Warum haben sie jetzt ein Magazin vielleicht da, wenn du da oben klickst? So ein Foto willst du nicht von dir auf einem der weit verbreitesten Magazine da haben.
Das ist schon auch interessant, wie sie den Trump jetzt schon mit seinen Befindlichkeiten ausspielen, oder? Also jetzt sagen sie mir die ganze Zeit, dass er nur die Puppet von diesem Bannon ist. Und was fängt da an jetzt der Trump? Nee, ich bin da schon selber. Das heißt, wenn er das so lange anhören muss, würde er den einfach nur schon deswegen rausschmeißen. Aber man kann ihn schon auch sehr fernstreuen. Genauso mit seinem Spicer. Der gefällt ihm jetzt ja auch schon nicht mehr so.
Musst du dir mal anschauen, den Clip. Das ist wirklich grandios, wie sie diesen Spicer nachgemacht hat. Das hat ja so richtig Implikation.
Dazu muss man ja erstmal wissen, wie der Spicer ist. Ich kenne ja den auch noch nicht. Das heißt, ich muss mir erstmal den eigentlich angucken.
Dadurch, dass jetzt in diesem White House halt, also ich glaube, dieses White House-Stuff, das besteht so aus 30 Prozent loyalen Trump-Nazis, aber zu 70 Prozent so teilweise aus Leuten, die so What's going on here?
Meinst du, so viele noch? Also sind schon alle rausgeschmissen? Ich dachte, da hätte der ganz schön gesäbelt nach dem, der da eingezogen ist.
Der kann nicht alle rausschmeißen, weil es einfach in der Kategorie von Volltrotteln, die ihm total ergeben sind, so viele Leute, damit kriegst du keinen kompletten White House-Stuff gefüllt. Also da ist einfach der Vorrat an Vollidioten, der ist einfach begrenzt. Also schon die mit der formalen Qualifikation auch diese Jobs dort auszufüllen.
Alle seine Typis, die der da gerade einlädt, haben keine Qualifikation. Das sind alles irgendwelche Öl-Milliardäre oder sonstwiegen welche Reichhosen.
Na die Anforderungen sind ja unterschiedlich je nachdem, was du da so tun musst. Tatsache ist, dass die Leak-Quote sehr hoch ist weil eine ganze Menge Leute auch so ein bisschen entsetzt sind, weil sie merken, dass dieser Trump offenbar wirklich einfach mental geschädigt ist. Also der ist einfach in seinem Narzissmus.
Hat Förderbedarf nennt man das?
Ja, vollkommen. Hat Förderbedarf.
Irgendjemand fragte gerade nach einem Link im Chat von dem Time Cover oder was? Spezifizieren Sie, solange wir so noch...
Hat der sich für das Bild tatsächlich so hingesetzt und das abgesehen, dass sie das so zeigen dürfen?
Also Stephen Colbert hat ja gesagt, People say that Steve Bannon calls all the shots. Und dann sagt er mit dem Time Cover, He's certainly taking all the shots. Oh, he looks like he's taking all the shots.
Die US-Late-Show-Szene ist derzeit sowieso hochgradig konsumierungwürdig.
Also Sommerlach werden wir dieses Jahr nicht haben. Kannst du mal davon ausgeben. Und wenn wir Pech haben, nächstes Jahr auch nicht.
Ich dachte, wir werden noch so lange Präsident ist, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja, du hast doch auch nicht geglaubt, dass das wird. Hab ich das nicht? Gleiche Fehler wie alle.
Ich hab das auch nicht geglaubt.
Hab ich mich dazu geäußert? Der geneigte Hörer kann das rausfinden. Aber ich kenn keinen, der geglaubt hat, dass der das wird.
Ich glaub, wir haben alle rumgeeiert, aber auch alle irgendwie nicht gesagt, dass wir das tatsächlich glauben. Also, naja.
Es ist alles nachhörbar. Und es sah ja auch so aus. Wenn man es einfach nicht glauben wollte, sah es nicht so aus, als wenn der gewinnt.
Liebt man die Filter rüber, Tim.
Also wie gesagt, jetzt ist erstmal Brexit.
Denen stimmt es ja auch. Er hat ja nicht die Mehrheit der Stimmen. Also ich meine, es hat keiner ahnen können.
Es ist ja in den USA ziemlich egal.
Du rechnest keiner.
Was ich sehr unterhaltsam finde jetzt, ist halt einfach die Liegequote im Weißen Haus. Die ist halt extrem hoch. Man kriegt am laufenden Meter Einschätzung von Situationen, von denen du in den Jahrzehnten vorher nie, auch nur im Ansatz irgendwas gehört hättest.
Wie mit dem Typen, wo sie meinen, wir zerstören seine Karriere?
Na, das ist ja eine Aufnahme gewesen von irgendwie...
Ja, anscheinend auch vergessen. Der Typ, der da irgendwie einen Senator ankackt, wie so eine, wie sagt man, so so eine... So eine Pässe halt so richtig und der Trump, der vergisst, dass seine Kamera läuft und raus sagt, ja wir zerstören seine Karriere. Hört sich an, aber der macht das glatt.
Geil fand ich.
Gespräche mit anderen Staatsmännern. Darüber gibt es dieses Telefongespräch, was er mit dem Australischen... Das ist ja nicht so, dass sie das Recording aufs Internet gekippt haben. Das ist ein Leak. Und solche Leaks gibt es jetzt am laufenden Meter die ganze Zeit. Das heißt, wir kriegen in Realtime diesen vollständigen mentalen Zerfall mit. Und in meinem Grundoptimismus hab ich halt schon das Gefühl, das kann nicht... Vielleicht überschätze ich diese Republikaner. Kann sein, dass die mittlerweile schon so dermaßen hirnzerfressen sind. Aber ich glaube auch da gibt es Leute, für die so ein bisschen noch so die eine oder andere Grenze existiert. Weil der Trump schon alle Grenzen überschreitet von dem, was die bisher eigentlich auch immer gesagt haben, was für sie akzeptabel wäre. Und an dem Punkt, wo die ihre Fette davon schwimmen sehen. Also es ist im Wesentlichen eine Frage, wie reagiert die Opposition? Wenn sie jetzt den Fehler machen und sich instrumentalisieren lassen und irgendwie anfangen hier mit brennenden Mülltonnen und gegen Polizisten Steine schmeißen, dann ist alles vorbei. Und wenn sie es schaffen, diesen intelligenten, zazifistischen, zurückhaltenden, wir sitzen uns irgendwie lustige Pussyheads-Protest, wenn sie den durchziehen, damit...
Das ist also genau das, was die Tochter von dem King geschrieben hat.
Vor allen Dingen müssen sie die ganzen Fails von Trump den gesamten Republikanern anlasten, damit die restlichen Republikaner sich im Zug zwangt sehen, sich von Trump zu distanzieren.
Weil sie halt mit ihm sterben.
Und sonst nicht wiedergewählt werden.
Weil Trump ist denen egal. Wichtig ist denen ihr Einfluss. Wenn sie sehen, dass ihr Einfluss mit der Unterstützung von Trump fällt, werden sie dem Trump die Unterstützung entziehen. Ich glaube jetzt auch nicht, dass wenn der Trump dann irgendwie weg ist, und ich weiß immer noch nicht so richtig, ob der jetzt sozusagen einen Unfall haben wird, oder ob der...
Nee, dann kommt der da, oder? Oder wer kommt dann?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Der Pence. Der ist noch schlimmer.
Der ist nicht schlimmer.
Ideologisch ist der noch schlimmer.
Vielleicht ein richtiger Nazi.
Vielleicht nicht populistischer, aber auf jeden Fall.
Er ist ein evangelikaler Christ.
Ja, das ist so ein normaler Hardcore-Republikaner.
Normal, wenn das schon jetzt normal ist heutzutage, ist ja das Problem.
Ja, aber bei dessen Netzwerk sind die Republikaner. Dessen Machtstruktur ist die republikanische Partei. Und der muss innerhalb dieser republikanischen Partei die Kompromisse eingehen, zu denen Trump sich nicht genötigt sieht, weil die ihm alle den Stinkefinger gezeigt haben, eine Woche vor der Wahl. Und dem das sowieso egal ist. Der hat sich seine Billionärs zusammen geschaufelt und seine Rechtsaußen-Nazis von den Webseiten. Alle, die ihm geholfen haben, alle, die ihm sozusagen Loyalität geschworen und auch bewiesen haben, die haben jetzt alle einen Posten. Wenn Pennstar ist, zudem haben die alle kein Verhältnis. Und der hat ganz andere Loyalitäten.
Wie sagt man, das ist House of Cards bei Sebum?
Danach werden wir ein unerträgliches, aber zumindest nicht vollkommen durch die Decke bekloppt abgehende Rechtsausleger White Supremacist-Scheiße erleben.
Naja, aber Bannon, solange der mit im Boot ist...
Der ist ja dann nicht mehr im Boot. Ich mein, wenn Trump geht, ist der weg. Der Pennstar hat dem nichts zu verdanken.
Ich seh Trump auch eher als Marionette, als der Macher.
Ja klar, aber er ist derjenige, der die Macht hält.
Da gibt's doch die Bilder, wo er genau der Ben im Hintergrund sitzt und vorne die Marionette hält, die das Trump-Gesicht hat. Da gibt's doch schon verschiedene Bilder von.
Ja sicher, naja, jetzt haben wir doch noch über Trump geredet.
Man soll auch nur noch 45 sagen.
Dieser 3 am Phone-Call ist so geil, wo er da mal nachgefragt hat, ob das jetzt gut ist, wenn der Dollar stark oder schwach ist. Und wen hat er gefragt? Seinen Security-Advise?
Seinen Verteidigungsminister.
Seinen Verteidigungsminister und der nur so, äh?
Oh weia, die Welt, ey. Die dreht sich weiter. Also Leute, hier, gebt nicht auf. Wir werden das schon irgendwie überleben.
Wie heißt denn? Waloshow?
Genau. Kauft den richtigen Kopfhörer.
Oder kauft Kabel.
Wir haben euch zwar nicht verraten, welche das sind. Thank you for coming and we'll see you soon.
Stopp den Flugzeug, ich habe mein Notbuch überprüft.
Meine Damen und Herren, ich werde dich jetzt verlassen.
Ich habe mein Notbuch überprüft. Ich habe es überprüft. Habt ihr mein Notbuch gesehen?
Lass nicht den Notbuck-Computer, den du wählst, einen von ihnen sein.
Ich habe mein Notbuch überprüft.